THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER. FOR ALL OF THE FOLKS. UP
THERE WE ARE STREAMING ONLY
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH YOUR
CAMERA THERE IS NO VIDEO TAPE.
DUE TO SOME TECHNICAL CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE STATE'S
CAPITAL BUT GOOD MORNING ANYWAY
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOULFUL DISTANCING. AND FEES
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY. ALL MEMBERS OF
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE AT
THE HEARING ROOM. THOSE
PROVIDING TEST MIGHT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING YOU. ASKING IF YOU WOULD
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT A ME
BEFORE YOU BECAUSE- ALL RIGHTY
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
BUTTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU WERE SEEN. ON THE
SCREEN. ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT SO
NECESSARY TODAY STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THEY WERE READY TO- ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN THE
HEARING ROOM I SEE SOMEONE HERE
TODAY TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHICH THE TESTIFIED
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS. ARE
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I CANNOT REPEAT
WE'RE ONLY STREAMING TODAY
THERE'S NO VIDEO. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND- THEN I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS THIRTY FIVE THIRTY ONE.
TO EIGHTY THREE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE-
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS WILL TAKE. A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE TO CALL
YOUR LIGHT NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
HE WILL BE A NEEDED HE WILL NOW
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU.
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU TOO MUCH MAKE YOUR
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING OR PRIOR TO YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING
THE HEARING. AS DISCUSSED. BUT
THAT MAY BE. REMOTE MEETING
SERVER. WOULD HAVE TO CONNECT
MADE. COMMENT WILL BE HER AFTER
. ALL DISCUSSION I. HAVE PRESENT
. LAST FOR. ANYONE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR
MASK ON COVERING YOUR NOSE AND
MOUTH. AT ALL TIMES- SENATE
MCGUIRE HAD TO CHECK A STEP OUT
FOR A SECOND SO WE WILL HOLD OUR
ESTABLISHING. A QUORUM. AT THE
MOMENT- FOR VOTERS ONLY
CALENDARS- THERE'S TWO ISSUES ON
THE VOTE ON THE CALENDAR THAT
ARE BEING TAKEN OFF- THE MATTER
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ON THE NATURAL
RESOURCE BAHNSON TECHNICAL
PROPOSAL IS BEING REMOVED FROM
THE VOTE ON A CALENDAR AND ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ONE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE TASK FORCE.
BOTH OF THESE PROPOSALS WILL BE
HEARD AT A LATER DATE- SO WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE TO OUR
DISCUSSION ITEMS WE'RE ON ISSUE
NUMBER NINETEEN ENTITLED
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PACKAGE IT
RELATED WILDFIRE PREVENTION THIS
IS A- IN THE BCPS WELCOME.
SECRETARY CRAWFORD- AND JESSICA
MORSE FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY MR. OCULAR WITH FINANCE
AND HELEN- KRISTIN WITH TE L.
A. L. NIGHT UNDERSTAND FOR THE-
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE WE HAVE.
THE ACTING DEPUTY. BUT DIRECTOR
FOR CAL FIRE OF THE CONSERVATION
CORES MR GEAR. GIRL TO CHEAT
WITH THE HELP- YES THE
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION CALLS
ALL THE CONSERVANCY'S AND THE
AIRPORT AND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCE BOARD CAN NO PR AND THE
IG BANK IN UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS-
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS SO WITH
THAT SECRETARY CROWFOOT GOOD
MORNING. THANKS SO MUCH YOU'RE
WHITE COUNTY AND SENATORS IT'S
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU AGAIN AND
MOST OF ALL RELEVANT TO THIS
HEARING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON TACKLING THAT
GROWING CRISIS OF WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY WERE GONNA
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT OUR
REQUEST TO YOU OR ONE ON ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF NEW
INVESTMENT IN FRONT PROACTIVE
ACTIONS TO REDUCE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE RISK I'M GONNA STEP
BACK CONTACT FOR DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY AND THEN TRYING TO JESSICA
MORRIS I DID DETAILS ARE ARE
PROPOSAL. SO WE OBVIOUSLY ALL
KNOW THAT THE LAST WILDFIRE
SEASON WAS REALLY CHALLENGING
FOR- THE WORST WILDFIRES IN THE
STATE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
YEAR HISTORY. OCCURRED LAST YEAR
. EIGHTY EIGHT HI WILDFIRES
ACROSS THE STATE BURNING TWO AND
A HALF MILLION ACRES. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY TO WILDFIRES PREDICT THE
AND CAL DOOR ACTUALLY TRAVELED
OVER THE CREST OF THE SIERRA
NEVADA SUMMIT INTO THE EASTERN
SIERRA. THOSE FIRES WERE
CHARACTERIZED BY FLAMES JUMPING
OVER FIVE HUNDRED FOOT CLIFFS. I
AM STARTING THREE MILE THE HEAD
OF THE FIRE LINE AND AREAS OF-
THAT THAT FOR IS BURNING AGAIN
TWICE IN THE SAME FIRE.
COMMUNITIES LIKE GRIZZLY FACT
PLOTS IN GREENVILLE- TRAGICALLY
DESTROYED DESTRUCTION OF OUR
UPPER WATERSHED IN THE SIERRA
THAT THE THOR'S OF 60% OF OUR
STATE'S DRINKING WATER. LOST
ABOUT 15220% OF OUR- THE WORLD'S
LARGEST GIANT SEQUOIAS OFF OVER
THE LAST TWO PIRACY THEM.
REMARKABLY THOUGH FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A DECADE NO IT'S THE
BILLION LIVES WERE LOST DUE TO
THE HEROISM OF OUR CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS AND OF COURSE OUR
MUTUAL AID FIREFIGHTERS.
REMARKABLE WE KNOW THAT BUILDING
A RESPONSE CAPACITY IN THE STATE
IN A CALIFORNIA FIRE CONTINUES
TO BE CRITICAL MORE FIREFIGHTERS
MORE EQUIPMENT MORE TECHNOLOGY.
INCLUDING IMPORTANTLY STOPPING
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL RELIEF TO
OUR WILDFIRE FIREFIGHTERS DURING
THE FIRE SEASON. BUT WE CLEARLY
ARE NOT GOING TO SIMPLY RESPOND
OUR WAY OUT OF THIS WILDFIRE
CRISIS YOU ALL HAVE LED THE WAY
POINTING OUT THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE PROACTIVE UPFRONT ACTIONS
TO REDUCE. THE RISK. DYSTROPHIC
WILDFIRE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. THE WAY I
WOULD TALK ABOUT IT IS WHILE OUR
WILDFIRE CHALLENGES GETTING
WORSE OUR INTERVENTIONS ARE
GETTING BETTER. WE SAW EFFORTS
LIKE STRATEGIC FUEL BREAK HOME
HARDENING AND PRESCRIBED FIRE
WORKING LAST YEAR. HE WILL BREAK
FOR EXAMPLE AROUND THE
COMMUNITIES O SOUTH LAKE TAHOE
AND POLLOCK PINES ALLOWED
FIREFIGHTERS TO TAKE A STAND TO
PROTECT NEIGHBORHOODS AND
PROTECT THOSE COMMUNITIES-
GRANDFATHERED IN THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING WHAT YOU'RE INVESTING IN
IS WORKING- WE HAVE A STRATEGY
THAT WE ARE FOCUSED LIKE A LASER
ON IMPLEMENTING. WE KNOW HOW
COLLECTIVELY TO BUILD WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. WITHIN COMMUNITIES
HOME HARDENING INDEFENSIBLE
SPACE AROUND COMMUNITIES- WITH
THE STRATEGIC FUEL BREAK ALLOW
FOR FIREFIGHTERS TO TAKE A STAND
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES AND
GIVING RESIDENTS TIME TO
EVACUATE. AND ACROSS OUR BROADER
LANDSCAPES TO LOWER THE
INTENSITY OF WILDFIRE. AND A
RESTORE FOREST HEALTH. NOW
STRATEGIES ARE NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL TOP DOWN FROM
SACRAMENTO ARE PROJECTS OUR WORK
HAS TO BE DRIVEN BY REGIONAL
PRIORITIES- BIG DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND PARTS OF OUR
STATE. AND THEY ALSO NEED TO BE
GROUNDED IN FINANCE AND WE NEED
TO ADAPTIVELY MANAGE BASED ON
SCIENCE. YOUR POINT THAT WE
ALWAYS MAKE IT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THIS ALONE- AND STATE
GOVERNMENT OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OWNS 50% OF OUR
FOREST LANDS THE STATE ONLY.
OWNS ONLY THREE WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN SUBSIDIZING WORK ON FEDERAL
LAND. IN AUGUST- TWENTY TWENTY
GOVERNOR NEW SOME SIGNED A
LANDMARK AGREEMENT WITH THE U.
S. FOREST SERVICE. MAPPING OUT A
TWENTY YEAR SHARED STRATEGY TO
IMPROVE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE.
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE FOREST SERVICE COMMITTING TO
BUY. TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES OF THE PROJECT A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROJECT BY THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND OF COURSE
THE STATE- PEOPLE LEADING
COMMITTING TO THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES A PROJECT. TO
MEET THESE GOALS ARE NOT SHARED.
STEWARDSHIP AGREEMENT WE RESHAPE
AND REVITALIZED THE STATE HOUSE
FORCE WHICH WE CALL THE WILDFIRE
AND FOREST RESILIENCE HALF
FORCED. AND DEVELOPING AN ACTION
PLAN WITH VERY SPECIFIC
MEASURABLE ACTION THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE. OUT TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK. HALF FORCED AND OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO TAKE THOSE
ACTIONS WAS CODIFIED BY SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SIX LAST YEAR. I
AND WE HAVE PROVIDED A WRITTEN.
IN SENSE TO ENSURE THAT THAT ACT
. OTHER TOP FORCE TO THE BILL
WILDFIRES. ACTUALLY PLACE. WE
WERE VERY GRATIFIED TO HEAR
ABOUT PRESIDENT BY PRESIDENT
HERE AT THE END U. S. FOR
SERVICE ANNOUNCED EIGHT. MORE
YEAR TEN YEARS. SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING FEDERAL INVESTMENT
AND FOCUS IN REDUCING WILDFIRE
RISK- ALONG ACROSS NATIONAL
BORDERS THE NOT GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT. WE KNOW THAT
SCALING UP INVESTMENT IS
ESSENTIAL IF WE ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR WE WILL TOTAL TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS AND WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. BY FAR THE LARGEST
INVESTMENT WE'VE EVER MADE ON
THAT FRONT. LAST YEAR'S
INVESTMENT THANK YOU ALL
CHAMPION THE AND GOT THROUGH THE
PROCESS IS WORKING. IF YOU
RECALL AT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS WAS SPLIT INTO TWO PARTS
. ALPHABET RUSSIAN THEY HAVE A
BETTER PART OF IT WAS- VERY
REMARKABLY APPROVED IN APRIL OF
LAST YEAR OLD AND BURLY ACTION-
BUDGET FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
THAT WAS ALL ABOUT FOCUSED ON
GETTING THE FUNDING OUT OF THE
DOOR. TO RIGHT SHOVEL READY TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK. I'M I'M
EXCITED TO READ THE REPORT THAT
THAT FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IT ON THE GROUND
IT LAUNCHED THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN NEW WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
PROJECT. IN LESS THAN A YEAR BOB
SOME OF WHICH IMPACTED THE LAST
FIRE SEASON SOME OF WHICH ARE
POOREST ACTING- THE **** AND
FIRE SEASON. A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES REALLY- MEETING PAUL IS
THAT A GREAT THING FOR. THE
APPLE FUNDED BY STATE COAST
OPENED. STOP DELETE SOULFIRE I'M
ONE OF ITS AYE EDGES IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. SAN DEGO
CONSERVANCY PUT TO WORK FUNDING
FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND TWO
HUNDRED LOW INCOME SAN DIEGO
HOMES OUR BUYER STEPHEN. AND THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY FUNDED PERSON WATCH
PROGRAM THAT FOUND ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS THAT WERE DESTINED TO
BE SENT OFF. IN THE SANTA MONICA. MOUNTAINS LAST INDEPENDENCE
DAY. IN ADDITION TO THAT. AT THE
WORKING DONE- ***- LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES THE SHIP BUSINESS
PRACTICE PRACTICE IT ENABLE THE
PROJECT TO HAPPEN MORE QUICKLY.
LEGISLATIVE CONTRACTING REALLY
ENABLED AT HAND THEY TURN AROUND
RATHER THAN A ONE YEAR
TURNAROUND FOR STATE PROCUREMENT
. HI MY THE BEEN REDUCE THE
SEVERAL RATHER THAN THE LONGER
SIX TO NINE MONTH PROCESS AND
INVOLVED FOCUSED ON SHARPENING
SHOVEL READY PROJECT. BUT EARLY
ACTION PLANNING WAS IMPORTANT AT
THE SAME TIME THE REST REST OF
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS APPROVED IN SEPTEMBER.
IS WAS DESIGNED TO INTENTIONALLY
CREATE A LONGER LINE OF FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS. ARE PRIORITIZED BY
REGION. GOOD NEWS THAT OVER TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE FUNDS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN COMMITTED OR A
HUNDRED ONE PROJECT AND GRANT.
IT PRETTY REMOTE BEFORE LAST AT
THE STATE'S ENTIRE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE BUDGET WAS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND LESS THAN A YEAR
COLLECTIVELY WORKING ACROSS
AGENCIES AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WE PUT. NEW SCALED
UP FUNDING TO WORK THREE TIMES
THAT AMOUNT INTO PROGRAMS. AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED WE'VE GOT
THIS REGIONAL FOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM WHICH IS
BUILDING CAPACITY IN THE REGION
SO WHERE YOU REPRESENT- TO BE
COUNTY THAT CITY THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT BUT
CONSERVANCY ARE COMING TOGETHER
TO IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
PRIORITY PROJECT- HARDENING IT
IS MAKING GREAT STRIDES THANKS
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF OCT FIVE
BAG GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND OTHERS.
WATCHING THREE PILOT PROGRAMS
INSTANTIATE GO LAKE AND SHOP THE
COUNTY. WE'VE GOT FINANCED BY
BEING PUT TO- AND I DON'T WEBER
FEDERAL FUNDING TO GET TO ARE
CRITICAL WATERSHED COVER BY LAW
REMOTE SENSING. AND WE'RE BACK
PRIVATE CATHOLIC IT'S FINE TO
APPROVE BY THE BEING JUST WEEKS
AGO- ALLOWED OPR TWO ONE A
SERIES OF HIGH PROJECTS FOR.
TWENTY BE IN STOCK OR HOW TO
READ HOW TO UTILIZE THIS. COMING
OUT OF POOREST. AND THEN LASTLY
THE COW DEDICATION REATMENT
PROGRAM OR CAL BTP I WHICH IS
ALL ABOUT STREAMLINING FOR
PROJECT. IS NOW IN PLACE AND
BEGINNING TO WORK ASCENTIAL A
LIKE A THREE IN ONE. LOCATION TO
GET- SPEAK FOR APPROVAL A WATER
BOARD APPROVAL INTERACTION
WILDLIFE APPROVAL AND WE'RE
SEEING A TOP TAKE. AND WEALTHY
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE TO BE
SIGNIFICANT UPTAKE OF CAL BGT.
OVERTIME WHERE WE WE'VE COME
FROM AND WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
AND IT POINT IS GOING TO. ONE
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS FORTY. PRETTY
REFER REMARKABLE- AND SO I
WANTED TURN NOW TO GET THE
GOVERNOR AS HARD. SECRETARY ON
THE PRIORITY TO TALK ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY SENATORS WE'RE
REQUESTING. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. IT SECRETARY-
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AND HELPING US ESTABLISH- AND
SCALE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUCH A SUBSTANTIVE
WAY I'M- WHAT ARE. LAST YEAR WE
HAD THOSE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS
WHICH WERE REALLY STRANGE. UP TO
A MUCH HIGHER. ACTIVITY AND
MOVING A HIGHER PACE. THIS YEAR
FROM ONE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS IN
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE IS DESIGNED
TO BUILD ON THOSE INVESTMENTS
AND TAKE US FROM A SPRINT. TO A
MARATHON PEACE AT THAT MUCH
HIGHER VOLUME AND LEVEL OF
ACTIVITY SO WE HAVE GONE FROM
SPRING CHANGE TO NOW SCALING AND
SUSTAINING AND MAINTAINING THIS
MUCH LARGER SCALE OF ACTIVITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT WERE
WORKING ON. THIS INVESTMENT-
NEARER THE INVESTMENTS WE MADE
LAST YEAR IT BUILDS ON THIS
FORTY PROJECTS THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT SECRETARY CLOSELY- WAYS
DETAILING SO WE ARE CONTINUING
OUR INVESTMENTS- ACROSS THOSE
DEBRIS FRIENDS OF FIRE
RESILIENCE SO ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE TO LOWER FUEL
INTENSITY SPECIFIC PROJECTS
ACROSS THEIR FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE'RE PLAYING FOR PROJECTS
ACROSS THAT LANDSCAPE LEVEL SO
THESE INCLUDE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
POOREST HEALTH GRANT PROGRAMS-
CONTINUE DIRECT INVESTMENT GRANT
PROGRAM FOR TRIBES I'M SPECIFIC
SUPPORT FOR SMALL COURSE OF
LANDOWNERS WHO MAKE UP ABOUT 26%
OF THE FOREST LANDS IN
CALIFORNIA- THE END FUNDING FOR
ENSURING THAT OUR STATE LAND
HOLDINGS HE'S REALLY PRECIOUS
HABITATS AND RESOURCES. THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS LOVE THAT DOES
CONTINUE TO BE MAINTAINED AND
PROTECTED. FOR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. SO WE ARE WE'RE
ACROSS THE RESULTS LANDSCAPE AND
LAYER RESEARCH ME FOR ON OUR-
THE INVEST ARE COME. THINGS LIKE
STE YOU'LL BRING- ESCAPE ROUTES
OVER ROW. I'M AND WORK AND THAT
A SO WE ARE CAN. AND INVESTMENT
OF THREE HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
. FOR PROGRAMS LIKE THE FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAMS LIKE
THE CAL FIRE- UNIT. YOU'LL BREAK
PROGRAMS AND LIKE OUR I
INVESTMENTS IN. THE FORESTRY
CORPS IN OTHERS THE CDC. WILL
HELP US ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT GOING ON
STRATEGICALLY AND COHESIVELY
AROUND COMMUNITIES. LAST ON A IN
IN HOME HARDENING DEFENSE SPACE
. SO WE ARE INVESTING FORTY
MILLION INTO PRO THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON OUR COMMUNITY
HARDENING ACROSS THESE AREAS
INCLUDING BUILDING ON THOSE
PILOT PROJECTS THAT ADD THE
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY BETWEEN
HOW FIRE AND HELLO YES WHICH
JUST LAUNCHED LAST YEAR. ON THE
ARE GOING TO BE DEMONSTRATING
DIRECT SUPPORT FOR LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AS WELL AS
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH. OR AND I
THAT YEAH TO MAKE THESE BUT
BASIC RETROFITS AND DO THAT
DEFENSIBLE WORK WE'RE ALSO
INVESTING IN THE STRUCTURE THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO. MAINTAIN THE
SCALE SMARTLY SAFELY AND IN A
WAY THAT CONTINUES TO INVEST IN
A WORLD JOBS AND COMMUNITIES SO
WE ARE GOING TO BE CONTINUING TO
INVEST- IN SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. OUR PROGRAMS TO
CONTINUE ON DURING OUR BROWN
DEALING GATHERING SUCH AS THE
FOREST INVENTORY PLOTS WHICH IS
WHY WE RETURN TO THE SAME- THE
OVER YEAR AFTER YEAR ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IS TO BE
ABLE TO ACT ON- THE IMPACTS OF
CHANGE OUR ON. ON SPECIFIC FORCE
AREA ALSO INVESTING IN RESEARCH
AND GRANT FUNDING AND THEN IN
CREASING OUR INVESTMENTS- FOR
SPATIAL DATA ACQUISITION AND
BUILDING ON THAT INTERVIEW THREE
YEARS AS WELL. WE'RE ALSO
CONTINUING OUR INVESTMENTS IN
THE FORCED ECONOMIC STIMULUS
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
UNLESS YOU CONTINUE INVESTMENTS
IN OUR PLAYERS WORKFORCE AND
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT GRANTS. TO
EXPAND INVESTMENT IN THESE PILOT
PROJECTS AT THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW- ESTABLISHED
STREAMLINING- WHAT HE BIOMASS
SECTORS. AND THEN THERE'S SOME
NEW INVESTMENTS- PROGRAMS IN
THAT. SECTOR AS WELL. YOU DAHLE
. FOR INVESTMENT IN WHAT DO YOU
. REMOVE WE ARE SEEING AS WE'RE
IN OUR I'M ACTIVITIES WITH
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND ALSO
POST FIRE RECOVERY WE'RE SEEING
GROWING INCREASES OF SLASH PILES
THROUGHOUT THE FOREST WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE DIRECT
FUNDING. TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW-
SUBSIDIZED REMOVING THOSE FLASH
FILES TO A BETTER DESTINATION
THAN JUST OPEN ILE BURNING IN
THE FOREST LAST YEAR WE SAW CAL
FIRE HAD TO DEDICATE ENTIRE OF
FIRE ENGINES CHIU ARMIES LARGE
SLASH PILES AND JUST AS A POINT
OF PERSPECTIVE THEY CAN
SOMETIMES. BE THE SIZE OF A
STRIP MALL- AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN BED
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY WE'RE
MOVING NOW SLASH PILES INTO YOU.
BUSINESS I BUSINESSES THAT CAN
BETTER UTILIZE THEM SO THAT THEY
DON'T JUST GET OPEN PILE BURNED
OR ARE TAKEN UP IN A FIRE.
THERE'S ALSO A NEW INVESTMENT
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INTO REFORESTATION THIS IS A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON THOSE CRITICAL
WATERSHEDS- AND REALLY TARGETED
RECOVERY OF CRITICAL WATERS.
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEN OUR NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVASTATED BY
THESE FIRES SO THE DIXIE FIRE
BURNED NEARLY ONE MILLION ACRES.
I'M IN D. I. IN THE FEATHER
RIVER WATERSHED WHICH IS THE
HEADQUARTERS OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND I SECRETARY CROWFOOT
MANSION ALSO THE CALIBER CHOIR
IN THE TAMARACK FIRE WERE
CREDIBLY UNUSUAL. IN THAT HIGH
INTENSITY BURNT IN UPPER
WATERSHED AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE HAVING TARGETED
INVESTMENTS TO HELP RECOVER AND
G. AND INVEST NOT ONLY DIRECTLY
IN REINFORCED ASIAN BUT ALSO THE
REFORESTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING NURSERIES. FEEDBACK
COLLECTION- AND THE WORK FORCE
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
PROVIDING CRITICAL WATERSHED AND
HELPING TO MITIGATE DROUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S QUICK AND
DIRECTOR COVERAGE AFTER THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES THE LAST NEW
PROGRAM THAT I WANT TO HIGH. IN
THE BUDGET. THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR MORE DEFENSIBLE SPACE FOR
STATE- AS AS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
THE LARGEST- INCREASED SPACE NAY
YOUR IT NOT BY FOOT NINE PLAN
WILL LAUNCH SO WE TO MAKE WE HAD
TO ONE OVER THE YEAR TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE PARK SPECIAL
WILDLIFE- AT THIS SCALP WHERE
YOU KNOW ANY OF THOSE FACILITY
THAT ARE IN THE WILL WE THAT
THEY HAVE- THAT TOOLS A QUICK-
YEAH SURE THE THEY ARE.
PROTECTED AND HAVE THAT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE BORDER I'D
STATE VISITOR CENTERS AND THE
LIKE SO WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR INVESTMENTS IT IS BUILDING
ON AGAIN WE SEARCH FOR THOSE
EARLY ACTION DOLLARS YOU GAVE US
TOOLS TO WORK QUICKLY ARE OUR
OUR DEPARTMENTS DELIVERED WE ARE
NOW WORKING ON CHANGING THAT
HIGH SCALE- AND THIS INVESTMENT
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THAT
OUR AT A MUCH LARGER PASTE-
AFFORD THE COMING YEARS TO
DELIVER CRITICAL WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE ACTIVITIES THAT WE
HAVE THAT OUT. TO WORK
CALIFORNIA THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK I'M I'M
SURE THE OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE-
MEMORIES DON'T NEED TO BE
REACHED. LAST MAY WHEN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE INCREASED YEARLY
FIRE I FUNDING BY A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS IN AN INCREASE
THE REGULAR FUNDING. BY A
QUARTER MILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO WE'RE WE'RE GLAD FOR
THAT UPDATE I KNOW MY MEMBERS
HAVE. QUESTIONS LET'S GO TO THE
FINANCE DEPARTMENT DO YOU HAVE.
THAT WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
EVERYBODY'S ROLE HERE IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN ADD. ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS OF THE
DECISIONS THAT YOU'VE MADE FOR
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION THE GENERAL
FUNDS FOR RESILIENCY IN THIS
YEAR'S PACKAGE. YES SIR DRIVE
ARE WITH PART OF FINANCIAL
SECTOR MEMBERS SO THIRTY KROPA
AND EVERY THIRD CARRY MORE THAN
A GREAT JOB OF HIGHLIGHTING THAT
THE GREAT EAGLE COMPONENTS JUST
REALLY WANNA HIGHLIGHT ARE WE
LOOKING AT THIS YEAR'S EVENT
THAT COMBINED WITH LAST YEAR'S-
IT. TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR SOME CRITICAL WILDFIRE
GOING PROGRAMS AND LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- WE ALSO. MADE B. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TO EUROPE A
TRULY CONTINUE. APPROPRIATION
WHERE THEY ARE NOW THAT BUILT
INTO THE BASELINE FOR A
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET ACROSS
SEVERAL U. PROGRAM SO IT BUDGET
CONTINUES. THAT DOESN'T PROVIDE
A BASELINE LEVEL UP- FUNDING- OR
WHAT PART OF THE PROGRAM AND ITS
KINDA LAUGHING ALTHOUGH- I KNOW
WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME- KIND OF
INITIAL FIGURES- BUT YOUR STAFF
AND AN ALLEY- ON. SOME OF THE-
ABOUT OF THE MONEY FOR MY YEAR-
BY IN N. B. IN LAST YEAR'S THAT
. BILL I KNOW A- APRIL ONE
RECORDING THAT RIGHT LITTLE BIT
DETAILED. OUR GOAL IS THAT TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME MORE D.
NUMBER ON- LAST YEAR IN THAT AND
BUILD OUT COME THAT APRIL ONE OR
FORTY DEADLINE. WELL SIR THE TO
SEVEN- BILLION HAS BEEN HIGH ON
RECENTLY IN. IS AN IMPROVEMENT-
OVER WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
JUST AGAIN FOR THE PUBLIC'S
REFRESHING THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WAS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT INSISTED
ON HAVING TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. FOR THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE GET THAT THRESHOLD
SO WE'RE NOT THIS IS NOT NEW
NEWS FOR US ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF DOING PREVENTION WORK. BEFORE
JUST PUTTING MONEY ON
SUPPRESSION WE HAVE A RICH
HISTORY WE'LL GET TO THAT IN THE
NEXT SEGMENT BUT- THE BALL
STARTED IN SUBCOMMITTEE TWO ON
TWO HUNDRED MILLION BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. LAST MAY WE
REPORTED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE A
PROGRAM FOR A BILLION DOLLARS ON
PREVENTION OVER FIVE YEARS THAT
IS. NOW THAT HAS EVER BEEN PUT
UP A DEADLY BEEN RESPONDED WITH
SIX HUNDRED MILLION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS A
BILLION THAT WE HAD WE HAD ASKED
TO BE PUT IN SO. LMAO CAN WE
HAVE YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE PERFECT
PROPOSED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
. I YES THANK YOU AT YEAR END
CENTERS MY NAME IS TELLING
CRISTINA THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU INVITING US TO
SPEAK TODAY. AND SO WE HAVE SOME
RECENTLYRELEASED A RECORD THAT
HAS SOME HIGH LEVEL ACCESS
MANAGEMENT CONDITIONS ON A
PACKAGE THAT'S REFLECTED REALLY
WELL IN YOUR AGENDA- AND ALSO
OUR REPORT IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE AND I'LL BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE IT AND TODAY I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME. I SO OVERALL WE FIND THAT
THE CONTINUED AND THE SAYS ON MY
VERY MITIGATION AND PREVENTION
REALLY HAS A LOT OF MERIT AND AS
YOU MENTIONED CHAIR THIS IS AN
AREA HUGE INTEREST FOR THIS
COMMITTEE- AND IT'S REALLY BEEN
AN IMPORTANT AREA FOR THE STATE
TO FOCUS ON GETTING. THE RECENT
VERY LARGE AND VERY SEVERE AND
DAMAGING WILDFIRES THE STATE'S
EXPERIENCE- SO WE DEFINITELY
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT- THIS AREA
AND A RANGE OF TAKES ACTIVITIES
IN THIS AREA BOTH. HELP MAKE OUR
NATURAL LANDSCAPES MORE
RESILIENT AND ALSO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES- PEOPLE'S HOMES AND
THEIR. BUSINESSES THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS. HOWEVER WE DO HAVE TO
NAMES. REALLY ON THAT WE CAN
LEGISLATURE SHE CAN SAY. AND
EVALUATE THIS BUT- PACKAGE I
SUPPORT WE RECKON THE LOGISTICS
CONSIDER THE TOLL FUNDING LEVEL
WELL AS THE OF PROGRAMS IN THE-
OF ITS PRIORITY. THAT ARE COMING
ON BACK. COMPANY OF PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING LEVELS AND IT'S REALLY
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
GONNA WANT TO WEIGH IN ON AND
BASED ON ITS PRIORITIES. I DID
THAT SO WE IDENTIFY SOME FACTORS
WE THINK ARE VALUABLE TO
CONSIDER- INCLUDING THE EXTENT
TO WHICH FRIENDS PROTECT STATE
ASSETS WHICH WE THINK IS A
WORTHY GOAL. AS WELL AS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. I'M SO
SECOND WE RECOMMEND. YOU TO FOR
ACTION ON THAT PACKAGE UNTIL
THIS SPRING WHEN ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
AND TO HELP INFORM DECISION
MAKING AND THERE ARE. A FEW
SPECIFIC PIECES OF INFORMATION
WE THINK WOULD BE. ESPECIALLY
HELPFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HAVE THOSE. FACILITATE ITS
DECISION ON. SOME PARTICULAR ME
THINKING THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
TO HAVE SOME MORE DETAILS ON THE
PROGRAM PROPOSED FOR FUNDING IS
FOR THE PACKAGE- SO WE KNOW THAT
IN A NUMBER OF CASES THERE'S
STILL LIMITED INFORMATION AT
THIS TIME ON THE SPECIFICS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. ON FOR
EXAMPLE AS WAS NOTED AND BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THERE ARE A FEW
NEW PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED AND HALF PACKAGES- THAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE MADE AS PART
OF THIS PACKAGE- FOR EXAMPLE THE
SEXY FOR THE TRANSPORTATION OF
WOODY BIOMASS. CAN YOU PRINT
THAT REFORESTATION AND
DEMONSTRATION FORCE FOR EXAMPLE-
OF THESE NEW PROGRAMS WE THINK
GENERALLY ADDRESS IMPORTANT AND
WORTHY ISSUES THERE JUST ISN'T A
LOT OF INFORMATION ON HOW THEY
ARE EXPECTED TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
ON THE RATIONALE FOR THE
PROPOSED SPECIFIC PROPOSED
FUNDING AMOUNT AND HOW THEY'LL
INTERACT WITH EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS WHICH MAY IN SOME.
CASES YOU SOME OF THE SAME THING
. WE THINK THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE- FOR THE FOR
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE. DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW HE WANTS TO. FREE OF
THESE PRO. AND WE DON'T NOTE
THAT THERE IS. PRINT OF THE THAT
PROGRAMS WERE FINDING AND YOU
HER ABOUT THAT YET OF COURSE THE
COMEDIAN. VERY INTIMATE. AWARE
OF THAT OU PACKAGES THAT WERE
APPROVED LAST. YEAR AND THIS.
FOR BY. IN MANY CASES A SIMILAR
PROGRAM. OR THE AND HE THE SAME
PROGRAM EXPENSE AT THE SAME
PROGRAM- AND- HE SAYS THERE'S
LESS. AND ON THE OUTCOMES OF
THAT IS THAT FINDING BECAUSE
REALLY YEAH I WAS. PRETTY
RECENTLY THAT A LOT OF THAT
FINDING- WENT OUT THE DOOR. I'M
SO AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE THERE
IS THAT A REPORT THAT'S
ANTICIPATED TO BE AVAILABLE IN
APRIL. AND THEN WE HOPE THAT
WILL HELP ON RIGHT EVEN SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
OUTCOMES AND THE STATUS OF THE
EXPENDITURE OF THOSE FUNDS WHICH
CAN HELP. DECISION MAKING. I
WANT TO DEDICATE MORE MONEY IN
YOU KNOW PROGRAMS THAT HAVE-
ATTRACT OF GETTING MANY THE DOOR
MORE FOR AND SO IF WE SEE AFTER
THEM FOR ON I'M KIND OF HOW
THOSE ARE ARE GETTING MONEY OUT
ON THE CAN HELP INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M THIRD. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGACY CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVE TO IT YOU FUNDING
PLAN- AND I AS WITH MANY- VERY
CONTINUOUS. OF THAT G. AT AND-
TRAITS. BUT THE GENERAL FUND. A
REAL PROPOSED JUST FOR A TWO
YEAR. WE THINK THERE'S A TRADE
OFF AND CHALLENGES THAT APPROACH
ON THIS. SOME ACTIVITIES REALLY
REQUIRES SUSTAINED ONGOING
BINDING THEY'RE JUST NOT ONE AND
DONE TYPE OF THING. OTHERS ARE
BEING FUNDED BY THE TEACHER
ASKED BY THEIR CAP AND TRADE.
BUT THE MINIMUMS ARE PROPOSED TO
BE FUNDED- FROM GENERAL FUND-
AND IF YOU THINK YOU THINGS LIKE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. THAT THINGS
THAT- YOU WERE VEGETATION GROWS
BACK. AND YOU REALLY MAY NEED
SOME SOME ONGOING. ACTIVITIES SO
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
THAT COULD BE GOOD CANDIDATES
POTENTIALLY FOR SOME LEVEL OF ON
GOING FUNDING. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS- WHERE
THERE ISN'T A LOT OF DETAIL- I%
FOR A LOT OF INFORMATION YET
THEY'RE JUST GETTING GOING. FOR
EXAMPLE. I'M DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE. FUNDING WOULD BE FOR
THAT SECOND YEAR THE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR YEAR. I'M
GOING TO TAKE A PROGRAM THAT
COULD. MERIT WHAT YOU'RE FINDING
POTENTIAL IN THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER- HOW MUCH MUCH
DIFFERENT NEXT YEAR SO. I'M WE
THINK YOU COULD CONSIDER OTHER
APPROACHES TO THIS YEAR ANY
PLAN. I'M FOURTH WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE SUCH AS
WHERE YOU GUIDANCE TO FOR
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION. AS
RELEVENT AND WE IDENTIFY A
COUPLE PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
REGIONAL FORCING PARK PASSED THE
PROGRAMS. AND THE DEFENSE OF
DEFENSE CREATE SPACE PROGRAM
EXCUSE ME. I'M THAT WE THINK
COULD BENEFIT FROM SUCH GUIDANCE
BASED ON SOME RECENT PROGRAM
EVALUATIONS AT OUR OFFICE
CONDUCTED. I'M AND THEN FINALLY
WE'D RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
CONTINUE ITS OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES AND AS AS I KNOW BEEN
A BIG. AREA OF INTEREST IN
OVERSIGHT LEGISLATURE READING
THAT'S REALLY VALUABLE. GIVEN
HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
HAS BEEN SPENT IN REALLY GIVEN
THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE THE
LEGISLATURE GONNA. PUBLIC ENEMY
CONTINUING TO TACKLE I WANTED TO
DEDICATE FUNDS TO IN THE FUTURE.
JUST PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
GET LESSONS LEARNED. HOW ARE
THINGS GOING. WAY WAY THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE I THINK- AS AS A
WHOLE AND TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THESE ARE- OPERATING
DEFECTIVE. AND EFFICIENT MANNER
SO HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS ALSO
IF. I KNOW I THINK THERE'S A
SECOND. MISS ROY CAN WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT KASKY HERE
NINE YEARS MCGUIRE STERN HERE.
WE HAVE CORPS MISSES THE
ABOLITION FROM. LET'S GO TO THE
MUCH PUBLICIZED AGREEMENT WITH
THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
REMOVE A HUNDRED. OR MILLION OR
THREE MILLION ACRES OF FOREST
LAND- IN WHICH SET A DATE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHERE ARE WE
TODAY HOW MUCH OF OUR RESOURCES
. ARE ARE BEING USED IN
ACHIEVING THAT GOAL AND WHAT IS
THE ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT YOU WOULD NEED TO GET TO.
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
AS PART OF OUR SHARE. YEAH I
THINK. THEY'RE ALL TAKEN I THINK
IT'S CRACK AT PROVIDING CONTACT
AND I JUST LOOK AT BY. ANY OTHER
DETAIL THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE. SO
I'M OUR PERSPECTIVE THIS MILLION
ACRES I SHARED TARGET IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT NORTHSTAR AND
INDICATE DOES THE SCALE OF. OF
WORK THAT WE WANT TO DO ACROSS
THE STATE. IT'S REQUIRING STEPS
TO A- ONE OF WHICH ARE CREATING
A- CONSISTENT CENTRALIZED
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM AND DEFINITION
OF PROJECT. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE
ALPIREZ OUR STATE FORESTRY
DEPARTMENT HAS FOR SOME TIME
BEEN WORKING ON PROJECTS FOR
OTHER REASON DECADE. PART OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
TARGET IS CHEN SIGNIFICANTLY
BROUGHT IN THE AMOUNT OF GROUPS
I. ADVOCATE WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT ARE WORKING ON THAT
SO. THANK YOUR STATE CONSERVANCY
STATE PARKS- THE DEPARTMENT
ADDITION WILDLIFE. AND EACH OF
THOSE ENTITIES THAT DOESN'T HAVE
NECESSARILY THE SAME SYSTEM FOR
TRACKING PROJECT AND SO. I SHARE
I WOULD SAY THAT SWITCHES I'M
NOT ABLE TO GIVE YOU A NUMERIC
NUMBER. TODAY BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT. WE VERY MUCH RECOGNIZED
BEST TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE COMMITMENT OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND YEAH PROJECT
ACRES UP FOR THE STATE AND THE
DEATH. OR DEVELOPING THAT- THAT
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM REALLY
BUILDING UP HELP I RESPOND ASIAN
AND THEN ENSURING THAT THE OTHER
ENTITIES WERE WITH IN THE STATE
I- CAN ACTUALLY PLUG INTO THOSE
PROJECT ACRES AND THEN. AND THEN
AND THEN WORK THROUGH OUR TASK
FORCE REALLY WORKING THROUGH.
HOW WE ACCOUNT FOR EXAMPLE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PROJECTS
COMPLETED BY UTILITIES OR YOU
KNOW COMMERCIAL FORESTRY. I'M SO
THIS IS A QUESTION THAT THAT WE
EXPECT TO BE CONTINUE TO BE
ASKED AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE-
YOU KNOW A MORE PRECISE ANSWER
FOR HERE IN COMING MONTHS. AT
THANK. IN STANDARD UP THE A COW
FOR THE PROJECT THAT ARE UNDER.
TO THEY CAN GUESS THE OTHER
GROUP HERE IS OUR- PARTNERS IN
THE THERE'S P. THAT ARE IN
INTERESTED IN BIO MASTERS. THAT
ORANGE IN BY CHAR THERE'S PEOPLE
ORDER INTERESTED IN IN CHIPPING
THEIR PEOPLE INTERESTED IN IN
WONDERING YEAH THEY WANT THEY
THEY WANT TO ASSIST CALIFORNIA
IN THE THINNING OF THEIR FOURS
AND EVERYBODY HAS. EVERYBODY'S
ON THE FOOD CHAIN A LITTLE-
DIFFERENTLY SO THERE IS A
MOSAIC. AT LEAST IN MY MIND
THERE'S A MOSAIC THAT SAYS HOW
DOES IT HOW DO WE ACHIEVE THAT
YOU KNOW FIRST. YOU NEED TO THIN
THE WINDER SAID THIS IS A TICKET
SOME OF THESE AREAS THAT NEED TO
ACTUALLY GET IN SO THAT YOU CAN
GO NGUYEN AND DETERMINE WHICH
TREES NEED TO BE REMOVED. AND
BEFORE YOU EVEN GET THE
PRESCRIBER ANSWERS PRESCRIBED
BURNS ARE AFTER YOU'VE HAD A
TREATMENT AND I KNOW. EVERYBODY
ON THIS CALL UNDERSTAND STAT-
BUT- BUT THE FOOD CHAIN I GUESS
IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
SAID YOU KNOW THIS COMMITTEE.
HAD LAST YEAR SUGGESTED HAD IN
THE BUDGET TEN MILLION FOR
THROUGH REMOVING BIO MASS FROM
THE CHAMBERS THAT WAS TAKEN OUT
BY THIS ADMINISTRATION AND THE-
BUT JUST SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
WE'RE GLAD TO SEE IT BACK. BUT I
THINK MY COMMENT WAS PROBABLY A
MORE APPROPRIATE FIGURE WAS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING BECAUSE THAT'S
THE FIRST STEP IN GETTING. THE
CREATING THOSE TIMBER DEPOTS
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE OLD K.
MARKS WHEREVER THESE SHOPPING
CENTERS WERE ALL THIS PRODUCT IS
GOING THROUGH SO CAN YOU. TELL
US A LITTLE BIT THERE. ABOUT
WHAT GLOBIS IS DOING. WHAT YOU
WERE- HI MATE CATTLE. FUND HAD
THE FUNDS HAVE A GONE IN BUT
WE'RE THE PER. INTO FORESTRY OR
- BIOMASS. OR OF PRODUCTS
ECOSYSTEM HOW'RE WE GETTING OR
PARTNERS GIVING THEM GRANTS TO
RAMP UP SO THAT THEY BECOME THEY
GET THEY GET IN THE WITH THE
WORK FLOW. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION AND- AND IT'S
REALLY VITAL. THAT WE ENSURE
THAT WHILE WE'RE DELIVERING
RESILIENCE FOR CALIFORNIA IT'S
ALSO WE CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT
INCREASING THE ENTIRE SORT OF
WOOD PRODUCTS- A INDUSTRY AND
SECTOR AND THAT'S EVERYTHING
FROM SORT OF TRADITIONAL LUMBER-
CHU INNOVATIVE WOOD PRODUCTS.
AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENTS WE MADE LAST YEAR
AND WE WANT WE WANT TO BUILD ON
THIS YEAR THAT ARE REALLY
STARTING TO BE VERY DELIBERATE
ABOUT ENSURE ENSURING THAT THAT
SPEED STOCK SUPPLIES WHAT WE
CALL IT SORT OF WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH THE WAR AND HOW DO YOU GET
WHAT OUT OF. THE FOREST THAT'S
OVERSTOCK HOW DO YOU GET WHAT
OUT OF SLASH PILES HOW DO YOU
GET THAT BURKE POST FIRE- LLOYD
EACH INTO EIGHT AS A WHOLE AND
FEEDSTOCK SUPPLY CHAIN SO THAT
THEN DRIVES- AN ECONOMY. WHICH
BEGAN OF NEEDS ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
ECOLOGICAL GOALS BECAUSE IT IS
ALWAYS BETTER- IT'S YOU HAVE A
DESTINATION FOR THIS RATHER THAN
HAVE IT. IN A FIRE OR OTHER
ELDRIDGE SO HERE'S A COUPLE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW THE CLIMATE CATALYST
ONE OF FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS I'M EASE AVAILABLE NOW-
JUST APPROVED BY THE I. BANK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
GETTING THAT THROUGH LAST YEAR.
AND IT IS AVAILABLE TO GIVE
LOANS AND GRANTS OR LOANS AND
LOAN GUARANTEES ME TO KNOW OUR
BUSINESS. THAT ARE WORKING ON
WHAT INNOVATION AND TRADITIONAL
TRADITIONAL OUT WHAT PRODUCTS AS
WELL SO ANYTHING THAT IS
SUPPORTING A BUSINESS THAT CAN
SUPPORT THAT SUPPLY CHAIN OR
SOMEBODY NEEDS BUSINESS CAPITAL
EQUIPMENT- THEY CAN GET A LOWER
LOAN GUARANTEES. FROM THE BANK-
SO THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING TURNED
AWAY THEY'VE BEEN TURNED AWAY
BEFORE BY COMMERCIAL BANKS SO
THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM
TRADITIONAL SAWMILLS CHINO-
GEOTAGGING YOUR MASTER NUMBER
FACILITIES- AND INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTS THAT CAN CONVERT THAT
WOODY MATERIAL INTO. NATURAL GAS
OR WHAT. REPLACEMENT SO. I CAN'T
FIND IT. FOR TO HELP. GROW ANY.
THIS IN THE SACK. WE GOT TYLER I
- OPR. THAT ARE THE ONES FINE
PILOTS THAT ARE WORKING ON.
STOCK OF WIDE CONTRA. SO ARE
TRYING TO ACCURATE. EACH I'LL
COME OUT OF SO WE- SLASH PILES
I'M- COMING OF THE SMALLER
CRIMES- IN REGION AND BE ABLE TO
SAY HOW WE- GIVE OUT TENURE SO.
OF GREEN. SHOULD BE SPACE AS SO
THAT THEY CAN ALONG TERM. TO AND
KNOW THAT THEY CAN BUILD UP
THEIR- ONE PRODUCTS CAMPUS-
BECAUSE THEY CAN GET BEING. TEN
YEARS THE STOCK SUPPLY. AND THAT
I. THAT'S IN COMP. WERE ALSO
INVESTING IN A GREAT FROM FOR A
FORCE TO. AND THE TO. I WAS
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS LAST YEAR WE
WERE MORE THIS YEAR- WITH CAL
FIRE THAT'S IN PROGRAM SO. THE
I'D THAT IS JUST GETTING ONE
THOSE ARE GETTING THE DOOR. AND
SO THAT'S- TO BE ABLE TO GROW
WORK FORCE TRAIN THE RIGHT
PEOPLE I'M A- FROM. FRUIT LIKE A
PROGRAM INVESTED SHASTA COLLEGE
THAT TRAINS- THAT TRAINS I HEAVY
MACHINE OPERATORS- UNLESS YOU
ARE PROGRAM LIKE THE CHIPS
PROGRAMS I'M IN THIS YEAR AND
THAT IS TRAINING- TRIED EIGHT
DIFFERENT TRIBES. I'M IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
THEY BECOME THE FUELS CREWS- THE
IN IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THAT
IS NOW EXPANDING. THE ABOUT.
ALSO CREATE A BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT I GRANT AS WELL. SO
THAT IT THE BUSINESS ISN'T QUITE
RIGHT. FOR MORE ON THE BANKS.
THEN THEY CAN. GO TO. TRIAL YOU
TO GO TO HELP GETS. TO THEIR
BUSINESS. STARTING A SMALL
BUSINESS I'M THAT WERE WANTING
TO MAKE SURE COVER AB ASPECT OF
ENTIRE SO. INSURANCE DECENT BASS
THAT YOU'RE ON THE- YOU TO LIVE
FIRESTONE. ARE ALSO. BETTER
STREAMLINE. TO REDUCE THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT. ON THE CHOIR RECENTLY
WHILE CREATING IT SUPPORTING
MORAL ACCOUNT- BUT WHILE WE'RE
DOING RESILIENCE. ECONOMICS
BURGER KING BOB WE'VE GOT I BE
ON THE ON THE CALL MISTER CALLUM
OR- ADLER- TELL US I MEAN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SEEMS TO BE ME
FROM MINISTRY. IT MAY IT'S THERE
WE JUST HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT IT
IS THESE TARGETS YOU KNOW ARE WE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO MUCH LUMBER
PRODUCTION RIGHT NOW OR WE COULD
DOUBLE THAT. WE TRIPLING DEBT
QUADRUPLING THAT BUT WHAT WE
DOING WITH THE BIOMASS NUMBERS
OF TARGETS BUT TELL SOMETHING
ABOUT. THE GRANT PROGRAM WE KNOW
THAT THE- PEOPLE CAN APPLY FOR A
LOAN THAT'S THAT'S GREAT BUT
SOME OF THESE FOLKS OTHER THAN
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND I
KNOW THAT HASN'T REALLY LAUNCH
BUT THESE BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS. WHAT'S THIS IS ONLY
THROUGH CAL FIRE OCCURS AT ALSO
THROUGH THE AYE BANK. FOR KIDS
GRANT PROGRAM IS THROUGH CAL
FIRE AND- AND WE DO HAVE CAL
FIRE ON THE CALL TODAY OR I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT- THE OUR COLLEAGUES
THAT KOBE IS AND I CAN TELL YOU
MORE ABOUT THE CLINIC CATALYST.
AND ALSO THESE- FEEDSTOCK SUPPLY
PROGRAMS I THINK ONE OF OUR
GOALS IN THE ADMINISTRATION AT
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE BOTTLENECKS
THAT YOU JUST ARTICULATED IS
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
IMPORT LUMBER WELL WE HAVE A
GLUT IN THE ONE OF THE BIG
BOTTLENECKS HAS BEEN MIL
CAPACITY. AND SO- AND YET IF WE
CAN INCREASE. THAT MILL CAPACITY
FOR. WE HAVE A GRANTED THIS YEAR
VATICAN. THAT STAB A SMALL MILL
IN. CRESCENT MILLS FIVE MY FROM
. THAT MAY IS NOW TO. ON THE
WALL FROM. WHAT FROM. ONLY
DRIVING AT FIVE MILES TO
CRESCENT MILLS AND THEN
RETURNING IT TO GREEN BELT TO
HELP YOU CAN FIND AND TO
SUPPORT. THE RECONSTRUCTION OF
THAT COMMUNITY AND AGAIN THAT
MIL IS HELPING US IMPROVE OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT. SO THE I THINK
IS REALLY HELPFUL IN EXPANDING
THE CAPACITY HAPPY TO TURN. TO
THEM- TO TALK ABOUT SORT OF HOW
WE CAN EXPAND CAPITAL EQUIPMENT
AND- IN CALIFORNIA CAN ANSWER OR
I CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THE- THE GRANT PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY. I THANK LISTA
WHAT'S BECAUSE I'M SURE. I GOT A
COUPLE OF MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE PLENTY OF-
MILLS HAVE BEEN. NOT RUNNING A
TO PASS. JUST CLOSE DOWN THERE
THEY'VE BEEN SHUT DOWN FOR ME
THE LEGACY. WE HAVE SO PLEASE
ENLIGHTEN US. YES HI. GTECH
EXACTLY DIRECTOR- SO WE'VE BEEN
THE LAST MONTHS- UP THE COMIC.
FIND THE FUNDS STATUTORY FOR THE
PROBLEM WORSE BY THE ON
SEPTEMBER THIRD. WAVES MEDIALLY
SET UP A WEB PAGE TO RECEIVE
POTENTIAL ENQUIRIES FINANCING
OPPORTUNITIES- WE JUST AS A-
SMART POINTED OUT WE JUST HAD
OUR- KIND OF CATALYST FINANCING
PLAN AS REQUIRED BY STATUTE. IN
ADDITION TO THAT PROGRAMS
FINANCING CRITERIA AT THE END OF
JANUARY- WE STARTED DOING A
MARKETING AN OUTREACH CAMPAIGN-
AT THE END OF JANUARY. AND WE'RE
JUST STARTING TO GO THROUGH
INITIAL ENQUIRIES UP WHICH WE
RECEIVED ABOUT FOR YOURSELF-
AND- IN THAT I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
THERE'S ANYTHING. IMMEDIATELY
DISTINGUISHABLE ON. PROJECT
SITES- THE- FOREST BIOMASS- IN
THOSE BACK. THEIR SON AND- A
DANCE MALES SPACE AND THERE'S A
DIFFERENT CAT. IN WE'RE JUST.
HAD A MEETING ON MONDAY TO WORK
THREE. A AND START THOSE KIND.
SO I THINK WE'RE AT THE STAGE OF
DEALING WITH PROJECTS. IS AND-
LENDERS IN THIS SPACE BECAUSE
THAT DO YOU KNOW THAT THE ONE
THING WE LIKE TO SEE FOR THE
PROGRAM IS THAT WE- THAT WE
CAN'T PROJECTS AND BUSINESSES
THAT CAN SUCCESSFULLY REPAYING
THEIR LOANS. SO THAT THE PROGRAM
OF ALL IN ADDITION IT'S A GROUP
POINTS TO THE CAPITAL MARKETS
THAT THESE ARE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE. VIABLE ECONOMICALLY FOR
THEM TO PROVIDE CAPITAL TO AS.
WELL GIVE US A BREAK DOWN OF THE
- OF YOUR TALK TO HOW MUCH IS IT
THE FOR RESULT. YOU KNOW VIDAK
WHAT IS IT IN YOU KNOW HYDROGEN
CATALYST OR SOME OTHER THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS UNDER YOUR- IN IN
THE AYE BANK THAT YOU GUYS ARE.
POTENTIALLY COLLECTING GRANDSON
WHICH IS HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
JUST WHAT FOREST. FORESEE
RELATED LOANS AND GRANTS. I'M I
WAS SO I'D LIKE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THE SPECIFIC SO OF THOSE
FORTY ENQUIRIES THERE'S ABOUT
TEN HIGHER PRIORITY ONES THAT
WORK FOCUSING ON THEN THERE'S A
BREAKDOWN WITHIN THEIR THAT SORT
OF A SUBSET OF THOSE SO LET ME
GET BACK TO YOU ON THE
SPECIFICS. OKAY- LET'S GO TO.
CENTER DOLLY HAS COUPLE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AYE I'M GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME THIS MORNING
BECAUSE I WANT TO JUST. SHARE-
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF WORKING ON
. THIS THIS ISSUE SO LAST YEAR
WE HAD THE DIXIE FIRE IN THE
CALDOR FIRE WHICH WERE BOTH IN
MY SENATE DISTRICT AND I WANT TO
JUST GIVE YOU PERSPECTIVE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO. I WAS ON WHAT
THEY CALL THE QUINCY LIBRARY
GROUP WHICH WAS A- IT WAS LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTALIST IT WAS TO
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND
CONGRESSMAN WALLY HERGER DID A
NET- FEDERAL. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO DO- A PILOT
PROJECT IN ON THAT LASSEN
NATIONAL FOREST THE PLUMAS
NATIONAL FOREST AND PART OF THIS
YEAR BILL DISTRICT OF THE-
FORCED. WE PASSED LEGISLATION
FEDERALLY TO DO MOSAIC
FIREBREAKS THROUGHOUT THE FOR SO
THAT WE WOULD HAVE NO FIRES
BIGGER THAN EIGHT THOUSAND ACRES
AND WE GOT HELD UP IN COURT
MOSTLY BY NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS STOPPING ARE PROJECTS
THAT WE NEVER REALLY COMPLETED
THAT. TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER.
THE WATERSHED HAS BURNED. THE
DIXIE FIRE BURNED TREES THAT
WERE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
YEARS OLD ON THE COLLINS PINES
PROPERTY. I ALSO SPENT SEVEN
YEARS ON THIS YEAR IN ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY BEFORE I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE WORKING ON. MAKING
MY- COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR AS FIRE RESILIENT SO. I
JUST WANT TO LAY THAT OUT FOR
YOU I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU-
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A HUNDRED YEAR. POLICY
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEAR OF.
STOPPING FIRE IN THIS YEAR'S
THAT'S NOT NATURAL THAT'S
MILLION COST. ON TOP OF CLIMATE
CHANGE SO WE HAVE A FORCED IT
IS. COMPLETELY OVERGROWN I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU I'M GONNA TRY TO.
DRAW A PICTURE FOR YOU. DIDN'T
THE LASSEN NATIONAL FOREST
BURDEN GROWS TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION BOARD FEET EVERY
YEAR. THEY HAVE THINNED OR CUT.
LESS THAN TWENTY MILLION EIGHT
TWENTY MILLION BOARD FEET. SO
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT FORCES
CONTINUALLY GROWING ALL THE TIME
AND IT'S STRESSING THE TREES WE
HAVE BARK BEETLE ISSUES WE HAVE
ALL THOSE ISSUES SO I WANT TO
OUT THE PICTURE OF THE- SIZE OF
THE- PROBLEM WE HAVE IN THIS
YEAR'S. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE FIRES LIKE THE
DIXIE AND THE CALDOR. INTEL WE
DO. MANAGEMENT NOW WHY CAN'T WE
DO MANAGEMENT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TODAY IS
MAINLY- PACIFIC INDUSTRIES AS A
FEW. OTHER PRIVATE. THAT
FACILITIES THAT DO MANUFACTURING
OF LUMBER. WE'VE TRIED SO WE'VE
LOST SEVERAL MAYBE FIFTY OR
SIXTY BIOMASS STAND ALONE
BIOMASS PLANTS THROUGHOUT THE
SEARS AND THE REASON WE DON'T
HAVE THOSE BIOMASS PLANTS TODAY
IS BECAUSE- THEIR POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS. WERE NOT EXTENDED BY
THE UTILITIES BECAUSE THEY CAN
GET SOLAR AND WIND AT A CHEAPER
RATE FOR RENEWABLESSO I HAVE
POWER PLANTS SITTING IN CHESTER
I HAVEN'T I USED TO HAVE AN ALL
OUT THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT THAT
ARE NOT RUNNING SOME OF THOSE
ARE TRYING TO BE RE PERMITTED.
TO COME BACK ONLINE. SO THERE'S
PLENTY OF MATERIAL OUT THERE BUT
NO PLACE TO TAKE IT. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING WITH ALL THE MONEY
THAT YOU THIS LAID OUT WITH HIGH
BANK THE REASON WE HAVE TO HAVE
AYE BECAUSE BECAUSE A PRIVATE
LENDER WILL NOT LAND. AND YOU
WANT TO THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE A
CONTINUOUS SUPPLY OF MATERIAL.
TO DO THE BUSINESS MODEL. NOW TO
MY QUESTIONS. I WANT TO ASK THE
SECRETARY AND I WANT TO PREFACE
THIS WAS SAYING THIS IS TOUGH
THIS IS NOT EASY TO DO BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO AGENCIES. MANAGING
THE LANDSCAPE NUMBER ONE THE
LARGEST AGENCY IS THE FEDERAL
FOR SERVICE. NUMBER TWO IS YOUR
DEPARTMENT AND THE SECRETARY
RESOURCES FOR THE REST OF IT. SO
MY QUESTION IS. HOW ARE WE GOING
TO GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
WORK WITH US DID MANAGE THESE TO
GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE CARE. OF A-
THE- PRODUCT IS COMING OUT- SO I
THIS IS A POLICY QUESTION
BECAUSE WE CAN THROW MONEY AT IT
ALL DAY. AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM UNTIL WE GET
THE POLICIES. OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE ON THE
SAME PAGE SO THAT'S MY FIRST
pSENATOR AND I REALLY RESPECT HIM
SETTING THE CONTACT THEM I THINK
I'D SAY I LARGELY AGREE WITH
WITH THE WAY THAT YOU FRAME IT
WHICH IS WE HAVE TO GET MORE
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES ACTIVELY
MANAGING OUR LANDSCAPES AND TALK
THROUGH YOU KNOW A RANGE OF
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
YOU KNOW RESTORING. A PRESCRIBED
BY A- AND YOU KNOW UNTIL WE
SCALE UP. CATASTROPHIC FIRE REST
YOU KNOW REMAINS REALLY HIGH-
YOU HEARD JACK MISS MORRIS TALK
TECHNIQUE SECRETARY MORRIS TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE WORK
WE'RE DOING TRYING TO REVITALIZE
THE FOREST DR- AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT BUT YOU ALSO POINT OUT
THAT WE NEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS AN ACTIVE PARTNER.
AND AS AS I POINTED OUT NEW
POINTED OUT 57% OF OUR FOREST
LANDS OWNED AND MANAGED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IF
THEY'RE NOT PRESENT AND WORKING
WITHOUT THAT AND WERE REALLY.
HOLDEN MAKING A- I THINK GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THE USDA THAT
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE THE
FEDERAL AGENCY OVERSEEING THE U.
S. FOREST SERVICE YOU KNOW
UNVEILED ABOUT A MONTH AGO I'M A
PRETTY PRETTY AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO
ACTIVELY ACTIVELY MANAGED
BELIEVE TWENTY MILLION ACRES OF
NATIONAL FORESTS ACROSS THE WEST
. WITH SOME REAL SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVE FUNDING- OR THAT. AIMS
TO BE SEEN HOW MUCH FUNDING
COMES TO CALIFORNIA WE'RE
CERTAINLY WORKING WITH THE
REGIONAL FORESTER AND REGION
FIVE- AND ALL OF THE REASON FOR
ON THAT ON THAT QUESTION AND
THEN SPECIFICALLY HOW DOES THE
WORK GETS DONE. YEAH YOU KNOW
SOME OF IT HAS TO BE DONE AND
THE TYPE OF GRANT THAT WE'RE
GETTING OUT OF WORK BUT WE NEED
TO REVITALIZE THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. DATEABLE YOU CAN ACT.
THAT BRING YOU KNOW THAT- DEATH
MEDITATION OUT OF THE POOREST
BUDGET TO PUT INTO EFFECTIVE YOU
KNOW AND FRANKLY. ON THE ON
GOING FOREST MANAGEMENT THAT
HAVE BEEN PLAYING. SO I'M NOT
GOING TO SIT HERE AND TELL YOU
THAT YOU KNOW. ANOTHER MESSAGE
OR CALL IT OR YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THAT YOU KNOW THE SOLUTION AND
YOU KNOW- RIGHT BEFORE US BUT WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND- WE GOT
THIS MILLION ACRE ALL OF MY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ALTERNATELY I
THINK WHAT FROM YOUR BILL I'M
NOT IN FUTURE YEARS. OUR OUR
FOCUS IS REALLY SCALING UP TO
HIT THAT GOAL. IN THE NEXT FEW.
YEARS AND THEN MOVE ON FROM
THERE. WELL I WANT TO JUST
FOLLOW UP WAS SAYING. I KNOW
THAT SENATOR FEINSTEIN I WORK
WITH ARE PERSONALLY UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE AND IT TO ME THIS IS
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATION THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE BITE
ADMINISTRATION GETTING TOGETHER
AND FIGURING OUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS BECAUSE IT AT THE END
THE DAY. HI I WAS ON THE DIXIE
AND I WAS ON THE CALDOR FIRES
WHILE THEY WERE BURNING AND THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE FOREST
SERVICE AND CAL FIRE. IS
NONEXISTENT. AND I'M I HATE TO
BRING THIS UP IS TO FAX THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THE TWO
AGENCIES. BY FIRE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT. AND WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
LOSING IS THE PUBLIC AND ARE
WERE EMITTING CARBON WE'RE
ROOTING OUR WATERSHEDS AND WE
I'M ASKING FOR LEADERSHIP. AS
YOU'RE IN THE POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO ADMINISTRATION. AT
THE STATE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND GET SOME POLICIES PUT IN
PLACE AND IT'S GONNA HAPPEN SO
I'M I'M BEGGING YOU FOR THAT
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
LET ME GIVE EXAMPLE THE LAB OF
FIRE WHICH WAS IN SISKIYOU
COUNTY WAS A SINGLE. LIGHTNING
STRIKE THREE. THAT THE POOR
SERVICE PUT A LINE AROUND DIDN'T
COMPLETELY EXTINGUISH IT LEFT.
AND THE WIND BLEW THE TREE OVER
AND IT AND THEN CALIFORNICUM
RESPOND BECAUSE WE HAD. WE LOST
WE LOST HOMES. BECAUSE THAT
POLICY. I WANT TO COST RIGHT NOW
IS SO BAD. IT'S THAT'S GOTTA
STOP AND AYE AYE LOOK. I'M NOT
HERE THROWING ROCKS I'M LOOKING
FOR SOLUTIONS BUT I'M SURE I'M
POINTING OUT THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE. THAT CANNOT CONTINUE IN
THE WILL THE FIRE WAS THE SAME
WAY IT BURKE FOR FOUR DAYS
BEFORE THE FOR SERVICE RESPONDED
TO IT. WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE MILLION ACRE FIRES. UNTIL
WE START EXTINCTION AND I KNOW
IT'S TOO COLD YOU HAVE TO. GET
TO FIGHT FIRE. AT THE SAME TIME
YOU HAVE TO PREVENT. DO DO MADE
AS WE ARE HUNDRED YEARS BEHIND.
SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU. THAT THE FOR SERVICE COUNTS
TREATED ACRES AS ACRES BURNED.
THAT MEANS IF A WILDFIRE CAME
AND DESTROYED IT THEY COUNT THAT
IS TREATED. THAT'S THE WRONG
POLICY DISTRICT ARE NOT TREATED
THAT'S DESTROYED. TREATED ACRE
SHOULD BE. ACRES THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY THE END. AND- AND FIRE
CAN THEN GO BACK INTO THOSE
ACRES. SO THE LAST. BUT THOSE
ARE JUST STATEMENTS AND I'M HERE
TO WORK ALONGSIDE YOU I'VE BEEN
IN THIS GAME FOR A LONG TIME AND
I CAN'T. STAND TO WATCH OR
FORCED CONTINUE TO BURN BECAUSE
WE CAN'T GET ALONG WITH THE FOR
SERVICE AND THEY NEED TO BE AT
THE TABLE. SO THE LAST QUESTION
I HAVE AND YOU CAN I KNOW THIS.
INFORMATION YOU PROBABLY WON'T
HAVE AS I'D LIKE TO KNOW. FROM
LAST YEAR. HOW MANY ACRES WE
TREATED. ACTUALLY TREATED. HOW
MUCH COST WAS A PER ACRE. AND I
WANT TO SAY IN CLOSING. YOUR
DOOR'S BEEN OPENED I'M NOT A
THIS IS NOT. IS NOT PERSONAL
THIS IS JUST FRUSTRATION COMING
OUT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. CAN NOT.
CONTINUE TO HAVE MILLION ACRE
FIRES AND THERE'S NO REASON FOR
THE ONLY REASON FIRED IN GOING
TO THE TAHOE BASIN AND
COMPLETELY WIPE OUT TODD WAS
BECAUSE WE HAD A FUEL BREAK
THERE. AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU
ON THE GROUND THERE. LOOKING AT
IT WE NEED MORE OF THOSE AND WE
NEED TO DO IT. SOONER THAN LATER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
STAYING ENGAGED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS ON THESE. ON THESE
TOUGH QUESTIONS. NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT THAT THE- CONDITIONS ARE
GETTING WORSE AND I. AND I
OPENED UP. CALDERON THE DIXIE
THAT YOU MENTION YOU'RE OFF ON.
YOUR DID SOMETHING THAT NO OTHER
FIRES DOWN A HUNDRED SEVENTY
YEARS ACROSS STUDENTS HEARING
ABOUT A SUMMIT. WHICH IS YOU
KNOW LARGELY GRANTED. BECAUSE OF
THE INTENSITY OF THOSE FIRES. I
DO THINK ARE ARE OUR
INTERVENTIONS ARE GETTING BETTER
MEANING YOU KNOW THAT THE
FUNDING THAT YOU ARE
CHAMPIONING. I GOVERNOR'S
CHAMPING ARE BEING PUT TO WORK-
REDUCED HOURS SHOPPING WHILE
PIRATES BUT WE CLEARLY NEED TO
DO A LOT MORE. WE ARE TRACKING
AND THE FISCAL YEAR BASIS- THE
NUMBER OF ACRES TREATED- BY OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT. BOB BUTTERS
CAL FIRE AND THE SO CAL FIRE YOU
KNOW PART WAY THROUGH THE FISCAL
YEAR NOW BUT BY THE END OF
FISCAL YEAR THEY'LL HAVE THE
FIGURES FOR CAL FIRE. I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THOUGH. I WANT CAL BUYERS
ARE LOOKING. OF OUR AFTER
FORESTRY. IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THE SCALE WE NEED TO KNOW WE
BROUGHT IT'S SORT OF A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH SO WE NEED
TO ACTUALLY INCLUDE. FOR EXAMPLE
YOU MENTIONED THIS YEAR AND
ABOUT A CONSERVANCY TO TAHOE
CONSERVANCY TO COASTAL
ARE DFW.
ABOUT YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS INCLUDING A RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT SO. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO HERE IN
THE NEXT YEAR AS I MENTIONED
AGAINST BRING. ALL OF THE
PROJECT THAT ARE BENEFITING
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE AND PUT THEM
IN ONE YOU KNOW ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT PLATFORM TO MEASURE. THAT
WE CAN REALLY ACHIEVE THAT SCALE
THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON- BUT- BUT
LOOK POINTPOINT TAKEN IN TERMS
OF THE URGENCY IN THE FOCUS THAT
WE NEED BECAUSE WHILE I. I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THAT I'M I'M PROUD. OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE AND THE
IMPROVEMENT. AND ARE GETTING
WORSE IN WE HAVE A LOT. OF AHEAD
OF- YES. LAST SAY THAT- YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR I THE PROC FOR THAT-
DID NOT GET FUNDED THAT WE'RE
SEQUEL READY PROJECTS AT
THROUGHOUT MY DISK IS ROCK
CALIFORNIA WITH THE RCTS IN A
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS- I. DO REALLY
BELIEVE IN THE CITY LEASES HERE
BACK IN SERVICE HE BECAUSE I SAT
ON IT FOR SEVEN YEARS THEY DO A
GREAT JOB AND THEY THEY CAN GET
THAT MONEY OUT WE NEED TO JUST.
FRONT LOAD THEM AND LET HIM GO
TO THE PROJECTS ARE ALREADY
SEQUEL READY PROOF PROJECTS. AND
YOU KNOW TOM PORTER LAST YEAR
SAID THEY COULDN'T GET THE MONEY
OUT THE DOOR FAST ENOUGH OR NOT.
MY WHOLE LIFE I'VE BEEN LOOKING
FOR MONEY. TO DO PROJECTS AND
NOW WE GOT MONEY WE CAN'T GET IT
DONE SO THERE'S OTHER AVENUES I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THAT
MONEY GO. TO THOSE AGENCIES THAT
CAN THAT DEL ALONG WITH CAL FIRE
BUT THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
READY. TO DO AND HOW THE
CONTRACTORS IN PLACE TO DO IT.
THANK YOU. WE WILL CERTAINLY
MISS CHIEF PORTER. WHO WAS A
FORCE FOR FIRST. AND HE DID HIS
JOB AS FIREFIGHTER CENTER
MCGUIRE. IF SOME QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I THINK
IT'S JUST- IT'S GONNA DO A
COMMENT HERE IN IN THAT'S ON THE
ISSUE OF BIOMASS LOOK- YOU TAKE
A LOOK AT THE NORTH COAST. IN
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH BIOMASS AND
IN PARTICULAR. WHERE A DEPUTY
SECRETARY AND I'M O GRATEFUL
FOR THE DEPUTY SECRETARY'S
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS ISSUE SHE
COMES FROM VERY SIMILAR REGION-
EAST OF US AS WE LOOK AT IN
REGARDS TO. THAT HERE ON THE
NORTH COAST BUT- THERE'S TWO
ISSUES ON WHY BROWN AT BINANCE
IS NOT WORKING IN THE STATE.
NUMBER ONE. BUT WE DO NOT GIVE
ASSURANCES. TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO A BIOMASS PLANT THAT THAT
ELECTRICITY IS GOING TO BE
PURCHASED. AND IF WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT. MAKING OUR FORESTS MORE
FIRE SAFE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A RECIPROCAL. TO THAT STOCK
THAT IS IN THE FOREST. SECOND
ISSUE ON WHY VIOLENCE IS NOT AS
SUCCESSFUL AS IT COULD BE IN THE
STATE IS TRUCKING COSTS WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE BIOMASS
POWER PLANTS LOCATED NEAR WHERE
THIS WORK IS HAPPENING AND IT'S
NOT HAPPENING AT THE OMENT SO
I'M ALL FOR TAKING A LOOK AT
INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT WE CAN- USE
DOLLARS ON. FOR TIMBER BUT I'D
ACTUALLY LIKE TO GET BACK TO THE
BRASS TACKS OF IT NUMBER ONE WE
HAVE BIOMASS PLANTS ARE ON THE
NORTH COAST IN CENTER DOLLARS
DISTRICT BY THAT COULD EXPAND WE
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN EXPAND
BIOMASS IN NON IMPACTED AIR
BASINS I MIGHT ADD AS WELL. YET
WE ARE NOT A GUARANTEE COSTS FOR
A MEGAWATT HOUR IN NUMBER TWO
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET IS NOT GOING TO CUT IT
WHEN IT COMES TO TRUCKING COSTS
SO I THINK THAT'S THE OTHER
PIECE AND I KNOW THAT BY THE
CHAIR IS VERY FOCUSING ON THAT I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT. CAN WE HAVE A RESPONSE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND CAN
YOU EXPAND ON THE BIOMASS
FACILITIES THAT ARE DISTINCT ME
TO PRODUCE ELECTRICITY AND WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE IT'S AN INVESTMENT
TO ALLOW THEM TO MAKE. UP FUEL
IF THAT WORKS IF THAT WERE MORE
DESIRABLE OR SOME COMBINATION
THERE OF WITH THE. WITH THAT-
PRODUCT THAT COMES IN. YEAH I
WOULD THINK BROUGH SPEAKING. WE
KNOW WE NEED MORE SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY ZERO ONE ONE
DEATH PRESENTATION OUT OF THE
FOURTH. YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
REMARKABLE FUNDING WILL NEVER
HAD BEFORE THANKS IN LARGE PART
TO YOU ALL WHO ARE YOU KNOW
MEETING THIS HEARING TODAY BUT
WE KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN BEEN
REMOVING THE VEGETATION AND
ECOLOGICALLY SUSTAINABLE WAY.
AND WHILE WE ARE REALLY BULLISH
ON NOON WHEN PRODUCTS LIKE THIS
MASK JIM BURKE CROP LAMINATED
TIMBER- WE RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW
THE POINTS YOU MAKE WHICH AND
BIOMASS. YOU KNOW- THE FACILITY
EXIST TODAY ACTUALLY UTILIZE
THAT- UTILIZED THAT. EDUCATION I
THINK CENTER DOLLY YOU KNOW HIT
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD THERE'S
ATTENTION WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
SORT OF THE SOBRE LINING
RENEWABLE ARE BECOMING SO
INEXPENSIVE LIKE SOLAR AND WIND
IT IS- BIOMASS IT MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE- TO GENERATE ENERGY
THAN THOSE CLEAN FORMS OF
ENERGY. AND THAT THEY'RE YOU
KNOW PPA IS FROM WE HEAR FROM
THE UTILITIES THAT- ARE
EXPENSIVE AND LEAD TO INCREASE
IN IN CONSUMER ELECTRIC
ELECTRICAL REYES. SO I THINK I
RECOGNIZE THAT FILE MATH PLANTS
YOU KNOW WHAT CLAIRE MORTON
ROLLED YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
SPEAKS DOT COM AT THE SAME TIME
THE CHALLENGES- EXACERBATING
RATE INCREASES AND IN SOME
PLACES YOU KNOW USING LEGACY
TECHNOLOGIES GRADING CARE
POLLUTION. SO I THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT I'LL SAY SENATORS IN THIS
IS A POINT WELL TAKEN WHICH WHAT
I HEAR FROM YOU AT ALL IS YOU
KNOW. TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION POSITION I MEAN
YOU KNOW I THINK THE BEST THING
BIOMASS PLANTS AND FINDING A WAY
TO ENABLE THEM TO OPERATE- YEAH
. BECAUSE OF THE BENEFITS OR DO
YOU KNOW CREATING MANIFESTO.
THIS OUT OF THE FOUR WE DO THE-
WILDFIRE. TO ALLOW I'LL TAKE
THAT THAT THAT. AS. YOU KNOW
IMPORT. POINT FROM YOU ALL- BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES PROSTATE TO THE
HAVE YOU NOTICED JUST A FOR OUR
- DATE WITH. THAT DIALOGUE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EACH CAN
AND OTHERS. ALSO ADAM THAT AND
THAT IF YOU AT OUR STRATEGY OR
HOW DO SHOULD MOVED MACHINE. OUT
OF THE COURT IN A CON- IT'S
ALMOST REFRESHING ARE TECH
AGNOSTIC IN CURRENTLY WHAT YOU
WITH TREAT AS TECHNOLOGY. RIGHT
PART OF THAT TREAT COULD
POTENTIALLY GO TO LUMBER ARE THE
TOP OF THE TREE COULD GO TO
BIOMASS PART OF THREE CAN GO TO
PARTICLE BOARD. AND SO BECAUSE
THERE'S MULTIPLE USES FOR THE
WORD EVEN IN A SINGLE TREE THAT
YOU'RE REMOVING WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WE ARE. THAT WE
ARE CREATING A FOUNDATION FOR
THAT ENTIRE ECONOMY AND THE BEST
USED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE AND SO
WHETHER THAT'S A CRIME A%
CATALYST. OUR BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT LOANS THIS OUTRAGE
PETITIONS SUBSIDIES TO GET THAT
MOVING OR THE FEEDSTOCK SUPPLY
GUARANTEES WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE STABILITY CONFIDENCE AND
ACCESS TO CAPITAL IN THE MARKET.
SO THAT THE ECONOMY CAN HELP
DRIVE THAT AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY- THAT AND SO I HOPE
THAT WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM US
IS THAT WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF ALL
OF THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT I AM
TRYING TO FACILITATE AND EXPAND
ALL OF THE TECHNOLOGIES. THAT
CAN USE THAT MATERIAL AS OPPOSED
TO TRYING TO CREATE ONE SILVER
BULLET OR DRAG THE FORCED AN
ECONOMY IN ONE QUESTION- AND YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT AND YOUR
POINT YOU KNOW WIRE SOME OF
THESE. AND THE BIOMASS
FACILITIES ARE EXISTING
FACILITIES. THAT CAN. ALLERGY
THAT. OUR ARMED. YOU KNOW AND
WHEN WE'RE TO GET A LOOK SORT OF
CASE STUDIES THE ONE TO
DISTILLATE AND SENATOR DOLLARS.
WHICH A WOULD BE. IS OF. THAT- A
- YOU KNOW IT IS NOT. SORT OF.
YEAR AND- YOU KNOW AND IT'S
VALLEY OR TO. COMMUNITY THAT
WOULD PULLING- AND SPELL. YOUR
EXPLORE IT AND I'M- WHERE.
HERE'S OUR- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT US ACROSS THE TIME. IN
THIS. SAN MCGUIRE THANK YOU I'LL
BE INDEED HERE'S MY BOTTOM LINE
. THERE ISN'T ANY THERE'S TENURE
DOLLARS TRANSFER SAID IN THIS BY
IT'S GOING TO GO VERY FAR TO
PILOT IS BY PROJECT IS BEYOND
ABOUT IT. IF WE'RE LOOKING AT.
WHETHER A IS ON THE NEW CO OR IN
NORTHEAST. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE PUTTING THE GOOD IN
FRONT OF THE PURE. AND WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS THIS- TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE INTO FEDERAL FORCE
QUICKLY. IN PARTICULAR WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE. AN AREA IN
WHICH WE CAN GET RID OF ALL OF
THAT ALL THAT SLASH IT'S COMING
FROM THE FORCE. TO BE TO DO THAT
THE PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE IN
NON IMPACTED THEIR BUSINESS I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE CENTER
VALLEY IT'S BOUNOUS- SO WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS THIS IS THAT. THE
BILL TO GET THIS ACROSS THE
STATE WE NEED TO GUARANTEED COST
OF ELECTRICITY AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HELP SUBSIDIZE THE COST
OF TRANSPORTATION THE LAST THING
I'LL SAY WE'VE HEARD THIRTY
BILLION IN INSURED LOSSES
BETWEEN THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SEASON THIRTY BILLION INSURED
LOSSES. WERE LOSING MILLIONS
UPON MILLIONS OF ACRES OF PRIME
FOR. IN WATERSHEDS EVERY YEAR
ACROSS THE WEST PALM WE HAVE TO
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND EVEN
IF IT IS FOR THE NEXT DECADE
WHEN WE WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
A AN AREA. IN WHICH A FACILITY
IN WHICH WE CAN TAKE ALL OF THE
STOCK OUT OF THE FORCE TO AND BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CLEANER GREENER
ENERGY I WOULD SAY WE NEED TO
SERIOUSLY LOOK. AT EXPANSION OF
BIOMASS IN NON IMPACTED AIR BASE
IN SAID I WOULD OPE THAT COULD
BE ON THE TABLE HERE- THIS YEAR
. BACK TO CENTER DOLLAR FOR
QUICK QUESTION I WANT TO JUST
ADD ON TO. THE SENATE REQUIRES
COMMENTS. COUPLE THINGS NUMBER
ONE. WE NEED TO OUR CHIP
CONTRACTS ARE LONG TERM CONTRACT
FROM THE FOR SERVICE SO THAT
THESE PLANTS HAVE A- STREAMLINED
WE WON'T WE DON'T NEED TO
SUBSIDIZE THEM. IF YOU TO BUILD
A MORE RE RE ENTER AT. TAKE THE
NEW ONE OF THE OLD ONES BACK
ONLINE. IF THERE'S A CONFLICT
THAT PPA CONTRACT. YOU HAVE TO
TOTAL FIVE PERMITS ARE PROBLEM
ON THE LOOK I'VE I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE WEST WOULD PLAN
AND THE LOYALTY PLAN LOYALTON.
PLANT HAS IS GOING TO SERVE THE
TAHOE BASIN WHICH DESPERATELY
NEEDS SERVED BUT I CAN'T GET A
PPA. POWER PURCHASE AGREEMENT SO
THAT'S WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN COME IN AND HELP. LOOK YOU
TALK ABOUT WIND AND SOLAR IS
CHEAPER GREEN ENERGY BUT THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT TO DO BIOMASS IS
THE- STOPS THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES IT HELPS WILDLIFE HELPS
OUR WATERSHED. THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT IS WAVING A BIGGER
BENEFIT THE COST MAY BE MORE ON
ELECTRICITY SIDE BUT THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT THIS IS. ENORMOUSLY
BETTER THAN WIND AND SOLAR AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN INTO THE
CALCULATION. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT-
PERMITTING THESE PLANTS IT'S THE
PERMITTING PROCESS AND THE PPAS
THAT NEED TO BE AND WHAT SUPPLY.
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS LOOK.
SERVICES BECAUSE IT HAS CAN'T
TAKE ANYMORE LAWMAKERS ARE
CUTTING THEIR CUTTING ALL THE
DEAD TREES THAT THEY HAVE ON
THEIR OWN LAND THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE ISSUE TODAY. WE CAN MAKE
WOULD OUT OF WE CAN MAKE BOARDS
AND WE CAN MAKE BY MASS AT THE
SAME TIME WE HAVE TO HAVE A
STEADY SUPPLY. TO THESE PLANS
WHEN THEY'RE PLACED. CAN CAN RUN
FOR FORTY YEARS SO THEY CAN GET
BACK THEIR INVESTMENT. THAT'S
THE ISSUES. AND THAT'S IT'S GOOD
COMMONSENSE APPROACH WE'VE GOT
TO GET THAT REGULATORY PEOPLE
OUT OF THE WAY. GET CONTRACTS
AND THEN GO FOR PUTTING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN THERE FOR
HAULING IS GONNA DO. KEEP IN THE
A FEW THAT ARE OUT THERE RUNNING
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO. TAKE CARE
OF THE LONG TERM- PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE WHICH IS A HUNDRED YEARS
OF FIRE SUPPRESSION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. VERY GOOD POINT. CENTER
STERN HAVE QUESTION. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND I
APPRECIATE DISCUSSION. SO FOR-
WHEN. WHEN PARADISE WAS BURNING
DOWN- YOU KNOW WE WERE HURT AND
WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES IS MY
HOME TOWN BURNED DOWN TO MIGHT
BE LOST EVERYTHING AND WE'LL
SEE- SO I DON'T NEED TO REHASH
ALL THAT- HOWEVER MAKES AMERICA
CUSTER CRY- BUT- OMITTED JUST
DIG IN THE- DETAILS HERE IN AND
START OUT BY THANKING THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE- WERE. WE
WANT TO GO BIGGER WE WANT MORE
CUTIE WITH OUR STRATEGIES IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS AND BUT I KNOW
YOU YOU ARE PUTTING YOUR
SHOULDER TO THE WHEEL AND YOU
HAVE BEEN THERE FOR US AND I
JUST I APPRECIATE THAT WORK- I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO MY- SAME
BEATING OF THE DRUM AS THE LOAN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ON. THIS
COMMITTEE- I DIDN'T BURN DOWN
OUR HOMES IN WOLSEY OR TOM IS
YOUR SADDLE READ YOUR- RIDE-
EMBERS DID- WE HAVE A- WIND
DRIVEN FIRE DYNAMIC WERE IN OAK
WOODLANDS AND CHAPARRAL- IT'S
ABOUT WIND SPEED AND GRASSLANDS
AND- LITTLE BIT TO MECHON VENTS
AND GUTTERS AND- AND THEN PEOPLE
NOT INSULATING THEIR GARAGES YOU
KNOW. IT'S ALL THE SMALL THINGS
IS NOT IT'S NOT ABOUT ACREAGE
ABOUT PEOPLE IN OUR AREA AND I'M
I KNOW WE DID TO HAVE TO
NEGOTIATIONS DOWN THE HOME
STRETCH AT THE END OF THE YEAR
LAST YEAR- THEN WE END. THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED MY BILL SB SIXTY
THREE AS WELL- AND IN THE
TRAILER THAT WE AUTHORIZED- FOR
THIS CURRENT APPROPRIATION
AROUND FIRE PREVENTION FUNDING-
I THINK THE LANGUAGE SAYS- THAT
TO THE FUNDING SHALL BE AWARDED
IN A WAY THAT PRIORITIZES
PROJECTS TO PROTECT A LARGER
POPULATION BASE. OR NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES RELATIVE TO THE SIZE
OF THE GRANT- AT THAT CALIFORNIA
BI<c.cyan> OP CONDUCTING OUTREACH- IN</c>
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE HAD
HISTORIC HAVE HAVE HIS. WE HAD A
LOW APPLICATION OR PARTICIPATION
RATE. IN THE FIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS PROGRAM- AND THAT BY
FEBRUARY FIRST WE WERE GOING TO
HAV. A REPORT FROM CAL FIRE-
THE LEGISLATURE BY COUNTY ON THE
NUMBER ONE DOLLAR OF
APPLICATIONS RECEIVING GRANTS
AWARDED SO- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
DISPARITY OVER TIME AND THE
DIFFICULTY OF PREVENTING FIRE.
IN THESE NOT JUST SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREAS BUT THESE SORT
OF MORE DENSELY POPULATED
REGIONS THAT DON'T HAVE THE SAME
FORESTRY CHALLENGES BUT- HAVE
MUCH MORE SORT OF COMPLEX IN THE
WEEDS CHALLENGES ARE IN THE
GRASS CHALLENGES IF YOU WILL
COULD BE IN THE BERKELEY HILLS
ARE IN ALAMEDA- COULD BE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY YOUR SAMBAR TO
DINO WE'RE DOWN IN ORANGE
COUNTY- BUT I ONLY. YOU KNOW I
SEE- A DROP OFF IN THE- PROPOSAL
FOR. FIRE PREVENTION ROGIC
FUNDING AND FROM THE ANALYSIS I
GOT FROM MY STAFF EVEN FOR THE
FORTY MILLION WE DID LAST YEAR-
THERE'S STILL A PRETTY DRAMATIC
DISPARITY- WHERE WORST YOU'RE
SCRAPPING OVER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS NOW MAYBE TALK ABOUT
TWENTY. CAN CAN YOU AWAY IN JUST
ON. HOW THE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
SINCE LAST YEAR AND- WHAT THAT
OUT REACHES LOOK LIGHT AND IF
THAT REPORT IS BEEN. GIVEN THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT RIGHT YET I
APOLOGIZE IF I HAVEN'T READ IT.
BUT IN IN WE WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT SINCE WE ULLED ISSUE TO
ON THE TASK FORCE REPORT IT
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE TO
DISCUSS THAT THE FIRST TIME.
DIFFERENT PORTS SORRY RIGHT NOT
NOT TASK FORCE REPORT I'M
LOOKING FOR WE'LL GET INTO THAT
ONE THIS IS THE RIVER THAT ON
FIRE BRIDGES THAT WE'LL DISCUSS
THE DIFFERENT TIME YET STILL
DON'T QUITE BUT JUST GENERALLY
ON. THE REPORT YEAH NOT TASK
FORCE SORRY JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR NOT NOT ON TASK FORCE
REPORT ON THE THIS IS TRAILER
LANGUAGE ON THE FIRE PREVENTION.
GRANTS PROGRAM AND THE HISTORIC
DISPARITY AND LACK OF PRIORITY
FOR FIRE THREATEN COMMUNITIES.
FOR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR STERN-
AND- I. I WILL CHECK IN ON THAT
REPORT WITH CAL FIRE- I KNOW
IT'S BEEN DRAFTED AND WE'LL SEE.
WHERE IT IS IN TERMS OF BEING
TRANSMITTED- AND- I AND I CAN'T
GIVE YOU JUST A BREAKDOWN IN
TERMS OF THE FIRE PREVENTION
GRANT FUNDING. FROM LAST YEAR
AND AGAIN REMEMBER THAT THE- AND
OF GRANTS FROM THE SEPTEMBER
APPROPRIATION JUST CLOSED FOR
THE FIRE AYE PREVENTION GRANTS
TO THOSE ARE- IN PROCESS SO. I
LOOKING AT THE EARLY ACTION
DOLLARS FOR FIRE PREVENTION-
GRANT- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WAS
GIVEN SIXTY FOUR GRANT AWARDS
TOTALING SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THE NORTHERN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHAT IS
AWARDED FORTY AWARDS TOTALING
SEVENTY POINT FOUR DOLLARS. AND
THEN ALSO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
LAST YEAR THAT WE'RE CALLING IN
THE BUDGET GOING FORWARD. IS
THAT- ARE CONSERVANCY'S WHICH
ARE ENCOURAGED FOR THE REGIONAL
FORCED EMPIRE CAPACITY PROGRAMS
THEY DELIVER ALSO GRANT DOLLARS-
ACROSS ADD THOSE RESILIENCE
SPECTRUM'S. CHU NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONCERT YOU DOLLARS
HUNDRED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR SENATE CAL.
UNDER EIGHTEEN DOLLARS UP. LAST
YEAR FOR PROGRAM THAT DELAY FIRE
. AND GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF FROM
SOME OF THE CONCERNS- DOLLARS I
AM. I SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO FOR
EXAMPLE I JUST DIEGO. I THEY'RE
DOLLARS WHAT YOU'RE INTO THE
FIGHT PREVENTION PRO. I'M A
STAFF THROUGH THE RE FORCE BUYER
PROGRAMS AIMED BY THE DIEGO
CONSERVATION DISTRICT THAT WENT
INTO. THE HOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE
TRIPPING PROGRAMS THAT SECRETARY
CROWFOOT MENTIONED IT I HAVE
PURCHASED A FIRE ENGINE FOR
EXAMPLE OR A LOCAL TRIBE- THE
AND INVESTED IN STRATEGIC FUEL
BREAKS AROUND THAT COMMUNITY SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE CONSERVANCY DOLLARS. ARE
BEING DRIVEN BASED ON THE
REGIONAL NEEDS WHICH SOMETIMES
ARE GOING TO BE ON THE LANDSCAPE
SOMETIMES ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
COMMUNITIES. AND. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS I WANT TO ROLL OUT.
TOWARD YOUR BROADER. ABOUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING ABOUT REALLY
SCALING HOME HARDENING
INDEFENSIBLE SPACE- I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM CAL FIRE HELLO
YES ON THE LINE TO TALK ABOUT
SORT OF THE PILOT PROGRAM IS THE
FIRST TIME WE'VE REALLY ROLLED
OUT. A DIRECT INTERVENTION TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT- LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS I TRIED TO GET SORT
OF A SATURATION LEVEL IN
COMMUNITIES. A NEW INITIATIVE
LIKE HEALTHCARE- I'M AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HELLO
YES JUST ROLLED OUT LAST WEEK IS
A PROGRAM THAT CREATES SPECIFIC
STANDARDS FOR INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO WORLD
WAR HOMEOWNERS. ARE PUTTING IN
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING STANDARDS SUCH AS-
FIREPROOFING THEIR MEN'S- AND
REMOVING FLAMMABLE MATERIAL FROM
AROUND THEIR HOMES AND SO THAT
WILL BE A HUGE TRYING HER FOR
THOSE HOMEOWNERS THAT CAN'T
AFFORD IT. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
DIRECT INCENTIVES FROM THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANY TO BE ABLE.
SHE ABOUT HARD. AND THAT PROGRAM
IS ALSO- NOT ONLY GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE INDIVIDUAL HOME
BUT ALSO HAVING INSURANCE
COMPANIES CHANGE. THEIR
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE AROUND HOW A
COMMUNITY- HAS ACHIEVED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HARDENING
BECAUSE WE REALLY RECOGNIZED
THAT WHILE AN INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNER CAN MAKE AN IMPACT ON
THEIR OWN WHICH THE FIRE
MEDIATORS TRULY MODIFIED. WHEN
YOU HAVE THE FULL COLLECTIVE
ACTION. TO HOLD SO THAT YOU HE
SAYS GET A SATURATION LEVEL
ALMOST IT'S SORT OF A AN
ALABASTER HERD IMMUNITY- IN A
COMMUNITY BECAUSE SO THAT IT
PREVENTS ALL OF THE STRUCTURES.
I'M FROM BURNING BECAUSE ONCE
YOU HEARD HAD A HEAT SIGNATURE
OF A STRUCTURE BURNING. EVEN IF
YOU'VE DONE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
NEXT DOOR- THAT DAY HE SIGNATURE
JUST GETS TOO HIGH. FOR YOUR
INTERVENTION SO- SO WE BOTH THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT ARE DOING EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH ON THAT WE'VE INVESTED
IN THE UC FIREFIGHTER PROGRAMS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTORS
INCREASING. I'M GLAD HE'S
PLANNING ON THANK THAT ALL CAME
TO THE BUDGET LAST YEAR. I'M
GLAD YOU CALLED AN ARE YOU SEE-
AS WELL THE- INTERVENTION- ARE
MAKING AN IMPACT ANY DO. RANT
DOLLAR THANK YOU HAVE REGION
LOCAL SAFETY THREE CUTS THIS.
SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE EMPLOY- THOSE
I THE DEFENSE WILL SPACE HARD ST
FUEL. THAT REALLY HELPED. THOSE
CAN. THOSE ARE IN AND I WE ARE
SO SOME ACT. IN TERMS OF AND
NORTHERN. OF THOSE DOLLARS. AND
I'M STOP YOU'RE THERE JUST FOR A
QUICK SECOND OR STERN ARDEN
CERTAIN JOB IN- BUT IT THANK YOU
FOR THE THOROUGHNESS AYE I. I
JUST. YOU KNOW YOU TALK NORTHERN
SOUTHERN I JUST WANT TO GET
CLEAR WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE BECAUSE- I THINK THAT THAT
DELINEATIONS- NOT WITH THE
TRAILER LANGUAGE- IDENTIFIED IT
TALKED ABOUT. POPULATION
CENTERS. JUST TO BE CLEAR WHEN
YOU SAY SOUTHERN YOU MEAN- YOUR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DEFINITION
FOR CALIFORNIA RIGHT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE- THE
DEFINITION THAT INCLUDES
EVERYTHING FROM. ALL THE WAY UP
TO TWELVE ME RIGHT UP THROUGH
MERCED UP IN THE CALAVERAS
COUNTY THAT'S. THAT'S YOUR
DEFINITION OF SOUTHERN RIGHT.
YEAH LET ME TRY IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE DANIEL LANCE- AT CAL
WHO CAN TALK IN A LITTLE MORE IN
DETAIL ABOUT THE FIRE PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM. AND AND HOW AN
OUT REACHED THE CIVIC LEE THAT
HAS BEEN- I GOING ON WITH I
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITIES PREVIEW THEM BEFORE
YOU GO TO DANIEL HAS BEEN
WONDERFUL OVER THERE I DO I DO
WANT TO APPRECIATE YOU FOR. THE
MENTION THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IN. AND HAVE AN AND I
AND ALL THAT BT WHAT PROGRAM
WERE YOU REFERRING TO THERE
WHERE YOU WERE. TALKING ABOUT
THE PILOT ON THE- INSURANCE-
DISCOUNTS FOR. FOLKS WERE DOING
HARDENING. YES THIS JUST ROLLED
OUT ON MONDAY- AND- I THINK IT'S
CALLED THE IT'S I THINK IT'S
JUST CALLED THE FIRE. PREVENTION
ANYWAY LOOK AT ALTERNATE TO
DANIEL TO GIVE MORE. TO GO IT
OKAY THE PROGRAM YEAH THANK YOU
. A GOOD FOR THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
TELLS YOU OUT- DANIEL LANDIS'S
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER ARE
NEWLY MINTED COMMUNITY WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS- IN MITIGATION
DIVISION- ALL ANSWER THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION RELATED
TO- THE OUTRAGE- THAT- WAS NOT
ONLY DIRECTED BUT ALSO- THAT
THAT WE DISCUSSED ON LAST YEAR-
AT THESE HEARINGS- FOLLOWING THE
EARLY ACTION DOLLARS- WE DID
EXTENSIVE OUTREACH SPECIFICALLY
IN. THE LA BASIN AREA AND THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION NOW
DANCER QUESTION YES WE REALLY
CUT THE STATE IN HALF AND
CONSIDER THE TOP HALF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BOTTOM HALF
WHICH DOES INCLUDE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHAT WE SPECIFICALLY WORK HARD
AND ACTUALLY I WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN AND YOUR STAFF.
WHO ACTUALLY MADE A NUMBER OF
CONNECTIONS WITH US WITH THE
PERFECT UP POTENTIAL GRANTEES
ARE WITHIN YOUR DISTRICT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DISCUSS- THE
PROCESS AND REALLY WALK THEM
THROUGH THE GRANT APPLICATION TO
HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
PROCESS OUR TEAM WORKED VERY
HARD TO DO OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE AWARDING- THE BEST
QUALITY BRANDS. BUT THAT WE'RE
SPLITTING THAT OUT AS EVENLY
ACROSS THE STATE AS POSSIBLE AND
I WANT TO DRESS YOUR TO CONCERNS
THE FOREST IN THE VEGETATION
TYPE IS NOT A DIRECT- COMPONENT
OF SOMETHING WE RANK THAT WE'RE
LOOKING IN THIS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY AT POPULATION BASIS
SO HOW MANY HOMES HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED.
OR BENEFIT FROM THIS PROJECT AND
SO THE VEGETATION TYPE- IS
REALLY LESS OF A CONSIDERATION
ON THE SECOND PIECES WERE REALLY
LOOKING AT FIRE REST IN THAT
THAT THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY-
IMMEDIATELY CONNECTED TO THE
FOREST VERSUS OAK WOODLANDS
VERSUS CHAPARRAL VERSUS
GRASSLANDS ALL OF THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE A- IMPACTED AND SO I
JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW AT LEAST
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS NOT FOCUSING
ONLY ON- FOREST. THAT WE ARE
DEFINITELY INCLUDING- THE LA
BASIN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
VEGETATION TYPES AS- HIGH
RANKING NOT AT. YEAH IN THE
OVERALL. HOPEFULLY THAT I- THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR BUT ALL I
POSIT AND MAKE IT MORE THAN THEM
GIVE ME ONE QUICK. UP B. IS YOU
KNOW AND IT'S NOT JUST BROKE YOU
INTERESTS HERE IN A. OR VENTURA
. YOU KNOW I HAVE THE I HAVE TO
BE LOOKING OUT FOR MY COLLEAGUES
IN MARIN COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO IN
SAN BERNADINO AND RIVERSIDE SO-
WITH THAT DEFINITION IN. THE
COUNTIES I JUST NAMED- HAVE HAD
LIKE HOW MANY DOLLARS WENT OUT
THE DOOR LIKE HOW MANY DOLLARS
WENT OUT THE DOOR AND ORANGE
COUNTY. AS A AGAIN SECRETARY I
JUST FROM MORRIS MENTIONED WE
WILL GET INTO YOU- VERY VERY
QUICKLY HERE- THE FULL BREAKDOWN
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES TO
SEE. HOW MEANT TO SHOW YOU AND
THE PUBLIC HOW MANY APPLICATIONS
ARE RECEIVED. AND ON HOW MANY-
WERE ACTUALLY AWARDED SO YOU'LL
FOLLOW UP. WITH WITH THAT-
QUESTION AND DID YOU WERE THERE
WORKSHOPS DONE IN IN ALL THOSE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES I
MENTIONED DID YOU DID YOU HAVE.
PUBLIC FORUMS AND STAY SAN DIEGO
ORANGE COUNTY SAN BERNARD DINO
RIVERSIDE LA VENTURA. YEAH OUR
LATEST- AROUND THAT WE JUST DID-
OCCURRED DURING THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER AND JANUARY- AND OF
COURSE DURING THIS SAME TIME
PERIOD WAS SPIKES IN COAL BIT
AND SO- YOU KNOW TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE HEALTH
CONCERNS AND THE- GIVEN THE
RESTRICTIONS- WE WENT TO A
VIRTUAL PLATFORM NOW WHAT WE
REALLY HAVE FOUND IN THESE.
PLATFORMS IS THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE- I WOULD SAY QUADRUPLED IF
NOT TEN TIMES- EXPANDED- THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE AND DO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE MEETINGS
SO. THE ANSWER QUESTION NO WE
WERE NOT UNFORTUNATELY ABLE TO
HOLD MEETINGS IN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE COUNTY BOTTOMING
PHYSICALLY I JUST MEAN WITH
THOSE COUNTIES. I DON'T MEAN
THAT YOU PLACE YOURSELF
PHYSICALLY THERE DID YOU DID
YOU. WORK WITH THOSE NAMES
COUNTY'S INDIVIDUALLY TO HAVE
THOSE KIND OF DIGITAL WORKSHOPS.
THAT WE INVITED- FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS- PAST- ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST-
AND WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOLLOW ARE-
YEAH- IT LIST SERVE- TO BE
INVOLVED IN SO. WE DID OUTREACH
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
INCLUDED IN NOT JUST. JOIN US IN
THE WORKSHOP ANSWER QUESTIONS
BUT ALSO THAT WORKSHOP WAS
POSTED ONLINE ALONG WITH BROKEN
ASK QUESTIONS ANY EMAIL
ADDRESSES. WHICH ARE STAFF HAVE-
OVER THE APPLICATION CARE AND
BEEN ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
AND SO AGAIN I DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFICS FOR IT TODAY ON ON
THOSE COUNTIES YOU LISTED BUT I
KNOW THAT WE DID. OUTREACH WITH
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN THEM. OKAY
CENTER I COULD ADD ONE PIECE
ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT- PART
OF OUR STRATEGY TO REALLY
INCREASE- THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS IN. ALL SAY LA
BASIN BUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. IS THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
IN THE NUMBER OF FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND FIREWISE
COMMUNITIES IN WHAT WE CONSIDER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VERSUS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND SO WE
REALLY BEEN WORKING ON THE
CAPACITY BUILDING TO HELP BUILD
UP FUTURE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND
REALLY ENSURE- THAT DOES THOSE
TRADITIONALLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
JUST AS AFFECTED BY WILDFIRES
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE- THE SAME
NUMBER GRASSROOTS EFFORTS
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT WE FUND
THOSE AND IN FACT THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL- AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ROLLING OUT SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS A VERY SOON HERE.
WITH FUNDING THAT HELPS BUILD
COUNTY COORDINATORS THAT THEY
CAN TURN AROUND AND HELP
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATIONS OR-
COMMUNITIES DEVELOP. FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND THAT WILL START TO
BUILD UP OUR OVERALL CAPACITY TO
GET MORE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR GRANTS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL BE-
THE ANSWER TO REALLY BEEFING UP
THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS. AND
PROJECTS THATWE FIND IN THE LA
BASIN AS WELL AS THE SOUTHERN
REGION. YEAH OKAY ARNAUD ALL ALL
TRYING TO WRAP UP HERE MITER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE- IT SOUNDS. LIKE
THE ANSWER MY CALL. IS IT IS
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU. BUT IT'S
OUT LIKE. KNOW THAT IN THE-
COUNTY OUTREACH WAS NOT DONE. IN
THOSE. FIVE OR SIX MAKE A
COUNTIES DOWN SOUTH BUT THEY'RE
BOTH SORT OF MORE CENTRALIZED-
NGOS BASED OUTREACH WAS DONE
WITH SOME YEAH WITH SOME BLAST I
JUST KNOW THAT. FOR THE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE NOT
LISTSERVS- PEOPLE HAVE NO IDEA
THAT THESE PROGRAMS EVEN EXIST-
AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR- THEY'RE
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR HELP I MEAN.
WE DO HERE. IS NOT A RICH
NEIGHBORHOOD IN. THE SOUTHERN
PART OF LA AND YOU KNOW HERE
ARE PARTS OF RIVERSIDE THEY BURN
IT YOU KNOW THESE ARE NOT IT'S
NOT ALL WE'RE NOT TALKING JUST
ABOUT MALIBU AND CALABASAS HERE.
SO I HOPE THAT. YOU KNOW WE CAN
GET THAT OVERDUE REPORT IT'S TWO
WEEKS IN NOW AND- AND THE LAST
QUESTION IS THIS ARE YOU I DON'T
SEE A B. SB SIXTY THREE
IMPLEMENTATION. IS THAT- AM I
MISSING THAT IS THAT ON ON YOUR
RADAR. YEAH THERE IS A BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- TITLED THE COMMUNITY
WILDFIRE AND PREPAREDNESS-
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE AND DOES
INCLUDE SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE
YOURS- AS WELL AS EIGHTY NINE
AND- EIGHTY SIX FORTY TWO SO
THERE THERE IS NOT TOTAL FOR
STAFFING TO IMPLEMENT- YOUR
LEGISLATION. ROGER AND SO THAT
THAT'S NOT IN THIS OTHER BCP
WE'VE BEEN REVIEWING HERE THAT'S
IN A SEPARATE. THAT'S IN A
SEPARATE ITEM IS THAT FAIR
ENOUGH I'M LOOKING COMMUNITY
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENT FIRE
PREVENTION SO. OKAY SO THAT'S
SORT OF ALL WRAPPED UP THE HOME
HARDENING PIECE THE SIXTY THREE
PIECE- ARE YOU GUYS PUTTING
FUNDING TOWARDS THIS THIS DEAL
WHY PROGRAM THAT TO. MS MOORE'S
JUST MENTION THE SAFER FROM
WILDFIRES PROGRAM. YEP FIRST LET
ME AT THE HOME HARNEY FUNDING
WITH OUR JOINT PROGRAM WITH
CALLAWAY YES IS PART OF THE
PACKAGE THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE IS
IN ITS OWN- ITS OWN. BCP WITH
THOSE LEADS BILLS I MENTIONS I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WHY IS.
SEPARATE WE'RE TALKING THE FENCE
SPACE AND GARDENING TODAY THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL IS. WHAT WHY IS
THAT SEPARATE- THE RESOURCES AND
THE PERSON. THAT TO OUR NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THE SPECIFIC. SECTIONS
IN SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE ARE
IN THE STANDALONE BCP THE MONEY
THAT'S IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT WORKED OR THIS-
WILDFIRE FORCED RESILIENCE
PACKAGE THAT WE'RE- TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW. AUGMENTS OUR
OUR OUR BASELINE SERVICES- IN
BOTH EVENTS WILL SPACE
INSPECTIONS AS WELL AS- HOME
HARDENING- AND FUEL REDUCTION
WORK. AND SO YES THEY WILL GO
HAND IN HAND. BUT THE SPECIFIC.
TOOLS AND RESOURCES NEEDED
EMPLOYMENT THE LEGISLATION- FROM
SB SIXTY THREE. YEARS OUTSIDE OF
THIS- ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE SO YOU'RE SAYING.
THE LEGISLATION WE PASSED IS NOT
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE
INFORMERS FORCE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE. CORRECT IT'S IN IT'S IN
A SEPARATE B. C. I'LL PULL UP
THE AGENDA AND SHOW YOU THAT YOU
GOT A LOT OF ISSUE NUMBER OF
WHERE THAT. YEARS BACK. SERGIO
ARE AND FROM. CAN ANSWER I MEAN
I THINK- SENATOR DOESN'T KNOW
THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
THE INFO. OF THOSE ONE BILL YEAH
WE PACKAGE UP TO BE I THINK
POSSIBLY TO VISIBILITY WE WORK
THOSE WHAT THE STATE FELT. IT
DOES CREATE CONFUSION I DON'T
WANT YOU TO DROP THIS THAT WERE
SO DEEP. IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
BELTS DON'T. HAPPEN OVERNIGHT
AGUILAR BURKE YOU KNOW I THAT
SEPARATION AND HE'S. THANKS YEAH
LEVINE ADDED SO DIFFICULT WHEN
WE HAVE PROPOSAL REALLY TO
EVERYTHING WE CAN LEGISLATION WE
DO ALL ABOUT THAT INDIVIDUAL WE
DON'T KIND OF MAKE SURE ARE
PEOPLE AT TO DIG THROUGH ALL BE
LIKE THAT SHOWS THAT IT
REQUIREMENT ALTHOUGH PLEDGE. NOW
THEY'RE MY BE OTHER COMP RECALL
BY THAT- WE DO COMPLEMENT BUT
TYPICALLY YOU KNOW WE COME BY-
THE RELIGIOUS STATION BE COULD
BE EXACTLY ARE CALLED OUT AND SO
THEY'RE STILL IN THE GULF BUDGET
THEY'RE JUST NOT IN IN THIS
PROJECT AYE I'D THEY WOULD BE A
SEPARATE IDA BUT THEY'RE ALL
IMPORTANT PRIOR THAT WE ARE
QUITE WHICH IS WHY WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD NUMBER CAN I THE I DON'T
MEAN TO GET SOME ABOUT WE IT IS
I WHAT I WAS TRYING TO GET OUT
IS THAT PIECE OF IT CRITICAL
PART OF THE- STRATEGY AT THE
THAT'S ALL WAS GETTING NOT SO
MUCH A- YOU KNOW WHAT I. IN THE
IN THE BUT MORE SO THAT THAT.
COMMUNITY HOME HARDENING- LIKE
IS THE GO. GOAL WE KNOW AN
ACREAGE GOAL. WHAT IS THE POP.
FOR GO. WHAT IS IT A NUMBER OF.
GO IS A NUMBER OF PEOPLE GOAL
LIKE. I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M
SORT GETTING AS LIKE WHAT WHAT'S
- HOW MANY PEOPLE DO USE. TO
PROTECT THIS NOT JUST HOW MANY
ACRES DO YOU SEEK TO TREAT. THIS
IS AND IF I COULD ANSWER- AS
PART OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINE WILL
BE BRINGING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE A REPORT ON THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS NEEDED- IN
IN FIRE PREVENTION. BUT TO
ANSWERQUESTIONS IT IS A VITAL
COMPONENT OF THE OVERALL
STRATEGY AGAIN IT DON'T WANT TO
GET MIXED UP AND YOU KNOW WHY
THERE ARE SEPARATE- BUT- BUT
HOLISTICALLY TOGETHER ENSURING
THAT THAT WE HAVE. ADEQUATE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT WORK
HARDENING HOMES OR BUILDING
FUEL- BREAKS AROUND THEN IT IS
ABSOLUTELY A COMPONENT OF THE
OVERALL STRATEGY I APPRECIATE
THAT I'M JUST ASKING IS THERE A
NUMBER. DID YOU GUYS HAVE A
GREAT SET OF GOALS FOR YOURSELF
IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES YOU WANT TO PROTECT
OR NUMBER OF HOMES YOU WANT TO
PROTECT IS THAT IS IT IS THE
MINISTRATION AND ITS PLAN HAVE
A- HAVE A DRIVING. METRICS NOT
SO MUCH A- QUALITATIVE GO. WHAT
WE A NUMBER OF- ITEMS THAT ARE.
IN WILDFIRE FOR ITS FIRST.
ACTION PLAN I KNOW WAS NOTED
THAT THAT YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THAT TODAY BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF. OF ITEMS IN THERE
THAT WILL- BUILD UPON. TO I
THINK ANSWER THE QUESTIONS AND
SOME OF THE MORE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS THAT YOUR- WORK RIGHT
NOW OUR GOAL BUT WE DO HAVE A
FUEL REDUCTION ACRES BOWL. AND A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE SCHOOL- THOSE
ARE TWO BILLS THAT ARE SET TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS IS WHAT WE ARE. I
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS. YOUR
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION IS GOING TO
HELP US BE ABLE TO DO- INITIAL
TRAINING AND CURRICULUM. TO
AUGMENT- THE EDUCATION IN THE
ASSESSMENT SECOND DONNA
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND THAT'S
GOING TO. CRITICALLY I HELP OUR
ABILITY TO MEET OUR GOAL OF NOT
JUST INSPECTING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND HOMES. BUT
ENSURING THAT THE ERROR WITHIN
COMPLIANCE AND THAT THEY HAVE
THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE RIGHT. EIGHT I'LL
WRAP UP HEREBUT- THE ANSWER
THOUGH IS THAT. THERE IS NOT
CURRENTLY A METRIC FOR NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE. SOUGHT TO
BE HARDENED OR NUMBER OF PEOPLE
LIKE. THAT THAT METRIC IS NOT IN
THERE I GET THAT YOU HAVE A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE NUMBER OF DOING
A FIFTY THOUSAND. BUT IT IS. IN
THAT BIGGER PLAN. DRIVING THIS
WHOLE PACKAGE HERE. IS THERE A-
NUMBER COMMUNITY NUMBER. ARE
PROPERTIES SCHOOL. BETTER LET US
FOLLOW UP AND GET OKAY OKAY I
THANK YOU AND JUST TO RECAP ON
THE NORTHERN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S SEVENTY MILLION THAT'S
GOING EARLY WILDFIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SIXTY THREE TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE CONSERVANCY
FUNDS. A HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION WHAT TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONSERVANCY FUND SO. IN THE OLD
DAYS WHEN YOU HAD THIS KODAK
MOMENT IT'S PLUS THREE MILLION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE
CONTINUED I NEED TO MOVE ON BUT
I CAN'T HELP MYSELF COULD NOT
ASKING THE KIDS SEER CONSERVANCY
TO CHECK IN AND GIVE US SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE HAVE
CONGRATULATIONS ON GETTING ALL
YOUR EARLY FIRE- MONEY OUT THE
DOOR WE DON'T HAVE A NUMBER ON
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET ON WHERE THAT
MONEY HAS BEEN ACCOUNTABLE AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON. GETTING TWO
MILLION MORE ACRES OF
RESPONSIBILITY TO GO FROM TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TO TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION AND THE BIG EXTRA POINTS
EXTRA CREDIT POINTS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TEN
MILLION THIS YEAR AND TEN
MILLION NEXT YEAR FOR TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION ACRES OF FOREST
LANDS. AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
COMMENT. THERE'S BEEN SOME
ACTION OR SOME INCLINATION WITH
THIS SUB COMMITTEE TO GIVE MORE
MONEY TO WRECK LEAD TO THE
CONSERVANCY'S TO DO THE FIRE
PREVENTION WORK THE TWO THERE SO
IF YOU COULD GIVE US. A NUMBER
OF. PROJECTS THAT YOU BELIEVE
YOU COULD FIND IN THE NEXT
TWELVE MONTHS. MS AVERY YOU'RE
ON. THANK YOU THE CHAIRMAN AWAKE
HOUSEKI AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF MY NAME'S ANGELA ABRAHAM
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS YOU'RE ABOUT
TO CONSERVANCY HAPPY TO BE WITH
YOU HERE TODAY THANKS FOR THE
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOUNDARY
EXPANSION- CREDIT FOR THAT GOES
TO SENATOR DOLLY AND WAS
LEGISLATION THAT- ADDED THOSE
IMPORTANT REGIONS THAT IMPORTANT
REGIONS YOU ARE BOUNDARY. ALSO
YOU MENTIONED THE EARLY ACTION
FUNDING WE GOT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT OF FUNDING AND
WERE ABLE TO GET THAT FUNDING
OUT ON THE GROUND VERY QUICKLY A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN GRANTS AND
APPROXIMATELY WE'RE GONNA BY THE
ACRES TOTAL NUMBER OF ACRES I'LL
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT- FORGET
THAT MONEY ON THE GROUND REALLY
QUICKLY WE'VE RELEASED A TWENTY
FIVE OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE GOT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IN GRANT
GUIDELINES IN JANUARY. WE
ACTUALLY HELD THAT FUNDING A
LITTLE BIT TO BE SURE OF THAT
THE NEW REGION THAT WAS ADDED TO
OUR BOUNDARY- THE BOUNDARY
EXPANSION WAS ELIGIBLE TO APPLY
FOR THAT FUNDING AS A RESULT OF
THE GRANT APPLICATIONS BY THE
END IN THIRTY DAYS WE RECEIVED
FORTY NINE CONCEPT PROPOSALS
TOTALING FORTY TWO. POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND REQUESTS WE
ACTUALLY OF THAT TOTAL AMOUNT
RECEIVED A THIRTY FOUR PROPOSALS
WHICH WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
EVALUATING NOW OUR PLAN IS TO
RELEASE THE SECOND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. OF THE TOTAL FIFTY
MILLION THAT WE RECEIVED IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR INGRATE GUIDELINES-
IN IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR- WE WERE
TRYING TO SORT OF SPREAD BECAUSE
WE KNEW THAT THERE WERE SO MANY
PROJECTS THAT WERE INTERESTED
AND NEARLY READY TO GET OUT
FUNDING WE HELD A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT- TO MAKE SURE THAT PROJECTS. TO BE FULLY DEVELOPED. WITH
THINKING ABOUT A NEW READ- IT
WILL. TO WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN
SPEND THAT GOVERNOR'S. IS TWENTY
MILLION THE S. C. O. TO YOU.
THERE MILLION IN NEXT YEAR AND-
TWELVE MILLION AND YOUR POST- WE
OF EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN
GET THAT MONEY ON THE GROUND
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY ARE PART
OF THE REASON WE ARE REVISING
OUR GRANT GUIDELINES. IN JUNE IS
TO BE SURE THAT ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING COME THAT COMES TO THIS
YEAR ABOUT A CONSERVANCY CAN
SIMPLY BE ADDED. TO THOSE
GUIDELINES WITHOUT HAVING TO
REDO THEM- AND SO AT EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN COME IN
THE NEED AND OUR REGION IS. IS
HUGE AS HERE ARE WHERE
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S VIRUS IS IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA REGION- AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME OF THE LARGEST FIRES
WE'VE EVER SEEN AS YOU ARE ALL
ARE. ARE VERY MUCH AWARE. AND
WHAT'S YOUR- WHICH ACCOUNT I
KNOW I UNDERSTAND YOU GOT FOR
THREE EIGHT MILLION AND- WHAT'S
THE NEED YOU HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE- THE WOODED
AREA OVERHEAD AN- EXCELLENT
DISCUSSION ON BIO. FUELS AND
THINNING AND THIS IS OUR
RESILIENCY PACKAGE OF THE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION ACRES THAT YOU
CONTROL. WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT WE
NEED TO BE SPENDING TWO BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OVER THE NEXT
DECADE TO TRY TO GET. THE THAT
THE FORCE IN SHAPE SO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR TWO YEARS IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO REALLY MEET THE
CHALLENGE. ARE WE MISGUIDED BY
TRYING TO BE BELIEVING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE. THAT MUCH MONEY TO
DO TO GET OUR FORCING SHE
BECAUSE OF THE PAST- NEGLECT OR
- ACTIVITIES. NOW THE NEED IS
HUGE I CAN'T CHARACTERIZE THE
ACTUAL DOLLAR AMOUNT TO IN OUR
REGION AT THIS POINT WE ARE
WORKING ON REGIONAL PLANNING
WHICH WOULD CAPTURE SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS ON ABOUT THREE MILLION
ACRE SCALES ACROSS OUR STATE AND
IN SEVEN REGIONS ACROSS THE
SIERRA NEVADA- AS AS SERVICE
AREA THAT WE SERVE- BUT THERE
AGAIN ON THE ESSENCE HE IS ONE
OF MANY- ADMINISTRATION FUNDERS-
AND SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT
I DON'T HAVE AN ACTUAL DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR YOU AS IT RELATES TO
THE FULL SCALE OF NEED I CAN SAY
THAT IT'S ENORMOUS- I CAN SAY
THAT THERE ARE MANY ASPECTS OF
THE FUNDING THAT NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED FROM. ENVIRONMENTAL
PERMITTING- YOU KNOW CAPACITY
BUILDING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING CAN GET ON THE GROUND
AND I BELIEVETHAT MINISTRATIONS
BUDGET CVERS A LOT OF THOSE
DIFFERENT NEEDS ACROSS A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT. HI MONTHS- I CAN I
SAY THAT DOESN'T SEE A WAR. AND
TWENTY DOLLAR JUST. PER IN A YOU
KNOW A COUPLE OF MONTHS WITH THE
EARLY ACTION- WE'VE GOT WE'RE
GENERALLY SPEAKING- THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT IS REQUESTED OF US
FOR FUNDING IS. MOSTLY DOUBLE OR
NEARLY DOUBLE EACH TIME WE
RELEASE. A BUCKET OF FUNDING-
BUT I CAN'T SAY WE NEED SIX
BILLION DOLLARS ACROSS TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION ACRES AT THIS
POINT THAT WE ARE WORKING TO TRY
AND- BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT WE
WILL BE THERE. THEY WOULD ONE BE
THERE BY JUNE MAYBE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR IF WERE. INCORRECTLY
RECORD THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR-
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD IT WE
WILL BE ASKING. OTHER QUESTIONS
LET'S TAKE OFF OUR- FORSTER HATS
AND PUT ON OUR FIREFIGHTERS HAD
TO MOVE TO PROPOSAL- GOD. ISSUE
NUMBER. RELATED TO FIRE.
SUPPRESS AND- ASSESSED ALMOST
NINE MILLION TO. THIS YEAR AN
ONGOING FOR SUPPRESSION- WHAT'S
OUR DISCUSSION. SECTOR. THANK
THANKS SO MUCH SHOT YOUR WHITE
HOUSE OKAY AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO KEEP TYLER WITHIN CAL FIRE IN
JUST A MOMENT BUT I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WHILE WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT- PREVENTION OR WHAT
I CALL WILDFIRE RESILIENCE FOR
THE LAST HOUR AND A HALF.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IT'S
CONTINUING TO BUILD OUR CAPACITY
TO RESPOND TO WILDFIRES AND
AGAIN SO PROUD OF THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE AND WE
ASK THE MUTUAL AID RESPONDERS TO
. AVOID ANY FURTHER DOLLARS FROM
A REAL HORRIFIC WILDFIRE SEASON
LAST. I WANT A PARTICULAR. ON
THAT WILL PROVIDE RELIEF
STOPPING. OUR FIRE BY ARE DOING
. ROADWORK THE STATE AT. CAN PER
KERR. TO THEMSELVES AND FAMILIES
CONNECTING. AND SO I HAS YOUR
TILE TALKING. PART OF THIS IS
REALLY FOCUS ON. WRITING
RESOURCE THAT IN. REALLY ENABLE
THE MENTAL AND- HEALTH- ARE
WHILE FILE I WANT FIREFIGHTERS.
THANKS AND I'LL IT OVER TO PAY.
TYLER. THANK YOU SECRETARY CROW
THE SURE WHITE HOUSE AGAIN
MEMBERS OF SENATE DONE THAT CAN
- THANK YOU MY NAME IS JOE TIE.
I AM ADEPT DIRECTOR OF THE FIRE
PROTECTION BECAUSE THE FIRST THE
ITEM WE'RE GONNA ABOUT REALLY IS
SETTING THIS THAT- THEY HAD BEEN
SET UP IN TALK ABOUT THE LAST
ISSUE M. A. FIRE IN THE FOR
AFTER SO WITHOUT GOING IN THE
SIGNAL OF- OF WE IGNORE THE
SECRETARY DID- STRONG MORE OF
THE- WOMEN AND MEN IN THE FIRES
CROSS CAL. AND CALVET SPECIFIC.
TO BE ABLE TO COME MEDIC THESE.
WELL TRY TO REDUCE THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION OF- PROPERTY LIVES
IN IT NATURI SOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO AS WE GO
FORWARD WE TALK ABOUT- BOTH
PERSONNEL AND EQUIPMENT THAT
COULD BE USED FOR THE PURPOSES
OF IT TRYING TO REDUCE THE
WILDFIRE. OCCURRENCES IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO- TO
ALSO PROVIDE RELIEF TO OUR
EMPLOYEES ACROSS CALIFORNIA- AS
WELL THE FIRST SUBJECT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY ASK DO WITH-
THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS- OUR OUR
COMPUTER AIDED DISPATCH AN
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATION
PROGRAM HARDWARE AND SERVICE
REFRESH- THIS PROGRAM REALLY IS
A COUPLE COMPONENTS THE COMPUTER
AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM IS THE COR
SYSTEM THAT. IS WITHIN OUR
TWENTY ONE COMMAND CENTERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE DISPATCHER
RESOURCES- TO ALL TYPES OF ALL
HAZARD EMERGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING- INCLUDING
WILDFIRES. BEEN AN EXTENSION OF
THE PROGRAM IS THE AUTUMN OF
VEHICLE OKAY PROGRAM THIS WAS UP
. AND IT'S AN PHASE AND ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
BELIEVE- WHERE WE ADDED TWELVE
HUNDRED- AUTOMATIC VEHICLE
LOCATION SYSTEMS INTO- OUR
FRONTLINE VEHICLES OF FIRE
ENGINES. EMERGENCY CREW
TRANSPORT THE TIME SHE VEHICLES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- AND IT BECAME
A PRIME RESOURCE THAT EXTENDS
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO THOSE
FRONT LINE FIRE ENGINES- MOVING
FORWARD IT'S IPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT- THAT- WE COME FORWARD WITH
A CAT A REFRESHER WHAT WE CALL
THIS CAT REFRESH EVERY FIVE
YEARS. AND THE PURPOSE FOR THAT
REALLY IS THAT- THE CAT A
HARDWARE ITSELF WILL GO OUT OF
WARRANTY AND UNDER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
RECOMMENDED GUIDELINES- WE WILL
TYPICALLY REPLACE. OUR HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE FOR COMPUTER AIDED
DISPATCH SYSTEM EVERY FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS- THAT IS CAN CURRENT
IN A SIMILAR TO OUR SISTER
AGENCY IT C. H. P. IT DOESN'T
REFRESH CYCLE ON THE SAME FIVE
YEAR STANDARD. AS FOR- EXPANSION
OF THE PROGRAM- WE'RE LOOKING AT
AND REQUESTING AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL TO- ADD FORTY THREE
POSITIONS TO PROVIDE CAD
MAINTENANCE- AND CRITICAL A
PERSONNEL TO INSTALL AND
MAINTAIN- AB L. SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE REQUEST IS TO ADD- IN IN
ADDITION TO THE TWELVE HUNDRED.
YEAH I'M SORRY THE TWELVE
HUNDRED AVO UNITS ARE OUT THERE
READY ANOTHER TWENTY HOW- IN TO
OUR- ADDITIONAL VEHICLES. THAT
WE HAVE OUT THERE IS PART OF OUR
TOTAL FORCE PROGRAM IN IN-
CALIFORNIA HERE- THAT IS-
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
RESERVE APPARATUS THAT WILL BE
SEARCHED AND PLACED INTO
SERVICE- AS WELL AS- VEHICLES
LIKE THE OFFICE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL WHO ARE CRITICAL TO US
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND- ASSIST
IN THE TOTAL FORCE. EFFORTS DO
DAMAGE INSPECTION THAT ALLOWS
REALLY THE EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTERS- AND OUR INCIDENT
COMMANDERS IN THE FIELD TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK AND HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF OF THESE
RESOURCES IN ADDITION TO THAT AB
ALLOWS THOSE COMMAND CENTERS TO
DISPATCH WHAT WE CALL DYNAMIC
DISPATCHING THEY WILL DISPATCH
RESOURCES TO THEIR CLOSEST TO AN
EMERGENCY- UTILIZING THE
INFORMATION IS FED FROM THE
AVIELLE UNIT BACK TO- THOSE
DISPATCH CENTERS- IN BREVITY-
THAT IS THE REQUEST THEN I WILL
OPEN UP FOR ANY QUESTIONS. WHAT
C. DIRECTOR DRIVING TECH. GIVE
DO CHIEF WITH- WE YOU SOMETHING
TO ADD TO THE- SUPPRESSION.
REQUESTS AND THEY YOUR YOUR- YES
PEACE. HI YEAH HEY- AFTERNOON-
THIS YEAR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AND- MARKET RTG THE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
OBVIOUS IT'S NOT OUR USUAL
COMMITTEE BUT DOUBT WE'RE SO
PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM. RESOURCES AS
ALL OF THIS AS YOU HEARD HAS
BEEN A TRULY WANT TO ONE FIGHT
EFFORT IN OUR ABILITY TO WORK
THROUGH ALL OF THESE CHALLENGES-
I'LL JUST MENTION- AT THE
BEGINNING THAT- THAT- YES IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COORDINATION
OF. OVERALL STATE AGENCY
RESPONSE TO DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES- IN ADDITION RICH IT
WE'RE SURE THE STATE'S%
READINESS. RESPOND TO AND
RECOVER FROM ALL HAZARDS AND
COORDINATING WITH AND ASSISTING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THEIR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY MITIGATION EFFORTS.
AS A PART OF OUR STATUTORY
AUTHORITIES WE HAVE MANAGED TO
STATEWIDE MASTER MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM SINCE THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES. WHICH HAS PROVEN OF
COURSE TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL MUTUALLY SYSTEMS IN
THE WORLD. WE ALL REGIONALLY
COORDINATE WITH EACH OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. TO ADDRESS
GAPS DURING THEIR TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES OUR OFFICE IS ALSO.
THE APPLICANT TO THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT THROUGH FEMA. TO
SECURE FEDERAL THE- EVERY
FEDERAL DOLLARS SHOULD
CALIFORNIA- IN ALL AREAS THROUGH
YES- SO THIS. PROPOSAL IS PART
OF A THE TECH IMPROVEMENT BY
REALLY IS A DIRECT- MUTUAL AID.
OPERATIONAL RESPONSE CAPABILITY
I IS A PROPOSAL THAT IS CHALO
YES ALONG WITH CAL FIRE-
REQUESTING THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL FUND AND
THIRTY ONE POSITIONS THE BREAK
OUT OF THAT. IS TWENTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION AND A LOT OF
POSITIONS THAT WE ASK. AND FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION IN TWENTY
POSITIONS FOR CAL FIRE.
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET TO
ESTABLISH AND OPERATE WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE FIRE INTEGRATED REAL
TIME INTELLIGENCE SYSTEM WORKS
VIRUS. IT IS A STATEWIDE SYSTEM
THIS IS AN AERIAL INTELLIGENCE
PLATFORM BACKED UP PROVIDES REAL
TIME- SITUATIONAL AWARENESS-
THROUGH- ALL WHOLE PLATFORM OF
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGIES- TO BE
ABLE TO GET- IMMEDIATE
ASSESSMENT. OF WHERE FIRES ARE
BREAKING WHAT THEY'RE DOING-
AWARE WHAT DIRECTION THEY'RE
MOVING IN BUT HOW THEY'RE
IMPACTING THE COMMUNITIES AND
THAT INFORMATION IS THEN WE'LL
GET YOU READ ONLY DOWN TO.
RESPOND AS DECISION MAKERS AND
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTERS. WE
ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND THE FIRES
CAPABILITY. AND IS IT YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY AN EXAMPLE. OF A
CREATIVE PROBLEM SOLVING. AS ON
I DON'T GAS THROUGH- APART FOR
THE IN STATE. ARE WE SAW AND FOR
THIS REAL TIME VISUAL INTEL
MODELING AND SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS. FOR ALL HAZARDS TO
SUPPORT THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
INCLUDING. PROVIDING THE B.
INFORMATION TO MOBILIZING STRIKE
TEAMS IF THE COMMANDERS ON THE
GROUND MERGE OPERATIONS CENTERS
REGIONAL COORDINATION CENTRES
AND THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER.
WE DID BOB BOB BUT THIS WITH
ORANGE COUNTY I WAS A IN
COORDINATION WITH- WE ASKED. WE
ESTABLISHED A PILOT PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS FUNDED THROUGH STATE
FUNDS THAT WERE PASSED TO- YES
ARE UNUSUALLY THIS WAS FOR A
PILOT PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT WAS EXCESS
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT AREA AND WE
PUSHED OF THE CAPABILITY NORTH
OF REALLY DUE TO THE- EXTENSIVE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FIRES
THAT WE WERE SEEING IT ON THE
CALIFORNIA THIS LAST FIRE
SEASON- AND WE NEEDED THE
INFORMATION TO HELP US. IN THAT
A RESPONSE OPERATION- OVERALL
THE PILOT PROVED TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND PROVIDED MUCH
NEEDED. REAL TIME INTEL A
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS IT ALSO
IDENTIFIED TO US THAT IT WAS
LIMITED IN ITS- CURRENT
CAPACITY. IT DEMONSTRATED TO US
THAT. THERE IS A NEED TO HAVE AN
AMPLIFIED CAPABILITY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE ENTIRE STATE. IS
FACING UNPRECEDENTED EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS OFTEN
SIMULTANEOUSLY. SO THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR TO FULLY
CAPABLE AIRCRAFT AVAILABLE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IT. TOOK
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY EVERY
DAY OF THE YEAR WHICH INCLUDES
PILOTS AND AIRCREW AIRCRAFT
MAINTENANCE SUPPORT OF SOUTHERN.
AND NORTHERN- INTEGRATION
CENTERS WHERE WE INTEGRATE ALL
THE DATA- ADDITIONAL MODELERS
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE INTEGRATION
OF TECHNOLOGY UPDATES. AND.
EQUIPMENT OUR RECONNAISSANCE.
ACTUAL SUPPORT AND THE CALLASPO
. THE PUSH. MAN TO PROBE IN THE
AID RESPONSES. AT THE STATE
REALLY A LEVELS. ENTERING THE
ABILITY TO AND FIRE STATION. IT
THE OPERATIONAL PROTOCOL. AND
THE STATE WILL OPERATION GET A
GREAT. WITH THE STATEMENTS
PARTED. AT OUR LOCAL LEVELS AND
WITH CAL FIRE. REGIONAL
COORDINATION CENTRES AND THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES THE
BRITISH OF CAL FIRE TO UTILIZE
THE FIRES CAPABILITY FOR THEIR
MISSION. AND INCLUDES THE
ABILITY. AND PERSONALITY AND A
GREAT THE VIRUS PROGRAM INTO THE
CAL FIRE OPERATIONAL PROTOCOLS
AND THEIR COMMAND PROCESS. OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS IT'S BEEN
PROVEN TO BE A VERY CRITICAL
INTEL AND DATA GATHERING SYSTEM
IT HAS BEEN VITAL DURING A
RECENT WILDFIRE SEASON AND WE
SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR THAT BED
BATH BEYOND WILDFIRES THIS
CAPABILITY HAS BEEN USED. FOR
ALL HAZARDS- AND CAN'T BE USED
FOR ALL HAZARDS INCLUDING-
INCLEMENT WEATHER OIL SPILLS
WHICH WE COULD USE IT ENOUGH
HUNTINGTON BEACH OIL SPILL OFTEN
LARGE COUNTY EARTHQUAKES MUDFLOW
AND DEBRIS FLOWS AND OTHER
EVENTS LIKE SEARCH AND RESCUE
OPERATIONS. ALTHOUGH IT'S- ABOUT
THE PRO WHICH WAS HERE. AND ALSO
MAY IT. IT A PERMANENT STATE
PROGRAM- AND GET A BETTER
COMPONENT INTO THE BEACH LAYS
STORAGE. WIRE PROP- TO- AND- FAN
THAT MAKES IT A STATEWIDE PRO.
ONE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ONE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL FIRE WILL
BRING THEIR WILDFIRE
FIREFIGHTING EXPERTISE AS
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM TO MEET
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS AS WELL AS
PARTICIPANTS. IN THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM. SO THAT'S IN ESSENCE THE
SUMMARY OF THIS PARTICULAR- BOB-
AND THIS THIS THIS CAPABILITY
I'M OF COURSE I HAVE YEAR TO
DATE. G. PART MARSHALL ARE WHICH
STATE FARM RESCUE. CHIEF AND-
AND OF COURSE. ACTOR JOE TYLER
WHO YOU JUST HEARD FROM- THE
PROTECTION FIRE IT WORKING ON
THIS JOINT. AND CAN ANSWER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS NOT THAT
I'M GONNA JUMP LINE WERE THE L.
A- BUT THE FOR THE CASE THAT YOU
KNOW THE- WE NEEDED THIS. ON THE
EXIT WHILE RE. AND CAPACITY THAT
IS STILL. HAS BEEN DELIVERED WAS
TO IN TWO TWENTY BUT MORE. ON
ENHANCE YOUR FIVE. AND ME AIDES
IT'S UNCLEAR TO WHAT EXTENT THE
FUNDING WILL BE USED BY- YES TO
REPLACE EXISTING FIRE ENGINES
MORE FREQUENTLY OR PROVIDE MORE
WROTE ROBUST MAINTENANCE OF.OF
THAT WITHOUT THIS BASIC
INFORMATION. WORDS YOU KNOW THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS A DIFFICULT
TIME COULD YOU SHED SOME LIGHT
ON THAT. WELL I'M WELL.MAYBE A
CLERK BY THE FOR- SATURDAY THE
THAT THE FUNDING IS REQUESTING-
FUNDING FOR- THESE TWO- NONE OF
THIS BY THE GO TO SUPPORT FIRE
ENGINES THAT'S THAT'S DIFFERENT
FUNDING. THIS IS I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE ENHANCE FIRE AND
RESCUE MUTUAL AID FIRE FLEET THE
PROPOSAL SUPPORTS- YESS MUTUAL
AID FIRE ENGINE PROGRAM. SORRY
BUT THIS SPECIFICALLY IT'S
UNCLEAR WHAT EXTENT THE FUNDING
WOULD BE USED BY- YES TO REPLACE
EXISTING FIRE ENGINES MORE
FREQUENTLY OR YOU PROVIDING MORE
MAINTENANCE UNDERSTAND ON THOSE
EXISTING. TO COMBAT FLEET THAT
YOU HAVE I GOT YOU NOW OKAY ALL
OF ME I'M HAVE CHIEF MARSHAL.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR GHILARDUCCI.
THE REQUEST IS- TO PROVIDE
MAINTENANCE AND REPLACEMENT OF
OUR EXISTING FLEET. NO
ADDITIONAL FIRE APPARATUS ARE
BEING ADDED. AS A RESULT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION- THERE WAS A FIRE
REPORT BASED ON THE TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE FIRES- THAT DESTROYED-
COUNTLESS HOMES AND ACRES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THERE WAS
A RECOMMENDATION THAT- YES AB
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIRE
ENGINES- TO THE MUTUAL AID
SLEEP. WE HAVE NOW RECEIVED AND
IN THE PROCESS OF DISTRIBUTING
THESE FIRE ENGINES- FIRE ENGINES
DO NOT- HAVE- FOREVER LIFESPAN
AND THEY NEED TO BE REPLACED.
PLUS THE USE OF THESE FIRE
ENGINES- THIRTY THIS YEAR ROUND
FIRE SEASON WHERE THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRE ENGINES
ARE OFTEN ON THE FRONT LINES FOR
TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY SIX HOURS.
AND EXTREMELY- TOUGH CONDITIONS
THERE'S MORE MAINTENANCE SO THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO. INCREASE OUR
MAINTENANCE AND REPLACEMENT OF
OUR EXISTING FLEET. ON A
IDENTIFIED SCHEDULE- THERE'S
ADDITIONAL MECHANICS. TO-
ASSISTA THE THESE FIRE- ENGINES
WE OFTEN DISPATCH R. O. S.
MECHANICS OUT TO THE- THE FIRE
LINES TO KEEP THESE FIRE TRUCKS
IN SERVICE SO THEY'RE AVAILABLE
AND TO FIGHT THESE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES. PRETTY GOOD ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE TO THE CONSERVATION
CORPS A DIRECTOR SETO YOU'VE GOT
SOME. FIRE CREWS- AN
AUGMENTATION CAN YOU UPDATE US
ON WHAT YOU'VE DONE WITH THE
BUDGET MONIES THAT WE HAVE AND
WHAT RICK WHAT'S HAPPENING
BEFORE US. THANK YOU CAN FOR
CASPIAN'S COMMITTEE MEMBERS
STOP. RELATED THE WILDFIRES
SUPPRESSION PACKAGE- THE CULTURE
CORPS PROPOSING. EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND TO- BIRDS ARE TEN OF
OUR RESOURCE PRODUCED FIRE HANK
- BATCH FOR THE YOUR- TWENTY TWO
TWENTY. AND ARE OUR GENERAL FOR
- THIS AND ADDITIONAL OUR
PROPOSED TO. IS ONE MILLION
SEVEN ARMS NINE DOLLARS- TO AND
I'M GOING TO FUND. TO RIDE SIZE
OUR FAR THAT WOULD NEED ADDING-
THIRTEEN. AT OUR CAMERA CENTER
HAS FOR ONE CREWS A PARTNERSHIP
WE CAL. AS WELL AS A LIVE IN
POSITIONS- WHY SHOULD IS A SOME
OF LAST YEAR'S- BARRED-
EXPANSION PACKAGE OR CALL FOR. A
FOURTEEN OBSERVATION CORE CREW-
WERE. FOR PERMANENT CREW- AND-
SEASON FIREFIGHT FOR ALL THOSE
WHO WITH THEIR OWN. RELEASE OF
FUNDS- APRIL MAY OF THE STATE-
YOUR WHOLE OUT ALMOST. AND OF
COURSE YOU ARE AS KNOW WE ARE A
VERY BUSY SEASON- KIND. EVEN
THIS NOT FAR APART RAW. OR
ONLINE DATA UNDER THE OUR YEAR
SO I. THIS IS- REQUEST LAST YEAR
WORK A OUR OUR OUR- DEPARTMENT
WITH ALL PARTS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO- HEARING ANY QUESTIONS OR-
ADDRESSING CONCERN THAT YOU WERE
THERE CAN BE WHITE HOUSE.
GENERAL RESPONSE TO THE PROPOSAL. MISTER CHAIR STEVEN BENSON
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF I
IF I COULD FOR- STRIGULATED- SO
ON THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
WE'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS- HERE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE HAVE A GOOD DELIVER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FIREFIGHTER ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
BEST WAYS TO GO ABOUT HELPING.
ADDRESS THE FIREFIGHTER HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND THAT'S REALLY THE
FOCUS THAT FORTY MILLION- THERE
IS A LITTLE OVERLAP WITH SOME OF
THE SURGE FIRE- PROTECTION
PROPOSALS FOR EXAMPLE WELL THE
ONE IN THERE IS THERE'S A
PROPOSAL TO PURCHASE FOR NEW
SIKORSKY FIREHAWK- HELICOPTERS
IN THE STAFFING OR SAID THAT
WOULD BE COVERED WITHIN THAT
FORTY MILLION BUT- OTHERWISE THE
FOCUS OF THAT IS REALLY ON. HOW
RIGHT SIZING. AND- ADDRESSING A
- HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE OTHER
FIREFIGHTERS AND SO WE'RE
WORKING ON TRYING TO DEVELOP
THOSE DETAILS AND HOPING TO
BRING IN FORCE YOU CAN BUT-
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVEN'T GOT
THAT. AVAILABLE TO SHARE AT THIS
TIME. MMHM YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS
GREAT DEBATE THAT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN PREVENTION AND
SUPPRESSION AND IT'S IN. AND
WE'RE MINDFUL THAT THE BUDGET
FOR SUPPRESSION GOING FORWARD IS
TWICE AS MUCH AS IT IS FOR.
PREVENTION IS. THIS FINANCED
THINK THAT WE CAN FIGHT OUR WAY
OUT OF THE FLOOD CONTROL
CALAMITY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
IS YOU KNOW I MEAN. IT GIVE ME
AN IDEA OF WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
GOING FORWARD GIVEN THIS THIS
THE CURRENT BUDGET REQUESTS
COMPARED TO THE TO YOUR REQUEST
THAT YOU HAVE ON PREVENTION THE
MAYBE I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING. YOU
KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO HELP YOU
GET A RESPONSE- THE TO THE THAT
HAPPY PLACE WHERE WE DON'T WE
HAVE ALL OUR FIRES AND THE
CONTROL. WHAT WE WOULD LOVE TO
GET TO THAT HAPPY PLACE I'M NO
MISTER CHAIR WE CERTAINLY DON'T
THINK THAT THAT THE STATE CAN
CAN FIND ITS WAY OUT OF. THE
CURRENT SITUATION WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH ALL THAT'S EEN
MESSAGE FROM C. R. A. N. AND
OTHERS TODAY IN TERMS OF THE
IMPORTANCE. OF BALANCING FIRE
SUPPRESSION WITH FIRE PREVENTION
AND- FIRE PROTECTION- I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO TALK MORE
ABOUT- THAT PROTECTION. IT IS
SUPPOSED TO SUPPRESSION SO MUCH
IN IN THE SENSE THAT THE A FIRE
IN SOME CASES IS A GOOD THING
AND THAT'S PART OF THE
PREVENTION AND FORCED HEALTH-
SIDE OF THINGS AND SO. THERE
THERE IS NEED TO BE BALANCED BUT
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
- PROPOSAL ON THE FIRE
PROTECTION SIDE OF THINGS IS
REALLY ABOUT TRYING TO MAINTAIN
EXISTING CAPACITY. I THINK IT'S
BEEN KIND OF WELL DOCUMENTED NOT
PARTY TO LEARN ALL THE DETAIL.
THE CONDITIONS THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE DEALING WITH
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT. ARE JUST
NOT SUSTAINABLE AND WE NEED TO
DO SOME THINGS TO SUPPORT. THE
FIREFIGHTERS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN. EVEN JUST
THE LEVEL OF. CAPACITY WE HAVE
NOW. FOR FIRE PROTECTION- FROM
FIRE PREVENTION STANDPOINT WE
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT THIS IS A
IT'S A LONG TERM. ISSUE IT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO THE
STATE'S GOING TO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS TO COME. OF
THE WAY WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT IS
THERE IS THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS YOU'RE WELL AWARE OF THE
G. G. R. AFTER HE'S BEEN CAN
CHOOSE THE APPROPRIATE NOW AS A
PART OF LAST YEAR'S TRAILER
BILL. EFFORTS SO THERE'S A
DEGREE OF ONGOING FUNDING THERE
AND THEN A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE THINGS THAT YOU KNOW. WE'RE
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO GET A GOOD
HANDLE I THINK. ON THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING THAT'S NECESSARY TO
SUSTAIN IT. THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SCENERY DID A GOOD JOB TALKING
ABOUT THE SPRINT VERSUS
MARATHON. AND I MISS MORRIS
REALLY WORK. TALK ABOUT THAT
ANALOGY I THINK WERE LOOKING
DOING. FIGURE OUT. WITH A COUPLE
OF YEARS OF INVESTMENT AND THE
OUTCOMES THAT COME FROM THAT AS
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT.
MEASURE THAT. THAT WE'LL GET A
BETTER IDEA OF THE LEVEL SUSTAIN
FUNDING THAT'S NECESSARY AN ON
GOING BASIS. TO MEET OUR GOAL OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
ANNUALLY BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND I'M GOING TO. HAPPEN IS I
THINK IT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS IN TRYING
TO GET THEIR- INVESTMENTS IN
THEIR WORK ON. ON THEIR SIDE
WITH YOU KNOW THE NATIONAL FIVE
THOUSAND ACRE FROM THEIR SIDE-
I'VE AND SEEING. WHERE OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF FUNDING PLANS
US AND BEING ABLE TO ASSESS WHAT
REALLY IS THE TRUE BASELINE
AMOUNT FUNDING THAT'S NEEDED NON
GOING BASIS FOR FIRE PREVENTION.
HIS CURRENT. BALANCE WE'RE
TRYING TO STRIKE. ALL RIGHT BUT
THERE'S JUST NO WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
FOR ONE YEAR OR TWO YEARS EACH
YEAR VERSUS. NINE HUNDRED
MILLION FOREVER AND EVER SO
THERE'S THAT THIS KRISTIN. WITH
A RALLY- CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN US.
FROM THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US. I
YOU AGAIN- FOR LIKE IT'S
PROVIDES INCOME- SO WE ALL DID
OUR- ON WITH OUR- REPORT WE
DIDN'T. ON AND THE VARIOUS MAJOR
WHILE RESPONSE PROPOSAL THAT ARE
IN THE BUDGET AGAIN THAT'S
PRETTY AND IT'S VERY WELL
SUMMARIZED IN YOUR AGENDA AND
IT'S AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
I'LL JUST SOME REASON OF OUR
ASSESSMENT AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WE PROVIDED BASICALLY AN
OVERALL ISN'T OVERLY SHE'S
REALLY JUST A CONSIDERATION AS
WELL AS SOME SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON THE
INDIVIDUAL B. C. P. THAT YOU'RE
HEARING AS PART OF THIS ITEM.
THE OVERALL AND WE DEFINITELY
THINK THAT ADDITIONAL RESPONSE
CAPACITY YEAH MAKES SENSE WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF- VERY LARGE AND
SEVERE WILDFIRES IN RECENT YEARS
WELL WE CAN'T FIRE FIGHTER WAY
OUT OF THEM. THAT SEEM LIKE THIS
IS AN AREA THAT THAT COULD USE
SOME ADDITIONAL FOCUS. AND WE'VE
CERTAINLY SEEN AS AS WAS
MENTIONED- BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS THE STRAIN THAT THESE
FIRES HAVE CUT ON RESPONSE
CAPACITY AND OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
HOWEVER WE DO FIND OVERALL THAT
THE PROPOSAL'S ON. DO YOU RESULT
IN A VERY LARGE INCREASE IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE BASE BUDGET FOR
FIRE PROTECTION ROUGHLY 33%
ROUGHLY A THIRD- FOR CALIFORNIA.
I INVESTED THAT'S ON GOING ON
AND THIS IS ON TOP OF REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES THE
DEPARTMENT HAS SEEN IN RECENT
YEARS ALREADY- INITIALLY CENTER
CLEAR TO US THE EXTENT TO WHICH
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS WOULD
ENHANCE RESPONSE CAPACITY AND
OVER WHAT TIME FRAME AND WE
THINK THOSE ARE REALLY IMPOTANT
QUESTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE CAN
MAKE SURE IT'S GETTING. KIND OF
MOST FOR ITS DOLLARS. AND
FINALLY WE THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT. FOR THE STATE TO HAVE
THE STRATEGIC WILDFIRE PLAN TO
GUIDE ITS FUNDING ALLOCATIONS-
AND ASTHMA'S MENTIONED- YOU KNOW
IN THIS CONVERSATION. ON THE
LEGISLATURE DID TAKE SOME
ACTIONS TO TRY TO GET THAT
INFORMATION THIS- BY REQUIRING
REPORT IS PART SOMEONE RECORDING
LANGUAGE. AND NOW WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO IDENTIFY RESPONSE CAPACITY
GAPS COST EFFECTIVE APPROACHES
AND GOALS FOR THE STATE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY- WOULD BE REALLY
VALUABLE STILL. ASSEMBLY REALLY
ANY OTHER OF THAT PLANET IT'S
ALL THAT CHALLENGING THE
LEGISLATURE WE STAY THINK YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY. SO NEEDS TO MAKE
DECISIONS- WE DO PROVIDE SOME
SPACE. WHEN WE CAN GROUP
PROPOSAL. I KNOW THERE ARE A LOT
OF THEM IT'S HARD TO IT'S- HARD
TO. OF KEEP TRACK OF THEM-
ALMOST AND I. KNOW THEIR- I IT'S
A LOT IN WE TRIED TO GO. THEM
HEALTH CLINIC A LITTLE BIT YOU.
THERE'S THAT WE SUGGESTED RECKON
. THAT WE ARE. A PER. ON THOSE
ONES WE THOUGHT WERE RE. SO THAT
WE ARE WE ARE COMMITTING
WITHHOLDING. ON IT DOESN'T. THAT
RELY ON FINDING AS WAS MENTIONED
SPENDING WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
DETAILS ON THAT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION. AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT AND THEN-
THERE'S SOME INFORMATION WE
RECOMMEND JOHNSON PROPOSAL VERY
RECOMMEND HAVING DEPARTMENTS
REPORTS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
CENTERS OF APPROVING- ONE THAT
WE ARE COMMITTED PRETTY WITH A
CONTRACT COUNTY PROPOSAL I DON'T
THINK THERE AND THAT ONE MAY NOT
OF BEEN SUMMARIZED FOR THAT. FOR
THE COMMITTEE YEAH- BUT THAT ONE
IS RELATED TO YOU FUNDING. YOU
CAN CRUISE- IN THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT THAT. THE.
STATE HAS HISTORICALLY DONE.
EXPAND THE STATE'S. ROLE IN
FINDING. CRAZY THINK THAT.
UNREASONABLE OF THE SCREENS FOR.
TO MAKE SOME LAMP- FUNCTIONS FOR
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. FIFTY WE
THINK IT'S- READ. THAT FOR THE
STATE OF OUR- SOME FUNDING THIS
. THOSE AND TWO PROPOSALS WERE
WITHHOLD ACTION BECAUSE THEY-
TWO GROUPS OF PROPOSALS BECAUSE
THEY- INTERACT WITH CORNER
MILLION WE TALK ABOUT THEM JUST
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF DETAIL. ON
IT'S REALLY HARD TO. SORT OF GET
OUR HEADS AROUND HIM. IT'S HARD
TO SORT OF PROCESS- BECAUSE WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE MUCH IN THE
WAY DETAILS WERE EXPECTING THAT.
HOPEFULLY IN THAT SPRING- BUT
THOSE PROPOSALS INCLUDE THE
EMERGENCY SEARCH CAPACITY
PROPOSAL AS- FINANCE MENTIONS.
THE ONE. RELATED TO YOU- YOU
KNOW ITS ENGINES HELICOPTERS.
AND OTHERS. AND THAT WAY AND THE
STAFFING FOR THE HELICOPTERS IS
INCLUDED IN THAT OTHER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION. I THINK ABOUT
THOSE TOGETHER YEAH CAN I TAKE
ACTION ON THE ON THE HELICOPTERS
BEFORE YOU FIGURE OUT. HOW WE'RE
NOT AND YOU KNOW THE FUNDING I'M
KIND FOR STOPPING THEM. AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S A
PARTICULARLY TOUGH ONE AND WE IN
OUR MINDS TO IT REALLY. FAST
WITHOUT THIS KIND OF STRATEGIC
WELFARE PLAN. SO WE SIT WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING TO TAKE YOU THINK ABOUT IT
OPTIONS THE ULTIMATELY WANTS TO-
FINDS THAT PROPOSAL COULD DO IT
IN WHOLE OR IN PART. AND THEN
THERE. ARE SOME ALTERNATIVES FOR
EXAMPLE ONE POTENTIAL THING
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IS.
APPROVING SOME OF THE- SOME OF
THEM RESOURCES NOW HOLDINGS I'M
OFF ON SOME OF THEM CONTINGENT
ON THAT REPORT- WEEKS. WE AND- I
KNOW THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
HELICOPTERS WILL TAKE ABOUT A
YEAR EACH TEAM. FOR THE STATE TO
RECEIVE THEIR FOR. THAT ARE-
THAT ARE BEING. PROPOSED AND SO
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD NECESSARILY
SLOW DOWN THE ACQUISITION OF
THOSE BECAUSE IT'S GONNA TAKE
US. TWO YEARS TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM AND THEN FOUR YEARS TO
GET FORM EITHER WAY- SO THE
SECOND PROPONENTS ANSWER
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU TO
PROPOSALS- ARE THAT STATIC. THE
CONSERVATION CORPS PROPOSALS.
THOSE ONES ALSO ARE IN YOUR
STANDING BASED ON PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS IS THAT SOME OF
THAT. THE STAFF TO SUPERVISE
THOSE- CCC CREWS- ARE ALSO
FUNDED AS PART OF A FOUR YEAR
MILLION SAID IT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING. UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THOSE ARE ALSO LINKED AND
SO AGAIN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT WE THINK IT'S
PRETTY REASONABLE- FOR CCC TO
HAVE. AND SOME ADDITIONAL PARKER
CAPACITY THAT CAN PROVIDE SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT BENEFITS. AGAIN
WE CAN FOR YOU YOU'RE GOING TO
WANT TO THINK ABOUT THAT. IN THE
CONTEXT OF THAT. FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL. I AND
REGARD TO THE PROPOSAL WE CAN
GET THE- REPORT. IS MERITED. I'M
ONE OF THEM IS THAT. AND I DON'T
WE TO ABOUT THIS ONE AS WELL
THAT PRIOR TO. SO PROPOSAL THAT
PROVIDE. WHERE PROVIDE AND NEW.
NEW A- AND SOME OTHER EQUIPMENT-
AT TO A CAL. TRAINING CENTER-
WE'RE RECOMMENDING REPORT-
REQUIRING HEALTH CARE TO REPORT
WHY DOES NEW TRAINING AND ARE
NEEDED THAT IT APPEARS TO US
THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN USE
RESERVE ENGINES ARE ENGINES THAT
MIGHT BE SURPLUS OTHERWISE. I'M
TO MEET THAT PURPOSE- WE THINK
THAT DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ARTICULATE THE SPECIFIC-
CONSEQUENCES OF NOT HAVING NEW
ENGINES FOR THAT NEED- ABSENT
COMPLYING RATIONAL- REJECTING
THOSE. ON THAT FIRE IS PROPOSAL
AT THE WHEN AND YOU HEARD ABOUT
FRIENDS- WE ASKED WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT- YES AND TELL HER TO
REPORT. FIND ALL DONE AN
ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
FIND- THE PROGRAM ACT. BACK
THROUGH THE LISTING LEVEL OF
SERVICE AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EXISTING LEVEL SERVICE ACTUALLY
COVERS BOTH HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND ACTUALLY
INCLUDES- TWO PLANES ALTHOUGH
ONE OF THEM MS. OR ANYTHING OF
THE TWELVE ARE COMMISSION
WEDNESDAY TWENTY FOUR HOUR
COVERAGE BUT I THINK THAT THE
WAY THEY ARE ABLE TO SCHEDULE
THEM IN SEQUENCE THAT THANK YOU
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE
COVERAGE- THAT'S BEEN REALLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE. I SO.
THEY ARE MINE THERE IT'S- THAT
DEPARTMENT HAVEN'T PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT. AS TO WHY. THIS LIVE
OF SERVICE. I'M WOULD BE NICE-
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT THIS
ALSO- ALREADY HAS ACT TO OTHER.
TO OF TECHNO. FOR EXAMPLE
MILITARY. WE CAN PROVIDE BOTH
MANNED AND- AND I MANAGE-
DROWNED COVERAGE. ON THAT
SOMEWHAT SOME. AND THEN- ALSO WE
NOTE THAT THE LEVEL COVERAGE WE
EXPECT BE SICK. CHEAPER THE
PROPOSAL FOR EXAMPLE IN THERE
THAT WEREN'T COUNTY THEY THERE'S
AN ESTIMATE ORANGE COUNTY COULD
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE. EXISTING
LEVEL OF SERVICE ROUGHLY
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS A SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN THE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
PROPOSED. FINALLY ON THAT CADDY
PROPOSAL AND HE TYLER- AND-
MISTER TAYLOR MENTIONED. AS WELL
THAT'S THE ONE AND- REGARDING
YOUR PUTTING AND- CATENAE YELL
ON THE REMAINING SLEEP RIGHT NOW
IT'S JUST ON THE FRONTLINE-
BATTERY THAT ABL IS ON THE
FRONTLINE EQUIPMENT. ON THAT
WOULD BE EXPANDED TO ALL THE
FLEETS AND EXTRACT I'M TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED. RIGHT NOW TWENTY
X. TWELVE HUNDRED TO GO TO
ANOTHER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED. I NEED TO BE
REPLACED EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
ALSO REFRESHING- KEPT THEIR CAD
SYSTEM AS WELL- ON THAT ONE
RECOMMENDING THE DEPARTMENT
REPORT ON THE BENEFIT. OF
EXPANDING IT TO EVERY VEHICLE
RIGHT SO NOT JUST THE FRONT LINE
VEHICLES. BUT YOU KNOW EVERY CAR
THEN ACTINIUM NOTE THE ADL'S
ADDED WHEN YOU CARDS ARE
PURCHASED SO I'M YOU KNOW
THERE'S ACTUALLY GONNA BE EVERY
FRESH AS PART OF THAT- REFRESH
AND JUST WHEN YOU KNOW CARS ARE
CHANGED OUT BECAUSE THEY GOT
OLDER SO. IT'S NOT GOING TO ASK
WHY- THAT REFRESH RATE WOULD BE
NECESSARY AND- NO REALLY IT'S
PRETTY EXPENSIVE ARE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. IT'S MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
VEHICLE AND AGAIN IF YOU'RE
EXPANDING IT- TO ANOTHER TWENTY
FOUR SORRY ANOTHER TWELVE
HUNDRED VEHICLES- AND THEN
REFRESHING EVERY FIVE YEARS IT
STARTS ADDING UP QUITE A BIT. SO
WE THINK IT'S WORTH HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE SEEING IT OPTIONS ON
THAT AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
ARE- FOR BOTH EXPANDING IT- ALL
OF THOSE VEHICLES AS WELL AS
DOING THAT REFRESH RATE. SO
THOSE ARE AT ARMS OVERALL AND I
KNOW THAT WAS A LIE-
COMPREHENSIVE- I KNOW THAT MY-
HAVE QUESTIONS. I WAS REMISS
AFTER NUMBER. I NEED TO- AND-
THE PHONE AN AXE CODE SINCE. ARE
NOT HAVING A TELEVISED OR VISUAL
SCREEN SO THAT CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AN AX SIX
CODE IS THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY ONE
TWO EIGHT THREE CENTER DOLLY YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. HE'S I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ACTUALLY SO I WANT TO
JUST BACK UP TO THE- THE FIGURES
SO YOU THINK YOU CALL IT IS THE-
RADIO SYSTEM. OUR TRACKING
SYSTEM- AND I KNOW THAT-
DIRECTOR GHILARDUCCI A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE DID THE NINE ONE
ONE FEE WHICH WAS SUPPOSED TO IN
REAL TIME BE ABLE TO DURING THE
FIRES- COMMUNICATE WITH- PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY THROUGH THEIR
PHONES- SO AND THAT'S A PART OF
MONEY THAT IS. ANNUALLY COMING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HOW- DO THESE TWO PROGRAMS WORK
TOGETHER OR IS. THIS A LOT OF
MONEY AND IT'S ALSO
APPROPRIATED. OVER TIME IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT GOING AWAY THE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT. HOW MANY HOW
MANY VEHICLES ACTUALLY HAVE TO
HAVE IT IN THERE AND IF IT
COORDINATES WITH THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE UPGRADING
AS WELL. AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION WOULD BE- THE INMATE
CREWS THAT WE HAVE- ARE
DECLINING BECAUSE A PROP 47-57-
AND WHAT'S THE AVAILABILITY OF
GETTING THESE CREWS THAT- I KNOW
THE SENATOR MCGUIRE AND I ARE
WORKING ON TRYING TO GET SOME
LEGISLATION TO- THEY BELIEVE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY AND AT. TRAINED
UP AND READY TO GO- FOR THIS
FIRE SEASON. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE THAT- CHIEF. CORYTON
DIRECTOR YEAH HI GUYS MARC HERE
SO THANKS FOR THE QUESTION I- I
AM GOING TO- PICTURED OVERHEAD
TO JOE BECAUSE THIS IS AN ISSUE
WHERE THEY EIGHTY L. IT IS TIED
INTO THEIR- CAD SYSTEM WHICH IS
PART OF THE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM-
BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT THAT THAT
IS A HARDWARE AND CAPABILITY-
THAT IS NOT FUNDED THROUGH THE-
THROUGH THE NIGHT AT ONE ONE-
SET NOW FEET ENHANCEMENTS THAT
THEN I WENT SENATE THE
ENHANCEMENTS WHAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT- IS ENHANCING-
THAN I WOULD WANT ITS IT'S-
TEXTED NINE ONE ONE IT'S
REFRESHING ALL THE- EQUIPMENT
IT'S THE ABILITY TO HAVE- A
BETTER. COMMUNICATIONS LINKAGE
TO THE CADS EVENT OUT TO THE
FIELD AND SO- THIS THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEING REQUESTED HERE IS-
AND UPGRADE OF THAT TECHNOLOGY
IN THE CAD SYSTEM WHICH OUT
ALTERED. OVER TO JOE. YEAH THANK
YOU YOUR RECORD SHE- CENTERED ON
MY- I THOUGHT THE FIRST
QUESTIONS ARE T THE OTHER BY
FROM BUT SPECIFIC ACADEMY L. IT
IS REALLY AN ACCOUNT. TO AND-
DYNAMIC DISPATCHING A TOOL THAT
ALLOWS OUR EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTERS AND OUR INCIDENT
COMMANDERS ON THE GROUND TO BE
ABLE TO SEE WHERE OUR RESOURCES
ARE CROSS CALIFORNIA. IT
PROVIDES CRITICAL INFORMATION ON
THE MOBILE DATA TERMINAL THAT IS
INSIDE THE VEHICLE- THEY CAN-
SEND INFORMATION PUSH TO WAY
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
COMMAND CENTERS AND- THE
VEHICLES ON THE GROUND. AS I
SAID EARLIER- IT WAS INCLUDED
ONLY IN THE FRONTLINE VEHICLES
BUT CAL FIRE SEES ITSELF AS A AS
A TOTAL FORCE ORGANIZATION
BETWEEN. THE OFFICE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL- ARE RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM- ARE SUPPORT STAFF. AND
AND FIRE PROTECTION AND SO OF
THOSE PERSONNEL- WILL COME OUT
OF THEIR OFFICES AND THEY WILL
BE ONLINE AS WELL IN THOSE LATE
MEDIAN UTILITY VEHICLES. THAT
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE CATTERY BL
IN THEM- TO- TO BE ABLE TO-
TRACK AS WELL- I HOPE THAT AND-
YOUR QUESTION AS PART TO OF
YOUR- WE DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN- IN. THE INMATE
FIREFIGHTING FORCE ACROSS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION- UTILIZING THEIR
SPRING POP REPORT TO EVALUATE.
OPTIONS TO BOLSTER- ARE HAND
CREWS AVAILABLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE DO THAT IN
COORDINATION WITH CDC ARE WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH- DIRECTOR
SIDE- IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS- WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT- AS WELL AS
OUR OWN FIREFIGHTER HAND CREWS
TO TRY TO MAXIMIZE THE
AVAILABILITY OF. RESOURCES
ACROSS. THE STATE AVAILABLE TO
THAT NOW SPECIFIC TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT- A PROPOSAL- FOR
MORE HAND CREWS- AT THIS POINT
SO WE WOULD HOPE AND CONSIDER
THAT- AS WE GO THROUGH THE
SPRING- THE THAT- HAND CREWS
WILL BE DISCUSSED. AS PART OF
THAT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. THANK YOU SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
MISTER CHAIR IN NO QUESTIONS TO
SOME COMMENTS REALLY QUICKLY AND
OBVIOUSLY LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING IF THERE'S A COMING BACK
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINACE
OR- ANY THE AGENCIES FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS QUITE COMMON IN THE
FIRES PROGRAM I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE MOVE FORWARD ON
THAT AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO
HELP STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS
BUT I KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BE A
AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE DISCUSSED APPRECIATE
THAT. DIRECTOR BRING THAT
FORWARD IN I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THE CHAIR THAT WE CAN'T
FIGHT OUR WAY OUT OF THIS CRISIS
THAT RAIN IT'S GOING TO TAKE
MULTIPLE STRATEGIES TO BE A TO
COMBAT THIS CRISIS OF MEGA FIRES
IN THE STATE BUT I ALSO AS- THE
L. A. O. SAID WE NEED TO ENHANCE
RESPONSE TIMES ACROSS THE STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO CAL FIRE AND
I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF TELLING
STORIES BUT I TELL ONE THAT IS
SIXTY SECONDS. AND IT HAPPENS
ALMOST EVERY YEAR HERE DURING
WILDFIRE SEASON WHETHER IT'S
DIRECTOR PIMLOTT OR DIRECTOR
PORTER. AND SENATE AGAIN STATION
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. AND
THERE IS A COMMUNITY THAT IS
THREATENED BY WILDFIRE. CALLING
DIRECTOR PROMOTE INDIAN DIRECTOR
PORTER. DURING THE WALBRIDGE
FIRE THERE ARE NO FIREFIGHTERS
AVAILABLE. COLIN DURING THE
GLASS FIRE THERE ARE NO
FIREFIGHTERS AVAILABLE CONDOM
DURING THE TUBBS FIRE THERE WERE
NO FIRES AVAILABLE. IN THIS
STORY. THERE'S BEEN SO MANY
TIMES IN THE STATE'S RECENT
HISTORY OVER THE LAST DECADE
WHERE CALLS HAVE BEEN MADE
WHETHER IT'S HERE IN STATE. TO
OUR NEIGHBORING WESTERN STATES
AND FIREFIGHTERS SIMPLY AREN'T
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
TAPPED IN CALIFORNIA HAS THE
GOLD STANDARD GOLD STANDARD OF
FIREFIGHTING FORCES CALIFORNIA
INTERVIEW JULIE SYSTEM BUT
HERE'S MY FRUSTRATION. WE ALL
KNOW IN WE'VE KNOWN. FOR YEARS
NOW THAT CAL FIRE IS AND STEPPED
UP TO MEET THE DANGEROUS REALITY
THAT THE STATE FACES WITH
WILDFIRES. YET WE CONTINUE TO
PUT BANDAIDS ON A PROBLEM ON A
PROBLEM THAT IS A GAPING WOND.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT STAFFING
UNITED STATES FOR SERVICE RIGHT
NOW EVERY YEAR HAS AT LEAST
THREE PEOPLE ON THE RANGE AT
LEAST THREE. MOST MUNICIPAL
DEPARTMENTS MOST FIRE DISTRICTS
HAVE AT LEAST THREE PEOPLE PER
ENGINE. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS FLEE THEY HAVE
MAYBE TWO AND A HALF TWO POINT
SEVEN. DO WE PASSED A FEW YEARS
AGO A COUPLE YEARS AGO. THIRTEEN
ENGINES THIRTEEN ENGINES OUT OF
CAL FIRE HAS THREE POINT ONE ONE
STAFF. THIRTEEN NOW WE WANNA DIG
INTO THE DETAILS THERE'S ABOUT
THREE EARNED FORTY TO THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY ENGINES THAT DON'T
. THEY HAVE ABOUT TWO POINT FIVE
TO TWO POINT SEVEN. NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BROUGHT
FOR THE PROPOSAL TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL OFFICER
POSITIONS BUT WE FUNDED ONE YEAR
OF THAT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO. WE STILL NEED
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO RELEASE STAFFING. NEEDS
ARE JUST OFFICER POSITIONS. YET
WE CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE LIKE WE
DID LAST YEAR THE HIRING OF
TWELVE HUNDRED SEASONAL
POSITIONS FOR HAND CREWS. THAT'S
GREAT. BUT IT'S A HEADLINE AND
IT'S NOT TELLING THE TRUTH STORY
ABOUT THE CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTER
SHORTAGE. THE REAL STORY IS
THIS. WERE SHORT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED. OFFICER POSITIONS TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO OVER THREE-
STAFFING ON ENGINES. NUMBER TWO
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE REAL
STORIES THIS WEEK LOS FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED INMATE.
INMATES IN FIRE CREWS. AND WE
HAVEN'T MADE HIM UP YET. YEAH WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE TWELVE HUNDRED
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS BUT- IT'S
NOT GOING TO DO THE JOB WITH THE
REALITY THAT WE ALL LIVE IN. WE
NEED IMMEDIATE INVESTMENT WE
NEED AN IMMEDIATE SIXTEEN HAND
CREWS LIKE WE DID LAST YEAR WE
NEED TO DOUBLE WHAT THIS YEAR.
EACH OF THOSE HAVE FORTY EIGHT
FIREFIGHTERS. WE NEED ENGINES UP
TO FULL STAFFING JUST LIKE OUR
FEDERAL SISTERS AND BROTHERS
ALONG WITH OUR MUNICIPAL
AGENCIES. AND- AND I'LL JUST SAY
THIS. IT'S ABOUT RESPONSE TIME
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF FIREFIGHTERS. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT NO ONE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT. BUT WE NEED TO BE
OPEN AND HONEST AND BLUNT ABOUT
. THIS SEVERE SHORTAGE THAT WE
HAVE YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
IT'S PUTTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY FIREFIGHTERS AT RISK.
THEY'RE WORKING FORTY DAYS IN A
ROW FIFTY DAYS IN A ROW THAT A
SINGLE DAY OFF. THEIR DEPLOYED
AN INCREDIBLY DRAMATIC POSITION
AT CONDITIONS YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND BY THE WAY I'VE
SAT ON THIS COMMITTEE. GOD I
DON'T KNOW FOUR YEARS FIVE YEARS
AND WE STILL KEEP TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE NEED FOR FIREFIGHTERS
AND NOTHING'S ENOUGH. WE CAN'T
DO ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER WE
GOTTA FONG WE HAVE TO FIND A AS
THE DETERMINE HAS SO ELOQUENTLY
STATED IN HIS LEAD THIS
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE TO FIND.
PREVENTIVE MEASURES AND WE HAVE
TO FIND ENHANCE STAFFING FOR
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS. THIS IS AN AWFUL
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS ARE THE
LAST FOUR YEARS TO MEET FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND MENTAL HEALTH
CALLS. FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
MENTAL HEALTH COSTS. LAST YEAR
WAS THE FIRST YEAR IN THIS
NATION'S HISTORY. WHERE SUICIDE
. LED IN DEATH OVER ON THE JOB
THE COUNTIES. YET YEAR AFTER
YEAR WE TALK ABOUT THE NEED FOR
MORE FIREFIGHTERS. TURN OFF IS
ENOUGH. WE GOT TO START TALKING
ABOUT THE REAL STORY WE GOT TO
BE OPEN AND HONEST ABOUT IT NOW
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IT'S- TO BE
DETERMINED IN THE BUDGET. LOOK
THIS FOUR HUNDRED MILLION I'M
WORRIED THIS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION THERE IS YET TO BE
ALLOCATED SET ASIDE IT'S GOING
TO GO I THINK TO BE GOING DOWN
FROM SEVENTY TWO HOURS A FIFTY
SIX HOURS PER CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS THAT'S GREAT. BUT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO LEAVE ANY
ROOM FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
NINE INTER RIGHT HERE IN MISTER
CHAIR YOU HAVE BEEN SO WONDERFUL
TO LET ME TALK AND I'M SORRY
BOTTOM LINE. NUMBER ONE RATHER
THAN JUST PUT HER FNGER IN THE
AIR EVERY FREAKING YEAR AND
START FIGURING OUT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO WHEN IT COMES TO STAFFING.
WE NEED A STAFFING PLAN THIS
LEGISLATURE NEEDS A STAFFING
PLAN WHEN IT COMES TO CATCH FIRE
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THE REALITY THAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW. FOURTEEN THE
LARGEST TWENTY WILDFIRES HAVE
HIT THE STATE IN THE LAST DECADE
THIRTY BILLION IN INSURED LOSSES
HAVE HIT THE STATE IN
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY. FIRE SEASONS COMBINED.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT RESPONSE IT
ALSO HAVE TO BE HAS TO BE ABOUT
PREVENTION WE CAN'T DO ONE
WITHOUT THE OTHER. IN WILDFIRES
ARE CHANGING THE WAY THAT THIS
STATE LIVES NEVER BEFORE IN MY
LIFETIME HAVE KIDS HAD TO BE OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR WEEKS ON END DUE
TO SMOKE DAIS. THIS REALITIES
GOING TO GET WORSE. AND IT SHAME
ON US IF WE DON'T MOVE
PROACTIVELY TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE
YOUR RESPONSE TIMES TO BE ABLE
TO ADD ADDITIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
AND CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
PREVENTION. AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET THERE IN THIS BUDGET- AND I
WOULD ASK. THAT BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OBVIOUSLY THE
LEGISLATURE WORK TOGETHER NOT
JUST ON EASONAL FIREFIGHTERS
BUT ACTUALLY GOING TO WHAT THE
FEDS IN OUR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
HAVE BEEN. FOCUSED ON IN THAT'S
GOING TO THREE PEOPLE PER FIRE
ENGINE IN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RESEARCHER THUNDERSTORMS EVER
QUESTION. I DO JUST BRIEFLY GO
AS EXTENSIVE AS LAST. I GOT
CANNELLA. JOHN YEAH I HAVE NO
LIFE OKAY I'M ON THANK YOU- I
WOULD I CAN'T STATE ANY MORE
ELOQUENTLY THAN. THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NORTH JUST DID
SO. OUT OF HIS BOTTOM LINE IS
HEARD- HURTING BECAUSE WE'RE
OPERATING IN A MINDSET OF
SCARCITY- IN A TIME OF ABUNDANCE
AND WE DON'T NEED TO.
SHORTCHANGE MARC COMMUNITIES OR
OR THE BRAVE WOMEN AND MEN WHO
FIGHT THESE FIRES- I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S ACTUALLY A NUMBER I
SAW ON OUR ANALYSIS THEY WERE. I
THINK IT'S SEVENTY NINE HUNDRED
CALLS THAT WERE NOT ANSWERED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. C. MINISTRATION
OF A NUMBER OF. THAT THAT NUMBER
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE HOW MANY
CALLS WERE NOT ANSWERED. ACTING
CHIEF FIVE TYLER DO YOU HAVE A
NUMBER ON THAT ACCOUNT FOR.
CALLS THAT WERE ANSWERED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE SENATOR
STERN- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- RELATED TO SEVENTY
NINE HUNDRED CALLS UNANSWERED BE
REFERRING TO EMERGENCY RESPONSES
ARE UNABLE TO FILL REQUESTS.
HERE IT SAYS IN OUR ANALYSIS
HERE- AND YOUR DATA ROUGHLY
SEVEN HUNDRED QUEST FOR FIRE
ENGINES NINE HUNDRED QUEST FOR
DOZERS SIX AND REQUEST FOR
HELICOPTERS COULD NOT BE ILLED
SO I JUST WONDERED IF. WE HAD AN
UPDATE- HOW LAST YEAR WAS
LOOKING ON THAT FRONT. I WILL
CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT STAFF HAVE
BEEN WORKING OUT I WILL
CERTAINLY GET THAT GRAPH FOR YOU
AND- HAVE A SENT OVER. OKAY
THANK YOU- I CAN I FOLLOW UP
ALSO I DON'T KNOW IF THIS. GOES
BACK TO CAL FIRE- YES. BUT- I
WANTED TO GIVE A CHANCE FOR YOU
ALL TO DEFEND- THE PROPOSALS ON-
THE MUTUAL AID FIRE FLEET- AS
WELL AS SOME OF THIS EMERGENCY
SURGE CAPACITY- YOU KNOW WE
DISCUSS SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
BUT- IF ANYONE WANTS TO COMMENT
ON THOSE ITEMS- AND EXACTLY HOW
THEY FUNCTION LIKE IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE- THIS MUTUAL AID FLEET- HOW
WOULD THAT IMPACT THE STATE- IN
ITS ABSENCES THE SAME WITH THE
SURGE CAPACITY. ERECTOR
GHILARDUCCI IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE MUTUAL AID FOR WEEKS
AND THEN I WILL TAKE THE SURGE
CAPACITY. SOUNDS GOOD JOE THANKS
SO THANKS FOR THE QUESTION- SO
THAT THE- YES FIRE FLEET- WHICH
IS A- A SYSTEM THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE IN NINETEEN FIFTIES-
REALLY WAS A POST. COLD WAR-
SORT OF. INITIATIVE TO ENSURE
BACK BEYOND ANY EMERGENCY OR
DISASTER. THAT WOULD BEFALL THE
STATE. WHERE WE WOULD HAVE
IMPACTS TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEY WERE RESPONDING
ACCORDINGLY THAT- FOR ALL HAZARD
SITUATIONS WHETHER IT BE
EARTHQUAKE OR FIRE OR FLOOD- OR
ACT OF TERRORISM- THAT WE WOULD
HAVE. AN ADDITIONAL CAPACITY TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND AND SUPPORT
OF THE OPERATION NOW THE UNIQUE
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM I DON'T
HAVE- AFTER SO BUT I USE IT ALL
THE TIME JUST YOU KNOW. BIRDS
YEAH. I THINK SHOULD BE OUT OF
MY CAR YEAH I THINK WAS ON ZOOM
THEIR DIRECTOR BUT IT OVERSEE
THE UNIQUENESS OF THIS PROGRAM
IS THAT- WHAT WE DO IS WE TAKE
THESE ENGINES ARE ALL RISK ALL
HAZARD ENGINES CAPABLE OF
RESPONDING TO ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF EVENTS AND THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WE ASSIGN THEM TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS SO BASICALLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATION WE HAVE
AN AGREEMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN USE THE
ENGINE AS A SECONDARY ENGINE IF
THEY NEED TO PART LOCAL RESPONSE
BUT IN ESSENCE WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT WHEN I'M DISASTER OR
EMERGENCY OCCURS THE STATE OF
SIGNIFICANCE. WHAT WE NEED TO
ACTIVATE THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
THE ON ACTIVATING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE UNITS WE ARE
ALSO ACTIVATING THOSE- YES
ENGINES AIRFORCE FORCE
MULTIPLIER AND THE AGREEMENT IS
THAT THERE THEN STAFFED WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIREFIGHTERS SO
THEY BECOME NOW. QUOTE UNQUOTE
THE STATE'S FIRE. SURE AND WE
MOVED. AROUND THE STATE TO
ADVANCE WHATEVER THEY ARE AND WE
TYPICALLY REIMBURSE THOSE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS FOR THEIR PERSONNEL
ONLY WHEN WE USE THAT- AND WE
REIMBURSE THEM THROUGH WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH CDA OR THROUGH
FEDERAL DISASTER FUNDS OR
THROUGH. IF IN THE EVENT THAT
THE RESPONDING TO A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY OR YOUR FIRE I
COULD BE IN THE KALIFORNIA A
PROGRAM OR U. S. FOREST SERVICE.
SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS TO REIMBURSE THE
FIREFIGHTERS WHEN THEY'RE
DEPLOYED. BUT THE- BUT THE
OVERALL PROGRAM WHICH IS-
DOESN'T EXIST ANY OTHER PLACE IN
THE WORLD- PROVIDERS WITH
RESTORE NUMBER OF ENGINES. WE
ARE. WE'RE. CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN TYPE ONE
ENGINES SIXTY SEVEN TYPE THREE
ENGINES SEVENTY NINE TYPE SIX
ENGINES TWELVE WATER TENDERS CAN
IN A HOST OF OTHER SUPPORT
VEHICLES RIGHT AND THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE DESIGNED ALL TO
ADDRESS THAT THAT THE KINDS OF
THREATS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
STATE AND THEN JUST FINALIZED A
SAY. WE ROUTINELY DEPLOY EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE RESOURCES-
AND IT'S GOTTEN TO THE POINT
THAT WE ARE STILL SHORT. BEYOND
NOT JUST THE- YES FLEET. BUT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE MUTUAL AID
THAT IN MULTIPLE CASES SINCE
AROUND. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ACTUALLY MOVING
FORWARD WE'VE HAD TO ROUTINELY
GO OUT OF STATE FOR MORE
RESOURCES. AND I THROUGH
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
COMPACT AND IN SOME CASES WE
GOTTA GO INTERNATIONALLY- FOR
ASSETS SO- I AM ALL ABOUT
MEDICATION BECAUSE MEDICATION IS
THAT IS THE WAY THAT WE BY DOWN
THE REST. BUT TO GET THERE RIGHT
NOW WE'RE KIND OF GOING TO A GUN
FIGHT WITH A POCKET KNIFE AND WE
NEED TO REALLY ENHANCE THAT
CAPABILITY AND IN OUR CASE
REALLY IT'S JUST MAINTAINING. A
CAPABILITY THOUGH THEY WERE NOT
ASKING FOR A NEW ENGINES WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE FLEET THAT
WE HAVE AND THEN AS THEY THEY
NEED TO BE REPLACED- HAVE A
REGULAR REPLACEMENT CYCLE WHICH
IS BASED UPON. STANDARDS SET
FORTH BY THE NATIONAL. FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION AT FTA.
SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN TO JOE.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR AND SENATOR
STERN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- UNDERSTANDING THE
FLOW OF ISSUE TWENTY THERE WERE-
BUT CHANGE PROPOSALS WE INVEST
SO I APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
I SPECIFIC TO YOUR QUESTION
OVERSEE SURGE CAPACITY IN
RESPONSE ENHANCEMENTS. IN THIS
PROPOSAL- CALIFORNIA IS
REQUESTING FOR ADDITIONAL S.
SEVENTY I. HELICOPTERS AS YOU
RECALL THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE GRACIOUS
ENOUGH TO FIND A TWELVE
HELICOPTERS SEVEN OF THOSE
HELICOPTERS ARE CURRENTLY IN
OPERATION- EIGHT THREE TWELVE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING ACCEPTED AND DELIVERY
ORDER BEING DELIVERED TO THE
VENDOR- AND IS PART OF THAT
PROPOSAL. WHILE ALL TWELVE OF
THOSE HELICOPTERS WERE CAPABLE
OF FLYING AT NIGHT FIVE OF THEM
WERE STAFFED TO FLY AT NIGHT- SO
THIS PROPOSAL AS THE ATLEO
MENTION DOES TIE INTO- FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE AND A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
REQUEST IS FOR ADDITIONAL S.
SEVENTY I. HELICOPTERS AS SURGE
CAPACITY DIFFERENT CRITICAL FIRE
WEATHER CONDITIONS THAT WE CAN
STAFF WITH ADDITIONAL PEOPLE. AS
WELL AS HAVING THESE FOUR
HELICOPTERS AVAILABLE AT AT AT
MCCLELLAN PARK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
THAT WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THREE SIXTY FIVE COVERAGE OF OUR
BLACK HAWK HELICOPTERS AS WE
BEGIN TO FLY AT NIGHT- AND IF WE
WERE ABLE TO FLY AT NIGHT WITH
ALL TEN HELICOPTERS HEALTHCARE
IS. AVIATION OFFICERS BELIEVE
THAT WE WOULD NEED THESE FOR
ADDITIONAL HELICOPTERS TO ENSURE
THAT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN COVERAGE
WHEN THOSE AIRCRAFT COME IN FOR
MAINTENANCE NOT ONLY IN THE
WINTER BUT- DURING THE SUMMER
WHEN THEY HIT CRITICAL-
INSPECTION PERIODS. THE SECOND
PIECE IS- AS WE CONTINUE TO
AWAIT THE ARRIVAL WORKING
BETWEEN THE VENDOR ON A FEDERAL
CONTRACT WITH THE UNITED STATES
AIRFORCE- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO AT A POINT IN
TWENTY THREE- SEE THIS C. ONE
THIRTY AIRCRAFT GOING TO SERVICE
BUT IN THE INTERIM- CALIFORNIA
IS PROPOSING TEN ADDITIONAL.
EXCLUSIVE. USE PRIVATE
CONTRACTED ERR AFTER A HUNDRED
TWO FIFTY DAY CON. THAT WE
ACROSS THE CALIPHATE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT- WILL. BE
DISPATCHED ON INITIAL ATTACK
WITH ANYWHERE FROM ONE THOUSAND
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED GALLONS
OF WATER CAPABILITY WHEN
DROPPING TO TRY TO REDUCE AND
MITIGATE TO THOSE INITIAL ATTACK
FIRES- LASTLY- AS IT RELATES TO
A QUICK MEANT- WE'RE REQUESTING
FIFTY FOUR. A SURGE FIRE ENGINES
THE COULD BE STAFFED WITH
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL IT'S TO PER
UNIT IN TWO IN EACH OF OUR SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES FOR A TOTAL OF
FIFTY FOUR- THAT- THAT WE AGAIN
COULD USE THOSE ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL TO STAFF UP AND HAVE
ADDITIONAL ENGINES DURING
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER
CONDITIONS- LASTLY- WAS AT TEN
ADDITIONAL BULLDOZERS BULLDOZER
TRANSPORTS AND BULLDOZER SERVICE
UNITS- THAT CAN BE PLACED ACROSS
THE STATE WE WOULD UTILIZE HEAVY
FIRE EQUIPMENT OPERATORS. TO
STAFF AND BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THOSE BULLDOZERS SPECIFICALLY-
FOR THE PURPOSES OF- CUTTING
LINE DIRECTOR INDIRECT ON FIRE
LINES AS WELL AS- PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL BULLDOZER SUPPORT
AVAILABLE- ESPECIALLY IN THIS
TIME OF REDUCED HAND CREWS ON
HAND GRAVELLE ABILITY- THAT IS
THE PROPOSAL FOR EMERGENCY SURGE. CAPACITY- EITHER SENATORS-
CHAIR HOUSE- IF BUT YOU WOULD BE
KIND- IF I COULD. TALK JUST
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE TRAINING
CENTERS IN THE CONTRACT COUNTIES
HOLLYWOOD HERE DISCRETION IF YOU
WANT NOW IS GOING TO BE MY FINAL
QUESTION ACTIONS ON THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES PIECE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR- GOING FORWARD AND
EXPANDING ON THAT WITHOUT EVEN-
US PUSHING- BUT IF THE CHAIR
WOULD INDULGES. IN MY COMMENTS
FIND SORT WE HAVE WE DO HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO GET AN OBVIOUSLY WERE
INTERESTED IN THE ALLEY-
POINTING OUT THAT NEW ENGINES.
AT THE TRAINING CENTER WHETHER
THAT'S- DESIRE. MAYBE IT'S
DESIRABLE OUT I'LL GIVE YOU THAT
. I UNDERSTAND SO I'M GONNA PASS
IT TO THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
COOPERATIVE FIRE GABRIELLE I'VE
BEEN OUT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONTRACT COUNTY. GOOD MORNING
CARACAL THREE AS- MANY MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO- THE L. A. L.
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED TO
PURCHASE. A NEW ENGINES FOR OUR
TRAINING CENTERS. OUR STUDENTS
HAVE A WE BELIEVE THAT PURCHASE
OF NEW EQUIPMENT IF NECESSARY
OUR STUDENTS NEED TO BE TRAINED
ON THE EXPORT IMPORT BANK WILL
BE UTILIZING IN THE FIELD WHEN
THEY GRADUATE FROM. THE ACADEMY
OUR EMPLOYEES UTILIZE THESE
ENGINES IN A LIVE FIRE TRAINING
SCENARIOS WHILE THEY ARE AT THE
TRAINING CENTER. AND IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THEY HAVE A
STATE SAVE OPERATING ENVIRONMENT
TO LEARN THE REQUIRED SKILLS.
THE REPURPOSED WE ARE TIRED
INGENS- YEAH THAT COULD BE
UTILIZED HAVE EXCEEDED CALPERS
REPLACEMENT CYCLE THESE ENGINES
ARE TYPICALLY TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AND MAY HAVE
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND MILES
ON THEM. THE ENGINES HAVE OLDER
TECHNOLOGY AND DIFFERENT
OPERATING SYSTEMS AND WHAT OUR
EMPLOYEES WILL BE OPERATING WHEN
THEY GRADUATE. FROM THE TRAINING
CENTERS. I'VE DEALT WITH HIGHER
ENGINES ALSO REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE TO KEEP THEM IN
SERVICE THANK JACKSON DO NOT
STAND UP AGAINST THE RIGOROUS
DEMANDS OF THE TRAINING
ENVIRONMENT. WHERE WE HAVE AN
EXPERIENCED OPERATORS LOGGING
MORE HOURS ON THE EQUIPMENT
DRIVING AND PUMPING BUT ARE
TYPICAL. OF AN ENGINE IN THE
FIELD. WE ALSO BELIEVE. THAT
THESE ENGINES ARE NOT TO BECAUSE
WE ARE MEETING DEMAND FOR
TRAINING RIGHT NOW- WE NEED TO
GET ENGINE THAT ARE CENTER. SO
THAT WE CAN RUN CONCURRENT
CLASSES AND REALLY MAKE UP FOR A-BACKLOG OF TRAINING THAT WE HAVE
TODAY- THIS ONE TIME INVESTMENT
WILL ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE- APPOINTMENT NECESSARY. TO
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE
THE REQUIRED TRAINING AT TWO OF
OUR STATE TRAINING CENTERS. I'M
ABOUT OPENING FALLS ON. PRETTY
GOOD THANKS FRED UP TONIGHT. I
WOULDN'T SAY IT WAS AN ENJOYABLE
READ ABOUT THE- CENTER TRAINING
CENTER BUT IT WAS INFORMATIVE
FIVE. FOR ME PART THAT WILL
CLOSE OUT ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
STAFFORD CONDITIONS WE HOLD IT
MATTERS OPEN THE SCHOOL THE
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
THE LEGISLATURE IN S. B. TWO S.
B. SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SIX AB
FORTY EIGHT AND A PATH. FOR
EIGHTY ONE HAS BEEN BUSY WE WANT
TO TALK ABOUT PEACE OFFICER AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENTS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
CHIEF OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH
THE- DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. DAVID YES THE- THE
MIKE IS YOURS. MORNING THANK YOU
SO MUCH. BEAR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. DAVID BASS STEPHANIE DIRECTOR
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. BUT TO GIVE YOU A
BRIEF SUMMARY RELATIVE TO THIS
BUDGET REQUEST FOR PEACE OFFICER
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENTS THAT TOOK EFFECT
JANUARY ONE. JUST A QUICK
OVERVIEW AS YOU JUST READ SHARE
WE'VE GOT SB TWO THAT WILL-
DEPARTMENTS NEED TO COMPLY WITH
WHICH EXPANDS THE AUTHORITY OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING POST AS WE ALL KNOW
WHAT TO INCLUDE ELIMINATING
CERTAIN PROVISIONS OF QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY FOR PEACE OFFICERS MORE
EXTENSIVE INVESTIGATION
PROCESSES AND A DECERTIFICATION
PROCESS OF PEACE OFFICERS UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS- PARENTS MUST
CONFIRM THAT ALL THE OFFICERS
ARE. POST CERTIFIED REVIEW PEACE
OFFICER INVESTIGATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CERTIFICATE
SUSPENSION OR REVOCATION.
RELATIVE TO SB SIXTEEN IT
CONCERNS RELEASE OF RECORDS
EXPANSE THE PIPE OF PEACE
OFFICER RECORDS ACCESSIBLE
THROUGH A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST AND REVISES THE RECORD
RETENTION PERIOD. AND PROCEDURES
REPLACE THE FIVE YEAR MINIMUM
WHICH CURRENTLY EXIST FOR THE
FIFTEEN YEAR MINIMUM FOR
SUSTAINED FINDINGS OF
MISCONDUCT. ACCESS TO RECORDS
TIME LINES AND- THE VOLUME OF
THAT WORKLOAD- WILL HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON ON
DEPARTMENTS. AB TWENTY SIX WHICH
IS RELATIVELY USE OF FORCE
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION SEVEN TWO EIGHT SIX IT
REQUIRES THAT OFFICERS
IMMEDIATELY INTERSTATE REPORT
WHEN I'M SERVING PERCEIVED
EXCESSIVE FORCE- FROM OTHER
OFFICERS- IT'LL EXPAND THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR WITNESS OFFICER
TO GO BEYOND REPORTING EXCESSIVE
FORCE FROM WHAT AT ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS YOU CONSEQUENCES
FOR AND OBSERVING OFFICER- IF
THEY DON'T TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
ACTION. AB FORTY EIGHT- HI
SPECIFICALLY TO USE OF FORCE-
REQUIRES- REPORTING COMPONENT
THAT IS MONTHLY INSTEAD OF
ANNUAL REPORTING. AND ADDRESSES
SPECIFIED USED TO FORCE
INSTANCES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND THEN FINALLY AB
FOUR EIGHT ONE. IT IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT- LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO ACQUIRE
EQUIPMENT THROUGH WHAT'S
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE TEN
THIRTY THREE PROGRAM- JUST.
CALLED MILITARY EQUIPMENT- HAVE
TO REPORT THERE'S A FUNDING
ACQUISITION AND USE REQUIREMENTS
AND REQUIRES USE OF ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL FORUM THERE A PLUGGABLE
GOVERNING BODY BEFORE THEY CAN
REQUEST TO REQUIRE THAT THE TO
ACQUIRED MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND
THIS ALSO REQUIRES SIMILAR
APPROVAL FROM DEPARTMENTS FOR
THE CONTINUED USE OF MILITARY
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY MAY HAVE
ACQUIRED PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE.
SUCH A BRIEF SYNOPSIS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE- BILLS- INCLUDED IN
THIS- ASK IS. PARDON OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION CAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS RECREATION
STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
WE'RE REQUESTING- THIRTEEN
MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR OF TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND EIGHT MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND ON GOING. THAT INCLUDES
TWENTY EIGHT POSITIONS FOURTEEN
VEHICLES TO COMPLY WITH THE
PEACE OFFICER LAW ENFORCEMENT
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AFOREMENTIONED BILLS. ALL
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. NEEDED TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY ON BEHALF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. TO THE
PUBLIC ON THEIR SH RESPECTIVE
MISSIONS AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
WITHOUT WE HAVEN'T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SWANSON AT CAL- YES DID
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD. YEAH
THANK YOU SENATOR- I JUST A
MISTER BEST A GREAT JOB IN
SUMMARIZING ALL THE- BCPS IN
FRONT OF YOU WE HAVE ONE SPECIAL
COMPONENT WITH AB FORTY ONE HERE
AT- CALLAWAY S. I GUESS THIS IS
THE BILL TO OBTAIN APPROVAL BUT
LOCAL LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES NEED TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL. FOR A COURT HEARING-
SURPLUS MILITARY EQUIPMENT FROM
THEIR GOVERNOR AND- BODY SUCH AS
A- COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
BOB THIS BILL ESPECIALLY APPLIES
TO US BECAUSE WE HAVE A ROLE IN
OVERSEEING THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORT OFFICE PROGRAM OR THE
TEN THIRTY THREE PROGRAM IS MR
BEST SAID. BOB AND WHAT WE DO IS
WE TAKE- APPLICATIONS FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR WALKING
A BOMB FORCED AGENCIES. TO
ACQUIRE SURPLUS PROPERTY- FROM-
THE U. S. MILITARY AND A LOT OF
THAT PROPERTY IS NOT WHAT YOU
THINK OF THIS TRADITIONAL
MILITARY PROPERTY IT'S OFFICE
EQUIPMENT AND THAT KIND OF THING
AS WELL. SO OFTEN COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS BILL WHICH ASSETS ARE
NOT ONLY THAT THEY GET- OBTAIN
APPROVAL FROM THE GOVERNING BODY
THAT ALSO WAS THAT THEY HOLD A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TRAINING THEY
DO OTHER SORTS OF THINGS WE WERE
GOING TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE-
ENFORCEMENT OF. I TAKES PLACE WE
HAD TO. BUT FOR THE APPLE TO THE
- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I AM
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AS WELL
. M. MISS KRISTEN ELLIOTT YOU
HAVE A COMMENT. WE DO THANK YOU
SO MUCH- THREE DO YOU THINK IT'S
REASONABLE CERTAINLY FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO REQUEST RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT- THOSE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION YOU HEARD ABOUT
THERE ARE SEVERAL AS PART OF A
STAFF PROPOSAL I'M BUT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED SOME INITIAL CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL OF ARE STILL.
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING IT-
SO SPECIFICALLY TO THE- YEAH
COMPONENT- WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT
THE RELEVANT BILL WHICH I'M AS
WAS MENTIONED IS AB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE AND IT REQUIRES LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT MANY AGENCIES TO
OBTAIN APPROVAL FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNING BODY BEFORE ACCEPTING
THE EQUIPMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND IT DOESN'T AS AS
WE READ IT SPECIFICALLY REQUIRE-
YES TO VERIFY THAT THOSE
AGENCIES RECEIVE SUCH AN
APPROVAL SO- AS SUCH IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO US THAT THE PROPOSED
RESOURCES FOR- YES ARE NECESSARY
TO IMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATION. AS
ENVISIONED BY THE LEGISLATURE
I'M ANYBODY HURT THE OTHER
COMPONENTS WERE STILL REVIEWING
THEM AND YOU KNOW AS AS WAS
MENTIONED THERE SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS- COMPARISON THERE
ARE. RECEIVE RESOURCE WORST
REVIEWING THE TO SEE IF REALLY
THAT THE APPROACH THAT APPEARS
THE PURCHASE MAYBE. DIFFERENT
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO FULLY ASSESS
WHETHER THEY'RE TAKING SURVEYS
CONSISTENT APPROACHES. AND THAT
RESOURCES ARE APPROPRIATELY
LIMITED AM ACTING LET IT
TERMINATE CASES WHEN THEY'RE
SHORT TERM WORKLOAD FOR EXAMPLE-
AND SO WELL WILL PROVIDE ANY
FURTHER ANALYSIS WE HAVE- AT
THAT'S AVAILABLE. IF YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA AND THE FOURTEEN
VEHICLES I MEAN I GET THE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
DISCLOSURE OF THE PEOPLE BUT ON
THE FOURTEEN VEHICLES- HE HAVE
ANY. INFORMATION TO HELP US OUT
ON. YEAH AND I THINK THIS IS
EVEN A BROADER I KNOW AT LEAST
ON THE CAL FIRE SIDE THIS IS A
BROADER ISSUE THAT- WE'VE
THOUGHT ABOUT IN THE PAST AS
WELL BECAUSE OFTEN THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW BE A LOT NUMBER
VEHICLES REQUESTED AND THEN AND
ALSO YEAH DGS SHORT TERM AND- WE
SAY THAN EVEN ADVANCE OF THOSE
VEHICLES THAT'S ANOTHER AREA
THAT I THINK WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO YOU- LOOK AT A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT REALLY THEY'RE ALL
AND MERITED BUT IT'S I THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE CERTAINLY WITH
REGARD TO THIS ARE THE ESSENTIAL
CHAMPIONING THESE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS- I THINK
THERE IS- YOU KNOW THE-
EXTENSION. THAT WE'RE AWARE OF
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT-
WE'RE REALLY CAREFUL AND
ALLOCATING AND PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR VEHICLES WILL
CERTAINLY WITH T. THE
PRESENTATION- IN THE STAFF
REPORT IN THE SEEING ALL THE
BILL'S LINED UP TO THE GATHER
AND MONTHLY REPORTING AND THIS
ONE AND FULL DISCLOSURE AT LEAST
AN INTERPRETATION. THAT THERE
MIGHT THROUGH SORT OF A CALL FOR
NECESSARY BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT FOR
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION ON WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO- QUESTIONS ON
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE ON THE
PEACE OFFICERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT- THE LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENTS. THIS IS OUR WORK.
OKAY SEEING THEIR QUEST. WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OVER WE HAVE SCHOOL
WILL COMMUNICATING WITH US THAT
ON THAT. FIELD NOW I WILL. BUT
THOSE ARE ALL THE ISSUES BEFORE
SO LET ME REPEAT FEE. THE ACCESS
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY ONE TWO
THREE THREE AND NOW WILL GO TO-
OUR PUBLIC HEARING WE HAVE
MEMBERS HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE AT THE STATE CAPITOL.
OUR FEWER RECOGNIZED MISMATCH
MAKAYLA. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I ASSUME ONE MINUTE
LIMITATION ON PUBLIC COMMENT
PICK WHAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A
FIRE IF YOU GO ON IF YOU ABUSE
IT I'LL CALL YOU OFF AS A WILL
THE OTHER GENTLEMAN HERE WILL
KEEP IT SHORT WE ARE FREE US OUR
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES WE APPRECIATE. YOUR
LEADERSHIP- AND THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO- LAST YEAR IN
PARTICULAR BUT ON WILD FIRES
FOREST FIRE FUNDING WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM THE
SECRETARY CROWFOOT AND DEPUTY
SECRETARY MORRIS- WERE PLEASED
TO SEE THE FUNDING GOING OUT TO
THOSE PROGRAMS I THINK IT LEADS
TO THE LOGICAL CONCLUSION THAT
WE ACTUALLY NEED MORE FUNDING
AND MORE PROJECTS TO BE DONE
ESPECIALLY IF WE GO AFTER THAT.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES ON
THE STATEWIDE BASIS A MILLION-
TOGETHER WE WOULD NOTE SIMILAR
STATISTICS TO THAT WHICH A
CERTAIN MCGUIRE SAID ABOUT THE
SUBSTANTIAL MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL LOSSES INSURABLE LOSSES
THE AMOUNT OF ACREAGE THAT HAS
BEEN- BURNED REPEATEDLY IT GOES
TO TWO MAIN POINTS I WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THE FIRST IS
THAT. OUR CLIENTS STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ONE PERSON IN CHARGE TO REALLY
FOCUS ATTENTION ON ACHIEVING
THAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND STATE
ACRES BE DONE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
AND HAVE SUBSTANTIAL STATUTORY
AUTHORITY IN SUCH A POSITION THE
OTHER IS I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT- CENTER DALLY
MADE RELATED TO BIOMASS. OUR
ESTIMATES IN CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- TREATED ACRES ANNUALLY
WILL ACTUALLY NEED SOMETHING IN
THE RANGE OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE TO ADDRESS.
THAT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
ZACKS TOURNAMENT THERE'S A
NUMBER MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY
MCHALE WITH ERIN REED ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE FIRST I WANTED
TO MENTION A CERTAIN ACQUIRES
IMPASSIONED SPEECH ABOUT THE
NECESSITY TO ENHANCE STAFFING
FOR FIREFIGHTERS. THAT SPEECH
WHICH WAS SO FIERY WAS ALSO
PROMISED ON THE TRUTH. HE WAS
THERE WHEN CAPTAIN FROM CAL FIRE
MENTIONED THAT SHE AND HER
HUSBAND WHO BOTH WORK FOR CAL
FIRE HAD TO WORK SIXTY STRAIGHT
DAYS LAST SUMMER. AND AS A
RESULT HAD TO BRING THEIR MOTHER
IN TO HELP RAISE THEIR CHILDREN.
THE DEMANDS ON CALIFORNIA THE
LAST FOUR YEARS IT'S BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY ONEROUS AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THEY NEED TO
HELP THEM IS RESONATING ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. PLEASE ALSO
AT THE GOVERNOR SET ASIDE THAT
THAT- FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. AND
WOULD NOTE THAT SECRETARY
CROWFOOT- DID GO TO SPEAK WITH
THE FIREFIGHTERS AND ALSO
PLEDGED HIS SUPPORT IN THAT
ISSUE. THE ONE THING I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE WITH HOWEVER IS TO
NOTE. HOW FIREWORKS. TWO HOURS A
WEEK AS OPPOSED TO FIFTY SIX
HOURS PER OTHER FIREFIGHTERS.
THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS WORK WEEK
IS ALSO A MISNOMER. BECAUSE THEY
MAKE IT ON THE ENGINE THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEVENTY TWO
HOURS. BUT THEY DON'T GET OFF
FOR WEEKS AT A TIME. SO THE IDEA
OF MOVING TO A FIFTY SIX HOUR
WORK WEEK IS BEING RELIEF. WILL
ONLY WORK IF WE HAVE MORE
FIREFIGHTERS THE FIFTY SIX HOUR
CHANGE OBVIOUSLY CANNOT WORK IF
PERSONNEL IS NOT ENHANCED. AGAIN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. X. SIX. GOOD
MORNING TERMINATE CUSTOMERS OF
COMMITTEE PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST I THANK YOU
FOR A ROBUST DISCUSSION EARLIER
ON THE WILDFIRE EXPENDITURE
PROPOSAL AND FOR YOUR PAST AND
FUTURE LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC-
I THINK YOU WERE CORRECT IN THE
PAST WE'VE SUGGESTED A MULTI
YEAR YOU KNOW FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS THAT
SORT OF LEVEL OF ONGOING
COMMITMENT IS WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BRING RESILIENCE BACK TO
THE LANDSCAPE- WHEN. THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW NOW WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE STABLE AND ONGOING
LIKE A FOREST HELTH GRANT
PROGRAM IF THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
WE CAN PREDICT YEAR OVER YEAR
MAKES IT HARD TO BUILD MOMENTUM
IN THAT INDUSTRY SO SOME PLACES
WE'RE GONNA WANNA MAKE THOSE
LONGER TERM COMMITMENTS AND
OTHERS WHERE I THINK WE NEED TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STILL EARLY IN
BEING SET UP. ONE AREA THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO LEAN INTO IS
GETTING MORE GOOD FIRE ON THE
LANDSCAPE PRESCRIBED FIRE
CULTURAL FIRE. AND REALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT FIRES ALWAYS
BEEN PART OF THE LANDSCAPE. THE
PERVERSE OUTCOME OF LEANING TOO
HARD ON SUPPRESSION. IS WERE
SELECTING FOR THE MOST DAMAGING
FIRES. THE FIRES THAT ARE
BURNING UNDER LOWER INTENSITY
UNDER. LESS EXTREME CONDITIONS
QUALIFIERS RIGHT ON. ENORMOUS AN
OUT OF CONTROL. WE CAN CONTROL
THE TIMING. OF PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND WE REALLY NEED TO USE THAT
TO GET. MORE THE LANDSCAPING
THAT RELY CONDITION LAST
OBSERVATION WOULD BE THAT AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT A MILLION ACRES
A YEAR OF HABITAT MODIFICATION
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE
NEED TO INTEGRATE THAT WELL WITH
OUR CLIMATE AND WATER AND
BIODIVERSITY PLANNING AS WELL TO
MAKE SURE GETTING GOOD OUTCOMES
ACROSS THOSE- COMPLEMENTARY
GOALS THE SHOULD BE THE ALL THE
SAME SORTS OF OUTCOMES. AND PART
OF THAT NEEDS TO BE LARGE
CONTIGUOUS BURN A WHOLE
LANDSCAPES WHERE WE'RE THERE ON
FRAGMENTED BY ADDITIONAL
DEVELOPMENT CONVERSION AND A
CONDITION WORK FIRE WOULD NOT BE
CATASTROPHE THE BURNING UNDER
REASONABLE CONDITIONS SO THANK
YOU LITTLE FOLLOWED WITH MORE
DETAILS IN WRITING. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY SO MODERATOR.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE AGAIN OUR
NUMBER TO DATE IS THE CALL IN
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY ONE TWO EIGHT THREE-
THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY. WE WILL
CONFIGURATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO A
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE IN THE PLACE RIGHT BACK
INTO THE QUEUE AGAIN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH- LINE TWENTY EIGHT. MY
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE PREVIOUS AS
SPEAKERS IN THEIR APPRECIATION
EXPRESSING HER APPRECIATION FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S LEADERSHIP ON
WILD HER FUNDING ISSUES THIS IS
JULIE MALINOWSKI BOTTLE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE- THERE'S
SO MUCH THAT THE COURT HERE BUT
A SPECIFICALLY WANT TO CALL OUT
THE- TRANSPORTATION THE BIO MASS
TRANSPORTATION SUBSIDY NO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT ENOUGH
FOR THE FOR THE PROGRAM- BUT IT
IS A PILOT AND I GUARANTEE YOU
IT'LL BE NO REGRETS. MONEY THIS
IS WILL BE SIMPLE TO DEVELOP
IT'LL BE EASY TO PUT OUT AND
THEY'LL BE SUPER EASY TO TRACK
YOU'RE GOING TO COME BACK AND
YOU'RE GONNA DAY THIS IS THE
BEST TEN MILLION DOLLARS WE
SPENT IN THIS IN THE BUDGET- WE
ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE FOURTH FACTORY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT
THIRTY MILLION OVER TWO YEARS WE
KNOW THAT WE JUST COMPLETE LACK-
CREWS- IN THE FLORENCE TAKING
CARE OF THIS MATERIAL AND THIS
PROGRAM. AGAIN MAYBE EVEN THIRTY
MILLION AND THEN AFTER THAT
EITHER- THE PROGRAM IT IS THE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE THAT MATERIAL
AROUND AND OUT FOREST AND WE ASK. FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU NEXT. WELL ALLIANCE
YOU OPEN. I GOOD MORNING RATHER
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU CARE AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS RACHEL HI
THERE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE POOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
SITUATION OF LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORPS MORE BROADLY. AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE PACKAGE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE VERY INVIGORATING
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING AND I
WANTED TO MAKE THE POINT THAT.
WE'RE PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL RESOURCES. TO
THE TTC AND TO THE LOCAL CORD
AROUND THE STATE. OR IF YOU'LL
REDUCTION CREWS BECAUSE THIS IS
THE INVESTMENT THAT WILL ENABLE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WE SERVE AND
THAT WE TRAIN. A PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO THE UNRELENTING RISK
WILDFIRE POSTED CHARGE STATE AND
OUR COMMUNITY- WE- AT EMPLOYEE
THROUGH A PAID JOB TRAINING. A
YOUNG ADULTS AGES EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY SIX AND THIS IS REALLY
THE HEART OF WHAT WE DO IN TERMS
OF FUEL LOAD REDUCTION. AND THE
COURT LOCATED IN WEST OAKLAND SO
WE SERVICE. EAST BAY AND
PORTIONS OF BOTH ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- SO AGAIN
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE. FOR WILD
CARD FOR THREE BILLION. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. WELCOME. SIX
POINT FIFTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BRIAN FENNESSY AND I AM THE FIRE
CHIEF WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
FIRE AUTHORITY AND ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE HIGHER SCHOOL BOARD
OF DIRECTORS I WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE VIRUS PROGRAM. BOB VIRUSES
SYSTEM IN A PROGRAM THAT IS NOT
DUPLICATED BY ANY OTHER AGENCY.
NO OTHER PROGRAM OR AGENCY IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE UNITED STATES
DISPATCHES INFORMATION GATHERING
AIRCRAFT ON INITIAL ATTACK WITH
ALL THE OTHER AIR AND GROUND
RESOURCES. THE RESULT IS RAPID
DISTRIBUTION OF REAL TIME FIRE
PERIMETER MAPS MAP LAYERS TO
PRECISELY DETERMINE AGENCY
JURISDICTION COLOR HIGH
DEFINITION LIVE STREAM VIDEO
INFRARED VIDEO THAT ALLOWS FOR
SEEING TO SMOKE. A UCSD
SUPERCOMPUTER IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE GENERATED FIRE
SPREAD MODEL THAT DEPICTS
STRUCTURES IN LIVES IMMEDIATELY
THREATENED IN THIRTY MINUTE
INCREMENTS. FIRE DISASTER
ASSESSMENT ALL HAZARDS INCIDENT
INFORMATION IS RECEIVED BY
THOUSANDS OF FIREFIGHTERS AND
ALL LEVELS OF DECISION MAKERS IN
REAL TIME. THEY RECEIVE THIS
INFORMATION TODAY ON THEIR
SMARTPHONES TABLETS DESKTOPS AT
CETERA SO USUALLY THIS
INFORMATION THAT A LARGE MONITOR
AT THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
WAS DEDICATED THE FIRES. FEET
LAST YEAR DURING A LARGE FIRES.
GEORGE COUNTY FOR THIRTY
ORIGINALLY PILOT PRO A WIN ON TO
INCLUDE CALLAWAY IN THE PILOT.
FRIEDMAN SUCCESSFULLY CALLAWAY
**** ALL HAZARD EMERGENCY AND
DISASTER APPROACH AS MENTIONED
ON THE CURRENT SURE THE FIRE
SCHOOL BOARD OF DIRECTORS IN IN
IN JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THE
BOARD VOTED TO UNANIMOUSLY
SUPPORT THE VIRUS PROGRAM. AND
HAVE AN INTEREST IN CONTINUING
TO PROVIDE INPUT IN ITS ADVISORY
ROLE TO THE CALLAWAY S.
DIRECTOR. ON BEHALF OF THE FIRES
GO BORDER DIRECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WHICH I'M AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER WE ARE
PLEASED THE CAL FIRE'S EMBRACING
THE TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION
WOULD BE FULLY INTEGRATING VIRUS
INTO ITS EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM. VIRUS IS NOW READY TO BE
USED AS A STATE WIDE ASSET
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA FIRE AND
RESCUE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
STRUCTURE IN IMPLEMENTING THE
RESOURCE SLASH ASSET IS DESIGNED
BY THE SYSTEM BEST FITS WITHIN
CALLAWAY'S ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU CHIEF NEXT.
THANKS FOR ALIGN SIXTY ARE OPEN
. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JENNIFER HEARING
REGARDING ISSUE SEVENTEEN THEM
OUT MY AND FOUNDATIONS THANK THE
FACT THAT ARE RECOMMENDED
SUPPORTING YOU FOR TAKING ACTION
TODAY TO APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE READY CANYON WILDLIFE
CROSSING THIS IS FRESH AND
EXCITING PROJECT AND HOPEFULLY
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
AROUND WHAT'S POSSIBLE FOR
INVESTING IN COSTS IN THE
QUARTER THE COST THE STATE.
BUDGET GREAT FALL TO THE
DEDICATED PARTNERS WHO ARE
MAKING OF THE VISION A REALITY
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
GAME WARDENS AND MANAGERS BUT
THE WHERE ISSUED ONE BUT
APARTMENT WILDLIFE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR WILDLIFE OFFICERS
ARE COMMITTED IMPLEMENTING THE
MANDATE SB TWO SIX EIGHTY THANK
. WE HAVE LIMITED STAFF
RESOURCES TO COMPLY WITH THE MAN
AND ESPECIALLY INCREASE THE
DEMAND FOR THE PARTNER ASK FOR
NOT NOT WITH THE ANY TO THE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AND WE HOPE THAT
THE CAR PROPOSAL WHICH ALLOWS TO
BE BUT MAYBE ANYTHING. YEAH IF
THE COURT THANK. ALL THE TALK
ABOUT FIRE IN THE IMPORTANCE OF.
SUPPORTING OUR FIREFIGHTERS IS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS HAD TO EVACUATE
THREE TIMES- DUE TO WILDFIRE-
BUT I'MHERE TO TALK ABOUT-
NUMBER SEVENTEEN BE LIBERTY
CANYON. WILDLIFE CROSSING TEN
MILLION AND- STAUNCH SUPPORT OF
IT AS MANY OF YOU MIGHT HAVE
GUESSED- BUT I DID WANT TO ADD
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT ENOUGH- IN
SOME OF YOU BROUGHT UP. THE
IMPORTANCE OF ATTENTION TO
NATURAL LANDSCAPES- TO BE MORE
FIRE RESILIENT AND LIBERTY CANON
ALTHOUGH. OBVIOUSLY THE MOUNT
LINE'S GOING EXTINCT IS
SOMETHING WE ARE REALLY TRYING
TO PREVENT. WITHOUT CROSSING
IT'S ALSO ABOUT RESILIENCY OF
ECOSYSTEMS IN THE FACE OF
DROUGHT WILDFIRE AND OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE WE WILL BE
RESTORING NATIVE ECOSYSTEM. TO
THAT AREA AS PART OF LIBERTY
CANYONS- THE CROSSING- IN RIGHT
NOW THE YOU KNOW THE SITE IT'S
FULL OF INVASIVE MUSTARD WILL
ALSO BE PAYING FOR THE
UNDERGROUNDING. OF SOME
ELECTRICAL TRANSMISSION LINES SO
THERE'S A BIG FIRE RESILIENCY
AN FIRE SAFETY COMPONENT TO IT
AS WELL. BUT JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU AND HOPE AND FOR SUPPORTING
ALSO THINK- THE STAFF FOR THE
RECOMMENDED SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUICK ACTION TO
APPROVE THIS TEN MILLION. IS A
PROJECT THAT THE WORLD IS
WATCHING IN THAT WE CAN ALL BE
REALLY PROUD OF IN TERMS OF HOW
TO DO. URBAN WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION RIGHT. I ALSO
BEFORE I LEAVE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY
THANK. SENATOR STERN FOR HIS
ONGOING COMMITMENT AND
LEADERSHIP TO MAKING LIBERTY
CANYON A REALITY. AND HAVE ALL
OF THESE OTHER EFFORTS TO
INCREASE CONNECTIVITY IN
CORRIDORS FOR WILDLIFE ACROSS
THE STATE WE APPRECIATE YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE WANNA REMIND COLORS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE KEEPING- COMMENTS. TWO ONE MINUTE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I LIVE SIX FOUR YOU UP
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RAY GUY CAN THE PHARMACY
FOR ONTARIO FIRE DEPARTMENT AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION JUST
WANT TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE FIRES PROGRAM THIS IS A
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT ASSET
THAT HELPS US IN REAL TIME THE
PLAN TO MITIGATE ALL RISK MULTI
DISCIPLINE EMERGENCY IS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
WOULD LIKE TO TOUCH ON A FEW
MAJOR POINTS TODAY WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE VIRUS PROGRAM
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AND ALSO BE
ENHANCE THE TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS IN
ADDITION WE SUPPORT TO TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN TWO AIRCRAFT MODEL
AND BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
RESIDE IN BE MANAGED AND STATE
WE US. AS AN ALL RISK MODEL TO
HELP ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
ALSO STATE GOVERNMENT- AGENCIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. AND
FINALLY THAT THE- GO COMMITTEE
CONTINUES OUT OF SOME ON THE
PROGRAM. WE JUST REALLY THINK
THIS IS A NON- PER PROGRAM FOR
EVERYTHING- THAT WE'RE DOING IN
THE IN THE WINELANDS AND ALL
RISK A THEATER. AND JUST REALLY
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR OF THE
OPPORTUNISTIC TODAY AND UP. AND
THEN JUST THAT CALCIUM DOES
SUPPORT THE FIRES PROGRAM THANK
YOU. HE NEXT. WE WILL GO TO OUR
LINE SIXTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CAPTAIN FRIEDMAN WITH
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. I'LL BE
BRIEF I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON TWO
ISSUES BUT AS AN OVERARCHING
REMARK WE SUPPORT CONTINUED AN
AGGRESSIVE FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND MANAGEMENT. I
WOULD APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION- I AM ABSOLUTELY I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
I'VE HAD CHALLENGE CONVERSATIONS
ON BIOMASS ABILITY ONLY TO LEARN
THAT THOSE SPEAKING BY
REFERENCING THE PRICKLY VALUE
URBAN FACILITIES. WE KNOW THAT
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL THIS IS A
DIVERSITY GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
ECOLOGICALLY AND TRUCKING WASTE
FROM LAST AND DEL NOR. EVEN
HUNDREDS OF MILES THE ONLY
REMAINING BY- AT LEAST MAYBE
THAT'LL JERRY IN THE SHORT RUN
BUT LET'S KEEP OUR EYES ON THOSE
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. WE NEED TO
WORK O REGIONAL BY ABOUT
POLLUTION IN OUR UPPER WATERSHED
AREAS ACROSS REGULATORY
BOUNDARIES OF AIRBOARD ENERGY
PROCUREMENT AND INDUSTRY. AND
THEN SECOND I LIKE A SMALL
ISSUE- ON PAGE THIRTY SEVEN OF
YOUR AGENDA WE JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PRE AND POST
WILDFIRE HAZARD HAZARD
IDENTIFICATION. WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT FUNDINGFOR IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE WATERSHED
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. TEAM WORKS
PROGRAM. MY CONSERVATION.
PROGRAM COMES AND THAT. WILDFIRE
IMMEDIATELY THE COUNCIL FOR AND
ALLOW STATE AND STATE TO TARGET
. SPECIFICALLY MECHANISM. FOR
THE INEVITABLE FLAT AND I'M SURE
REVERTING. IT'S JUST. SO I WANT
TO THANK COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
CAR. TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU. THANK
NEXT. THANKS NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KIM
DELFINO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THE NORMAL
LAND TRUST AND CAL WHILE WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THEIR FIRE BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND- A RLATIVE TO ISSUE
NINETEEN I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
TWO POINTS. FIRST WE NEED TO
INCREASE PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
A WELFARE PACKAGE ALONG THE LINE
THAT. THAT THE CHAIR YOU THINK
JEFF DID A BILLION OVER- EACH
OVER FIVE YEARS IN PARTICULAR WE
NEED TO INCREASE INVESTMENTS AND-PRESCRIBED FIRE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS SUCH AS THOSE FUNDED BY
THE FOURTH LEGACY PROGRAM AND W.
C. B. CAPACITY BUILDING FOR
TRIBES RCTS LANDRAT AND OTHER
PARTNERS AND CLIENTS
PARTICULARLY FINISHING THE FIND
SKILLED EDUCATION MAPPING FOR
THE STATE. SECOND I'D LIKE TO-
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THE LEGISLATURE FOCUS ON
IMPROVING MONITORING AND
EVALUATION OF THE MARION OF
BOARD AND FIRE PREVENTION
PROGRAM PROJECTS NOT ONLY TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE COST
EFFECTIVE WHICH IS SOMETHING THE
ONLY- POINTED OUT BUT ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE NOT HAVING
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. SUCH AS
RESULTING IN HIGH CONVERSION
HABITAT DESTRUCTION AND
DEGRADATION OF WATER QUALITY
THAT'S BACK IN MONITORING AND
EVALUATION IS NOT HAPPENING
BEYOND THE ASSESSMENT OF CARBON
REDUCTION AND IT'S KIND OF CRAZY
TO BE INVESTING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND NOT CONDUCTING
MONITORING AND EVALUATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS OTHER GOALS
TO JUST THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
BIODIVERSITY. PROTECTION THANK
YOU. Q. NECK. WE WILL SEVEN ONE
YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY
HEATON FROM NINE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THIRTY EIGHT COUNTY
BOROUGH COUNTY STATEWIDE I FIRST
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
CATHERINE FRIEDMAN FROM
DESEGREGATING CAN'T BE- PROPOSAL
FOR BIOMASS TRANSPORTATION
SUBSIDY. ONE OF THE TOPPINGS WE
HEAR FROM OUR MEMBER COUNTIES IS
THE NEED TO JUMPSTART BIOMASS IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP REMOVE THE
DEAD NINE MATERIALS FROM THE
FOREST TO HELP WITH FOREST
RESTORATION AND FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND PILING IN BURNING
NEED MATERIALS IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT IDEAL AND CERTAINLY NOT THE
PATH THAT WE FEEL WE NEED TO
CONTINUE GOING DOWN SO. WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THERE
ALTHOUGH I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
THAT WE WOULD ASK THE COURT AND
I HOPE THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
CONVERSATION AROUND EITHER SOME
BLOCK GRANTS FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL
COUNTIES THAT ARE SEEKING. A
GRANT FOR SOME OF THE FOREST
RESTORATION COMMUNITY FIRE
PREVENTION MITIGATION AND
HARDENING PROGRAM PAUL COUNTY
SUCH AS ALPINE SIERRA AND OTHERS
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THE
STAFF OR REALLY THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO COMPETE WITH SOME
OF THE LARGER COUNTIES THAT ARE
ALSO PLAYING IN THE SAME SPACE.
AND IT'S ALSO ONE OF THE
TOPPINGS WE HEAR FROM OUR
COUNTIES IS THAT THEY NEED THIS
ASSISTANCE OR JUST BLOCK GRANTS
TO HELP TO GET THESE RESOURCES
OUT TO THEIR RESIDENCE AND SO WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE MORE
DISCUSSION. AROUND THIS TO HELP
THESE. SMALL NORTH STATE
COUNTIES THAT DON'T THOSE RIGHT
. THANK YOU. MAX PIXIV LINES TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE WATERSHED
RESEARCH AND TRAINING CENTER AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS.
ON ISSUE NINETEEN WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS A BASELINE OF WHAT
SHOULD BE SPENT ON WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE BUT AFTER THE
COMMENTS OF YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SUBCOMMITTEE IN PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS THAT WE NEED A MORE
ROBUST AND AGGRESSIVE MULTI YEAR
PLAN FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE. WE
OF COURSE NEED MORE FOR FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECTS AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS LIKE A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER AND I STRESS THE WORD
AND WE ALSO REALLY NEED TO BE
WRAPPING UP OUR INVESTMENT IN
NON VEGETATION PROGRAMS ALONG
THE LINES OF WHAT CENTER STERN
WAS REALLY CALLING OUT. WHEN YOU
SEE MORE. READY MEDICAL.
RESILIENCE YOU HAVE TO HAVE. AND
UNLESS WE LIKE THE REGISTERS
SUPPORT FOR ONGOING FUNDING FOR
OUR REGION FORESTER PART AFTER
THE- WE'RE REALLY SEEING THIS TO
THE AND NOW THAT IT TELL A
CRITICAL NEED FOR PROJECT
PLANNING AND REGIONAL PRAYER
TAKE TO PASS THE THANK THIS SUB
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP GETTING
PROGRAM WELL FUND IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELCOME NEXT. ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DOUG
HOUSTON RECORD THAN EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT THAT THE
DISTRICT COURT TO EXPRESS ITS
GRATITUDE FOR THE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE COLLABORATIVELY
AGREE TO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. IN
THE FOREST HEALTH WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SPACE. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION FOR ADDED FUNDING
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR
PEOPLE'S MANAGEMENT PARTICULARLY
IN URBAN AREAS. THE CHAIRS
KEENLY AWARE DISTRICT WITNESSING
AN UNPRECEDENTED DROUGHT CLIMATE
BOARD OR TREE DIE OFF WHETHER TO
PUT A PROPERTIES. WE'RE NOT
ALONE. UPWARDS OF ABOUT POINT
MILLION TREES HAVE BEEN I. THE
MOBILE WITH THE DESK. AND WHILE
SPIRITUAL PART SPENDS ROUGHLY
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION IN ONE
ANNUALLY RATHER KÞT. MATERIALS
IT MAKES IN THIS AREA FOR INTO
SUCH AS THE PARK DISTRICT. GO
FOR CELEBRATE EIGHT SCALE THE
CRITICAL WORK NEXT TO THE D.
THREE AND- SOME CAL MOST FOR.
AND. THANK YOU. THAT THANKS FIVE
YOUR OPEN. I THANK YOU THIS IS
PATRICK WELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA UTILITY AND
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING PUBLIC
POWER AND PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE- ACCORDING TO
THE BOARD THAT YOU POP PROGRAMS
ON WHAT WASTE- THE BIOMASS.
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND THE
OTHER PROGRAMMING OPR TO DEVELOP
WOULD BE- AND MARKET FOR WHAT HE
WAIT. WE SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS
LIKE OTHERS WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT
MORE ADDED TO THEM IN TERMS OF
FUNDING I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE. APPEAR LIMITED TO POST
FIRE CLEANUP- SHE MADE MEMBERS
ARE ACTIVELY UNDERTAKING WATER
MITIGATION PROJECTS THAT RESULT
IN SEPTEMBER AND OTHER WHAT THE
MATERIAL THAT ARE NOT PROJECTS
RELATED OF SPARKING UP- WE THINK
THAT PROGRAM SHOULD LOOK AT
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM TO.
INCLUDE WHEN HE WAITS FOR BE
TAPPED A PROACTIVE BALLPARK
ISSUE PROJECTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANKS THE NEXT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE- SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARES SENATORS
GOOD DAY J. HOWEVER MY COUNTY
FIRE CHIEF FROM REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF CAL FIRE CONTRACT
COUNTY. QUOTING THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE LOS ANGELES VENTURA KERN
SANTA BARBARA MORAN. INTERVIEW
LEADERSHIP SURROUNDING BARBARA
PROTECTION STATEWIDE AS PART OF
THE STATE WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
THE CONTRACT COUNTY CREWS AND
REALIGNMENT ECP IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
ENSURING BOTH PRE FIRE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. AND
ADDRESS PARKING REDUCTION CAN BE
COMPLETED WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
INCREASING THE STATEWIDE
AVAILABILITY OF FIRE CREWS
RESPOND. YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ON TRACK
COUNTY BCPS. GREATLY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. THANK FINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YES HELLO
THIS IS ERIC CARLSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CONTRACT COUNTIES- BACKING UP
THE TESTIMONY OF CHIEF JUDGE
HOWEVER- CHAIR- THESE COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT SUPPORT THE FOR
THE- OZELL TO EXPAND HAND CREWS.
SPECIFICALLY TO- CREWS
IMPLEMENTED OVER TWO YEARS FOR
FIELD REDUCTION EDUCATION
MANAGEMENT HAS A SCHOOL
PRODUCTION AND WHILE THEM FIRE
PREVENTION IN THE CONTRACT
COUNTIES FOR THE STATE ON A
SURVEILLANCE THANK YOU. YOU NEXT
. THANK YOU AYE AS A FINAL
REMINDER ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
KELP FOREST HEALTH FOREST
APPRECIATE THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION COURSE RESILIENCY
PROPOSAL IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUT WELL SUPPORTIVE OF
THESE MEASURED CALIFORNIA HOW
FOURTH BELIEVES THAT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS ARE NECESSARY TO
IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH. THE
COLLEAGUES REQUESTED FUNDING FOR
MORE HAND CREWS AS THE PROPOSAL
FALLS SHORT IN A TO WHAT'S
NECESSARY. FOR ADEQUATELY
RESPONDING DURING FIRES AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE NECESSARY SKILL
MANAGEMENT WORK CAN BE COMPLETED
DURING THE OFF THE BENCH AND
SECONDLY CAL FOR ITS REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE INCREASE THE FUNDING
FOR BIOMASS TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM AND AS YOU KNOW THE
ACCUMULATION OF WOODY MATERIAL
GENERATE GENERATED THROUGH THE
FOREST MANAGEMENT PROJECTS IN
POST FIRE RECOVERY. IT'S A
GROWING PROBLEM IN THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU NEXT.
FIVE SEVEN NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
- GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS ABIGAIL MILE ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY I'M CALLING IN REGARDS
TO ISSUE SEVENTEEN DELIVER
KICKED LIBERTY CANYON WILDLIFE
CROSSING WE APPRECIATE THE
STATE'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
EXCITING PROJECT FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE THIS ITEM. SEPARATELY ON
BEHALF OF THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
BUT POTENTIAL REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND NUMEROUS
OTHER CONSERVATION GROUPS
DEDICATED TO WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
FACILITATING THE IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION TODAY AROUND
IMPORTANT ISSUES. A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE WE COLLECTIVELY
EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
IN THIS PACKAGE IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO BE PROACTIVE
IN FUNDING WILDFIRE PREVENTION
WORK AND ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE
HILLS REDUCTION ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING BIOMASS REMOVAL AGAIN
WE SUPPORT THESE INVESTMENTS IN
THE WILDFIRE COURSE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE AND ENCOURAGE CONTINUED
FUNDING FOR THE INCLUDED.
PROGRAMS MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NECKS. I NEEDED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS BRENDAN
A COMA AFTER THE TOP POLICE
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOC.
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS FROM ALL THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS. STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED BUDGET
FUNDING OF TWO MILLION EACH YEAR
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE AND THEN TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY FOUR FOR CONTINUANCE OF
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROGRAM WHICH IS
HELPING TO MEET THE GOAL OF
TRAINING ONE MILLION ACRES OF
VEGETATION ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS IDENTIFIED
IN THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW YOU I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AS
WILDFIRES AND TO BECOME MORE
COMMON AND SEVERE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRE SMOKE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC HEALTH IS AN
AREA THAT'S REQUIRING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ATTENTION FOR
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS- HOWEVER DUE
TO THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR THIS
ACTIVITY. AND RESTRICTIONS ON
HOW LOCAL COMING CAN BE USED
THEIR DISTRICTS ARE LIMITED IN
THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES AND SYSTEMS
TO DO THE JOB THE NEW BUDGET
APPROPRIATION FOR OUR DISTRICT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE RELATED
FINDING ALLOWS TO PROVIDE AIR
DISTRICT STAFF AND THE MANAGERS
OF SMOKE MANAGEMENT TRAINING.
ALSO INCREASES THE ABILITY OF
PUBLIC ACCESS AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THEIR MONITOR AND AIR QUALITY
SENSOR DATA AND USE THAT SUCH AS
PURPLE AIR MONITORS SENSORS AND
THEN PROVIDE HOME FILTRATION
DEVICES FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
CREATE CLEAN ROOMS. DURING SMOKE
EVENTS. FURTHER ADDITIONAL-
WOULD ENABLE US TO AND SPOKE OUT
CORD H. COORDINATORS THAT WOULD
. ON CORE. WITH OUR STAY AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO MONITOR
SMOKING TO ACTIVE OUTSIDE VINCE
AND THE SMOKE OUR QUARTERLY.
WITH RESPONSIBLE FOR-
COORDINATING PUBLIC OUR TO
PEOPLE. OF HAZARDOUS CAN. AND
THEN PU BY ON A PER RISK. WE
THE- TO WITH YOUR THIS AND ISSUE
AND EXCELLING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
MAX. MISTER JERRY OF NORTHERN.
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD
WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS- WE
HAVE- ONCE AGAIN ISSUES WANTING
TO BE REMOVED FROM THE VOTING
CALENDAR WILL BE HEARD AT A
LATER DATE- CENTER DOLLY DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUES THREE
THROUGH SEVEN. NINE AND TEN
TWELVE THROUGH SIXTEEN IN ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR DOLLY. MS
RIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AYE
CASKEY HI ALI MCGUIRE TURN WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FIFTY PEERS
HAVE ENOUGH VOTES- SEN REQUIRED
WE HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUES
NUMBER EIGHT ELEVEN AND
SEVENTEEN. THURMOND THERE'S A
MOTION BY A MCGUIRE MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I CASKEY
HI HOW ARE YOU. MCGUIRE STERN TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER
STERN N. OF FOR THAT VOTE I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATE IN THIS ROBUST
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY WE ARE
WE'RE THAT IF YOU DID NOT CAN
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
COMMITTEE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AS WE I WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE THAT- THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE'LL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN. UNTIL CENTER STIRRED
RETURNS- BUT OTHERWISE WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR BUSINESS. KOK.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.
WE'RE
BACK ON THE RECORD- THIS IS THE
MOTION BY SENATOR DOLLY ON
ISSUES THREE THROUGH SEVEN NINE
AND TEN TWELVE THROUGH FOURTEEN
AND ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN MISS
ROY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT FIVE COLUSA
ROTEL EVOKE THE I SEVEN FOUR
ZERO- THE BY THE MOTION BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ISSUES EIGHT
ELEVEN AND SEVENTEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EARN CLOSE
REAL TITLE SEE I SEVEN THREE
ZERO THIS WILL CONCLUDE THE WORK
OF SUBCOMMITTEE- TWO OF FISCAL
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW.